SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER, IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COULD COME TO ROOM
2100 SO WE COULD ESTABLISH A
QUORUM THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED
. AND WE HAVE 17 BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA AND SIX BILLS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT, BILLS WILL
BE HEARD IN FILE ORDER. OTHER
THEN WE WILL MAKE AN EXCEPTION
FOR THE SPEAKER EMERITUS, WHO
HAS A FLIGHT TO CATCH IN A
LITTLE BIT, SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM, WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
IN SUBCOMMITTEE AND ESTABLISH
QUORUM WHEN WE HAVE THE
SUFFICIENT, MEMBERSHIP, SO WE'LL
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR SPEAKER
EMERITUS, RENDON, YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL AB. 20 2285
THANK YOU, MR. MR. CHAIR, THANK
YOU FOR BEING SO ACCOMMODATING.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE THREE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THANK
YOU. SO NOTED. YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER AB 2285 ENCOURAGES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN ITS LAND
CONSERVATION EFFORTS TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAKING SOME INVESTMENTS IN
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED URBAN
COMMUNITIES UNDERSTANDABLE. Kò
THE PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE IN
REACHING LAND CONSERVATION GOALS
IS INVESTMENTS IN RURAL AND
SUBURBAN AREAS WHERE LAND IS
ATTAINABLE AND AFFORDABLE. WHILE
IT IS IMPORTANT TO CONSERVE
THOSE LANDS AS THE STATE WORKS
TO REACH ITS 3030 GOALS, IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO CONSERVE LANDS
IN HIGHLY URBANIZED,
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS,
BRINGING NATURE TO PEOPLE AND
THE REWILDING OF URBAN AREAS, TO
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE, SHOULD BE A
CO-EQUAL GOAL THAT WE EMBRACE.
THIS BILL BINDS US TO THAT
COMMITMENT. THIS BILL ASKS US TO
RECONCILE AND BALANCE FUNDING
AND POLICY DECISIONS AS THEY
RELATE TO OUR ACTIONS, TO
PROTECT, CONSERVE AND RESTORE
NATURE IN ALL SETTINGS. WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS DOUG HOUSTON,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PARKS AND RECREATION SOCIETY,
YOU JUST HAVE ONE WITNESS. YES
ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES, IF YOU LIKE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. YEAH. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBER
DOUG HOUSTON, REPRESENTING THE
4000 PLUS MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARK AND RECREATION
SOCIETY. AND WE'RE ASKING YOU
FOR YOUR FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BILL. SO AB 2285 IS
TAKING ITS CUE FROM THE FINDINGS
OF THE FIRST PARTNERS OUTDOORS
FOR ALL INITIATIVE, AND THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ELEVATE THE
AWARENESS AROUND THE IMPORTANCE
OF CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
REDUCING NATURE POVERTY IN OUR
URBAN AREAS AND THE OPERATIONAL
PREMISE ASSOCIATED WITH 2285 IS
HOW WE AS A STATE CAN BEST
INVEST IN BRINGING NATURE TO
PEOPLE SO, ALONG WITH AMPLIFYING
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF OUTDOORS
FOR ALL, AB 2285 IS A STATEMENT
BILL ENCOURAGING POLICYMAKERS TO
BE MINDFUL OF BALANCING POLICY
AND BUDGETARY DECISIONS RELATING
TO INVESTMENTS IN THE PROTECTION
, GREENING AND REWILDING OF
LANDS AT OUR STATE. AND WE'RE
ASKING FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WITH ME? TWO
TESTIMONY, SIR, IF YOU COULD
JUST MOVE ASIDE SO THAT OTHERS
MIGHT EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL, PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY FOR THIS. FOR YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. SORRY. THAT WAS THE
MEAT SECTION. YEAH. THIS. ME
TWO. OH, GREAT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MARCHESE, ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI THERE.
MEGAN MEKELBURG HERE. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION, THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CAUSE SEMPERVIRENS
FUND, AND THE EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DO
WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? NO ONE. ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
ONE IN THE ROOM, WE'LL GO BACK
TO THE MEMBERS HERE. I SEE A
QUESTION FROM SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU. I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS, FIRST IS, IT'S
GREAT TO SEE YOU BECAUSE I HAD
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL IN
JUDICIARY LAST WEEK ON.
ABSOLUTELY YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU, I HAD A LOT OF FUN,
NOT KNOWING YOUR BILL AT ALL.
AND THEN PRESENTING IT. AND SO
WHEN I GOT THE QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT'S THE URGENCY WITH THIS
BILL, I SAID THE MEMBERS TERMED
OUT, THIS HAS TO BE DONE BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. SO I WAS DOING
MY BEST, THE OTHER COMMENT IS,
IS, I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
BILL. AND IN THE PROBLEM THAT
HAS EXISTED IS 30 BY 30 WAS
FLOATED AND THERE WAS NO FLESH
PUT TO IT. I EARNED THE IRE OF
MY SUCCESSOR BY REFERRING TO 30
BY 30 AS LIKE PAT ON SATURDAY
NIGHT LIVE. EVERY TIME YOU START
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS, IT
SLIPS OUT OF YOUR HAND. AND IT
IS. BILLS LIKE THIS S THAT START
TO DESCRIBE IT AND PUT MEANING
TO IT. I THINK IT'S GREAT. I'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING IT WHEN
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR PADILLA. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO WEIGH IN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES. THANK YOU. SO WE'LL
HEAR THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. VOTE THE BILL, APPROPRIATE
TIME WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SPEAKER
EMERITUS SENATORS, DO WE HAVE
ANY? I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS IS IN THE ROOM WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 1284. YOU
CAN PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. ASSEMBLYMAN. WELL, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS,
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT, AB
1284, AND I WOULD LIKE TO START
OFF WITH ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, AB 2084, A BILL THAT
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO
ENTER INTO CO-MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS WITH CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES.
CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE PEOPLE HAVE
A SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LAND AND WATERS OF THIS LAND.
FOR CENTURIES, AS CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE HAVE CARED AND
NURTURED THESE LANDS AS THEY
HAVE BEEN CONTINUING TO BE A
MAJOR SOURCE OF SUBSTANCE IN OUR
FOUNDATIONAL PARTS OF THE
CULTURE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FROM THE FOREST TO
THE RIVERS, EACH OF THESE
NATURAL RESOURCES HAVE A DEEP
CONNECTION TO THE CULTURAL
IDENTITY OF TRIBES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT IS WHY
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT TRIBES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE ARE BROUGHT
TO THE TABLE TO HELP TACKLE SOME
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT ECOLOGICAL
CHALLENGES THREATENING OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND THEIR HOMELANDS.
TODAY, THE STATE HAS ALREADY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AS DEMONSTRATED BY
THE STEPS IT HAS TAKEN TO SEEK
GREATER COOPERATION WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGH CONSULTATION
AND COLLABORATION. IT HAS ALSO
COMMITTED TO CORRECTING
HISTORICAL WRONGS THROUGH
SUPPORTING REPARATION EFFORTS
AND ENSURING THAT OUR SCHOOL
BEGAN TO TELL THE TRUE HISTORY
OF CALIFORNIA. FIRST, PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL WOULD TAKE THIS
RELATIONSHIP A STEP FURTHER AND
ALLOW THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY TO ENTER INTO GOVERNMENT,
TO GOVERNMENT AGREEMENTS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF POLICY IN REGARDS
TO THE MANAGEMENT OF NATURAL
RESOURCES THAT SOVEREIGN TRIBAL
LANDS AND ANCESTRAL LANDS.
HOWEVER, I DO NEED TO STRESS
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT INTEND
TO AFFECT ANY WATER RIGHTS. THIS
BILL AGAIN DOES NOT INTEND TO
AFFECT ANY WATER RIGHTS. THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO ENCOURAGE
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN GOVERNMENTS
FOR THE MANAGEMENT AND
CONSERVATION OF OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES THROUGH CO-GOVERNANCE
AND CO-MANAGEMENT AGREEMENTS,
AND CLARIFIES THAT THE SECRETARY
OF CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY IS THE AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE STATE TO
ENTER SAID AGREEMENTS. WHILE WE
HOPE THIS BILL WILL HELP OUR
STATE BECOME BETTER STEWARDS OF
OUR OWN LAND, THAT CONTINUES TO
BE CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE'S
LAND, IT IS IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL
ULTIMATELY AIMS TO ENSURE THE
SURVIVAL OF TRIBES. HISTORICAL
CULTURAL AND SPIRITUAL SITES FOR
YEARS TO COME. WITH ME TODAY IS
COUNCIL MEMBER KENDRA JONES FROM
THE PUYALLUP TRIBE OF YUROK.
PEOPLE AND COUNCIL MEMBER JAY
STEINRUCK OF THE TOLOWA DINÉ
NATION. WITH ME HERE IS ALSO
MEGAN ROCHA, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE TRIBE THAT WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
JUST AS A MATTER OF PRACTICE, WE
WILL LIMIT TESTIMONY TO TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS. HIÂU Kò.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN MIN AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS KENDRA
JONES. I'M A COUNCIL MEMBER OF
THE POLITICAL TRIBE OF YUROK
PEOPLE, FORMERLY RESIGHINI
RANCHERIA. OUR RESERVATION IS
LOCATED IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
NEAR THE MOUTH OF THE KLAMATH
RIVER, AND WE HAVE A LARGER
ANCESTRAL TERRITORY ALONG THE
LOWER KLAMATH RIVER AND PACIFIC
COAST FROM NORTH OF KLAMATH TO
LITTLE RIVER. WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB 1284, AND I AM HERE
TODAY TO SHARE SOME KEY REASONS
WHY THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT.
AS TRIBAL PEOPLE, WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBLE K¾T TO PROTECT AND
STEWARD OUR LANDS AND WATERS.
UNFORTUNATELY COLONIZATION HAS
PREVENTED US FROM FULLY
UPHOLDING OUR RESPONSIBILITY. WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL HELP
RIGHT SOME PAST HISTORICAL
WRONGS. IF ENACTED, IT WILL
CREATE A CLEAR PATH FOR TRUE
CO-GOVERNANCE AND CO-MANAGEMENT
OF ANCESTRAL LANDS AND WATERS.
TRIBES HAVE THOUSANDS OF YEARS
OF STEWARDSHIP KNOWLEDGE THAT
SUPPORTS THE BIODIVERSITY,
CONSERVATION AND ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT. WE BELIEVE TRIBAL
STATE PARTNERSHIPS BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AB 1284 WILL ALSO
RESTORE TRIBAL CONNECTIONS TO
ANCESTRAL LANDS AND WATERS. IT
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT OUR TRADITIONAL
KNOWLEDGE, TO INCREASE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TO PROTECT
CULTURAL RESOURCES AND SACRED
SITES. ULTIMATELY, AB 1284
CREATES THE SPACE FOR TRIBAL
PEOPLE TO BE WHO WE ARE, TO
RECLAIM OUR RIGHTFUL
RESPONSIBILITY AND TAKE CARE OF
OUR PLACES. IN THE FALL OF 2023,
OUR TRIBE, ALONG WITH THE TALOID
DENE NATION AND TRINIDAD
RANCHERIA, DESIGNATED UNDER OUR
SOVEREIGN AUTHORITY THE FIRST
INDIGENOUS MARINE STEWARDSHIP
AREA IN THE US. THIS IMSA IS
LOCATED IN SHARED STATE WATERS.
WE DID THIS DELIBERATELY AND
WITH THE INTENTION OF ENTERING
INTO FUTURE CO-MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS WITH THE RESOURCES
AGENCY AND TO HELP THEM MEET 30
BY 30 CLIMATE GOALS. WHILE THE
AGENCY WEIGHS WHAT THIS MEANS
FOR THEM, WE SIT READY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO PROTECT OUR OCEAN
AND COASTAL RESOURCES. THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS DEVELOPED
POLICIES THAT SEEK TO HONOR AND
UPHOLD TRIBAL STEWARDSHIP AND
CULTURAL LIFEWAYS. AB 1284
ENSURES THAT THOSE POLICIES
ENDURE FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS.
THANK YOU AND WE URGE YOU TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD. THANK
YOU. AGUIAR-CURRY HONORABLE
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
DELEON JTC STEINORTH. I'M A
COUNCIL MEMBER OF THE TOLOWA
NATION, CO-SPONSOR OF AB 1284.
WE ARE HEADQUARTERED IN SMITH
RIVER NEAR THE OREGON BORDER.
I'M HERE TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB 1284. IT SERVES
AS A CATALYST FOR TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP, ESPECIALLY FOR THE
EFFORTS PUT FORTH BY THE YUROK,
TOLOWA INDIGENOUS MARINE
STEWARDSHIP AREA I MSA AND THE
TRIBAL MARINE STEWARDS STEWARDS
NETWORK TWM SION. BY RECOGNIZING
THE RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITY OF
TRIBAL NATIONS IN MANAGING OUR
ANCESTRAL LANDS AND WATERS AS WE
HAVE DONE SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL,
THIS BILL LAYS THE GROUNDWORK
FOR MEANINGFUL PARTNERSHIPS THAT
HONOR INDIGENOUS KNOWLEDGE BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE UNIQUE
CULTURAL, SPIRITUAL, AND
ENVIRONMENTAL INTERESTS OF
TRIBAL NATIONS. THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE IMSA
SIGNIFIES A PROFOUND COMMITMENT
BETWEEN OUR TRIBAL NATIONS TO
PROTECT AND PRESERVE COASTAL AND
MARINE ECOSYSTEMS. AB 1284
OFFERS VITAL SUPPORT FOR THIS
ENDEAVOR BY ENCOURAGING
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGH
CO-GOVERNANCE AND CO-MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS FACILITATED BY THIS
BILL, CALIFORNIA CAN FURTHER
ENHANCE THE ASSERTION OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND ENSURE THAT
TRIBAL NATIONS HAVE MEANINGFUL
INVOLVEMENT IN THE MANAGEMENT OF
OUR ANCESTRAL TERRITORIES.
TRIBAL NATIONS AND GROUPS LIKE
THE CMSN, A COALITION OF TRIBAL
NATIONS DEDICATED TO MARINE
CONSERVATION, STAND TO BENEFIT
GREATLY FROM THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL BY FOSTERING
COLLABORATION AMONG MEMBER
TRIBES AND WITH STATE PARTNERS.
THIS LEGISLATION STRENGTHENS
TRIBAL LED INITIATIVES AIMED TO
BUILD RESILIENCE AND PROMOTE
SUSTAINABLE MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
. AB 1284 IS MORE THAN JUST A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. IT IS A
TESTAMENT TO CALIFORNIA'S
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO HONOR
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AND PROMOTE
AND PROMOTE TRIBAL
SELF-DETERMINATION. THE ÓRDENES
NATION URGES YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AS IT ALIGNS WITH THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF
JUSTICE, EQUITY AND RESPECT FOR
INDIGENOUS RIGHTS SHOULD SHINE
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
FOR THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM MEAN TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
? GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS. JENNIFER FEARING, ON
BEHALF OF THE PEW CHARITABLE
TRUST AND OCEAN CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, RICO
MASTRODONATO WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, LILY SCURRIA ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS. PAT MORAN WITH AARON
REED AND ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE FEDERATED INDIANS OF GRATON
RANCHERIA AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, MEGAN MEKELBURG, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION, SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE, AND THE SEMPERVIRENS
FUND IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
PAMELA LOPEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
TULE RIVER TRIBE, A LAND
CO-MANAGEMENT TRIBE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
DIVYANSH AGARWAL FROM THE JUNIOR
PHILANTHROPISTS FOUNDATION AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. DANIEL. BRAD, ON
BEHALF OF THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. MY AIR OF. GOOD MORNING.
KENNETH BRINK, VICE CHAIRMAN
FROM KARUK TRIBE AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO MORE ME TOS, DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? JUST ONE. DO WE HAVE
ONE? ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE UP TO
FOUR MINUTES, SIR. CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. BOB
REEB WITH REEB GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF THE
VALLEY WATER COALITION
REPRESENTING 40 AGRICULTURAL
WATER SUPPLIERS THAT DELIVER
FARM WATER SUPPLIES THROUGHOUT
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. OUR
CLIENT DOESN'T OBJECT TO
GOVERNMENT, TO GOVERNMENT
CONSULTATION BETWEEN STATE
AGENCIES AND FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES. AND I WILL
START OFF BY INDICATING THAT WE
DID HAVE A GOOD MEETING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON. I THINK WE HAVE A
PATH FORWARD TO WHERE WE WILL BE
ABLE TO REMOVE OPPOSITION. I'M
HOPEFUL TO THAT POINT, BUT I DID
WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT THAT
WE BELIEVE THE BILL IS
INCONSISTENT WITH GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S STATEMENT OF
ADMINISTRATION POLICY ON NATIVE
AMERICAN ANCESTRAL LANDS. THAT
POLICY FOCUSES ON CO-MANAGEMENT
OF AND ACCESS TO NATURAL LANDS
THAT ARE WITHIN THE TRIBE'S
ANCESTRAL LAND AND UNDER THE
OWNERSHIP AND CONTROL OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE POLICY
ALSO FOCUSES ON WORKING
COOPERATIVELY WITH TRIBES TO
ACQUIRE NATURAL LANDS THAT ARE
IN EXCESS OF STATE NEEDS. THE
ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS OF THAT
POLICY HAVE BEEN CODIFIED IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE, WHICH AGAIN
ONLY SPEAKS TO WORKING
COOPERATIVELY WITH TRIBES THAT
HAVE ANCESTRAL TERRITORY WITHIN
STATE OWNED LANDS. NOW, THE BILL
ALSO REFERENCES THE STATE'S 3030
INITIATIVE, WHICH IS FOCUSED ON
LAND AND COASTAL WATERS. THE
INITIATIVE DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
CONSERVATION OF INLAND WATERS.
WHILE IT'S TRUE THAT ACTIONS
DESCRIBED IN THE PATHWAYS REPORT
3030 REPORT THAT INCLUDES
ACTIONS TO IMPROVE WATER QUALITY
AND ECOSYSTEM HEALTH, THE LATTER
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH ACTIONS ON
WORKING AND NATURAL LANDS. SO
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
DIFFERS SIGNIFICANTLY FROM
POLICIES AND STATUTES BY ADDING
WATERS THAT ARE WITHIN A
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
ANCESTRAL TERRITORY, AND BY
ADDING CO-GOVERNANCE OF BOTH
LANDS AND WATERS. AS THIS
COMMITTEE WELL KNOWS, THE
REGULATION OF AND ENFORCEMENT OF
WATER SUPPLY IN CALIFORNIA IS
THROUGH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD, WHICH
LIES WITHIN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY. WHILE THE
AMENDMENT THAT LIMITS THIS TO
AREAS OF JURISDICTION IN THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES IS
WELCOME, IT DOES STILL INCLUDE
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND THE STATE WATER
PROJECT, WHICH PROVIDES WATER
SUPPLY TO 27 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS AND MILLIONS OF
ACRES OF FARMLAND. SO AGAIN, WE
MET YESTERDAY, AND I THINK THE
PATH FORWARD ON THIS BILL MAY
REST WITH INCLUDING SAVINGS,
LANGUAGE SIMILAR TO THAT WHICH
WAS INCLUDED IN THE DELTA REFORM
ACT OF 2009, THAT ENSURES THAT
THE AGREEMENTS THAT THE STATE
ENTERS INTO WILL NOT INTERFERE
OR ALTER EXISTING WATER RIGHTS.
SO WE'LL WE'LL WORK ON LANGUAGE
AND PROVIDE THAT TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. SO JUST TWO FINAL
CONCERNS IN WRAPPING UP, MR.
CHAIRMAN, BY STRIKING THE
REFERENCE TO STATE OWNED AND
STATE CONTROLLED LANDS, THE BILL
WOULD SEEMINGLY NOW AUTHORIZE
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO
NEGOTIATE AGREEMENTS THAT AFFECT
PRIVATE PROPERTY. NOW, THAT IS
UNLIKELY THAT AN AGREEMENT WOULD
DO SO, BUT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULDN'T BE ENACTING AMBIGUOUS
LAWS AND THE PHRASE AGREED TO BE
STRICKEN TODAY SHOULD EITHER BE
RETAINED OR THE RESOURCE
AGENCY'S AUTHORITY TO GO BEYOND
STATE OWNED OR STATE CONTROLLED
LANDS SHOULD BE CLARIFIED IN THE
BILL. FINALLY, THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE SECRETARY OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY OR A
DELEGATE TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS AND BE A SIGNATORY ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE. WHILE IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR SOMEONE OTHER
THAN THE SECRETARY TO TAKE THE
LEAD IN CONSULTATIONS, OUR
CLIENT BELIEVES ONLY THE
SECRETARY SHOULD BE AUTHORIZED
TO ENTER INTO AGREEMENTS AND
BECOME THE SIGNATORY ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE. THANK YOU. AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL? ME? TWO WITNESSES. YOU CAN
COME UP WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. ADAM
QUINONEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES. NO POSITION ON THE
BILL. WE DID EXPRESS SOME
CONCERNS TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
REALLY APPRECIATE HIS TIME, HIS
STAFF'S TIME IN DISCUSSING THOSE
CONCERNS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM. OUR CONCERNS
WERE SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
WATER RIGHTS, SO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDRESSING THAT IN HIS OPENING
STATEMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS,
SENATOR LAIRD, ONE OPENING
COMMENT. AND WITH REGARD TO THE
OPPOSITION, I BELIEVE THE AUTHOR
TOOK AN AMENDMENT THAT, SAYS
THAT THE SCOPE OF THE AGREEMENTS
ARE LIMITED TO AREAS UNDER THE
NATURAL RESOURCES SECRETARY'S
JURISDICTION. SO I THINK THE
CONCERN THAT WAS EXPRESSED WAS,
AMELIORATED BY ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS. AND I'LL LET YOU AND
THE STAFF CLARIFY IT, IF THAT'S
TRUE, BUT IT SEEMS TO BE AND
THEN A GENERAL COMMENT, BECAUSE,
AS THE AUTHOR KNOWS, WHEN I WAS
SECRETARY, I NEGOTIATED
AGREEMENTS WITH TRIBES THAT,
MOVED THEM INTO THE MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS AND SO THAT THEY
COULD TAKE, FROM THE
CONSERVATION AREAS IF THEY
DEMONSTRATED A HISTORIC TAKE FOR
SUBSISTENCE OR CEREMONIAL
PURPOSES. AND IT WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST AGREEMENTS THAT SORT OF
RECOGNIZED HISTORIC RIGHTS FOR
TRIBES IN THE WATERS. AND THE
NEXT STEP WAS THIS. AND SO THERE
WAS ADVOCACY Kò FOR
CO-MANAGEMENT AGREEMENTS. BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFICULTIES,
THERE WAS A DIFFICULTY BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO DEFINITION OF WHAT
CO-MANAGEMENT WAS, AND THAT HAS
NOW BEEN TAKEN CARE OF BY THE
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION IN
ADOPTING A DEFINITION THAT IS
REFERENCED IN THIS BILL. SO THAT
IS A VERY GOOD THING. AND JUST
AN OBSERVATION. THÀNH THERE WAS
THIS WHOLE RANGE OF CAPACITY K¾T
AMONG THE TRIBES ON THE COAST,
AND THE TRIBE HAD A TRINIDAD, I
THINK HAS ITS OWN FLEET, HAS ITS
OWN EMPLOYEES, CAN GO AND
ACTUALLY DO WHAT MIGHT BE FULL
ON CO-MANAGEMENT AS OPPOSED TO
OTHER TRIBES THAT JUST DIDN'T
HAVE ANY CAPACITY AT ALL. AND SO
I AM HOPING THAT WHEN THE
CO-MANAGEMENT AGREEMENTS ARE
ENTERED INTO, THERE'S A
RECOGNITION OF WHAT THAT
CAPACITY IS BETWEEN THE TRIBES
AND THAT THERE'S A REAL
ADVANTAGE TAKEN FOR THOSE TRIBES
THAT DO HAVE CAPACITY. BUT, I
DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE GETTING NEAR
A QUORUM, BUT I WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING THE BILL WHEN
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. WITH THAT, YES, WE DO
HAVE. WE'LL ESTABLISH QUORUM IN
JUST A MOMENT. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE MEMBERS? I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF AND WANT TO NOTE THAT I
THINK THE COMMENTS OF SENATOR
LAIRD MADE ARE ACCURATE. YOU
HAVE TAKEN AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
LIMIT THE SCOPE, AND MAKE VERY
CLEAR THAT CNRA AND ITS
DEPARTMENTS CANNOT ENTER INTO
ANY CO-MANAGEMENT OR
CO-GOVERNANCE AGREEMENTS WITH
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES ON ISSUES
THAT ARE UNDER THE JURISDICTION
ALREADY OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD, LIKE
WATER QUALITY CONTROL PLANS OR
WATER RIGHTS DETERMINATIONS, AND
SO I THINK IT'S A REASONABLE AND
FAIR TO ALLOW CNRA TO PARTNER
WITH TRIBES IN ITS MANAGEMENT OF
THE STATE'S NATURAL RESOURCES. I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL, AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT
FORWARD, WITH THAT, BEFORE
BEFORE YOU CLOSE, WE'LL TAKE
QUORUM HERE REAL QUICKLY, SINCE
WE LOOK LIKE WE HAVE IT,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS. MIN MIN. AYE OR HERE?
HERE, SENATOR ELLEN DALLI.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. HERE. GROVE
GROVE. HERE. HURTADO. HURTADO.
HERE LAIRD. LAIRD. HERE. LEMON
PADILLA. PADILLA. HERE. STERN
STERN. HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM. A
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED,
ASSEMBLYMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? WELL, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS. AND THANK
YOU, SENATOR LAIRD, FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK AND PAVING
THE WAY FOR THIS BILL TO START
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THAT DIRECTION OF CO-MANAGEMENT
AND CO-GOVERNANCE CO-GOVERNANCE
ON A SOVEREIGN GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT BODY FROM THE STATE
TO THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. THIS
IS A BILL THAT'S DRASTICALLY
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT THE RIGHTS
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE OF AB 1284.
THANK YOU. SIMERMAN RAMOS. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL. THE
MOTION, BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR LAIRD AND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MINH. AYE MINH. AYE. SALADO.
ALLEN. DALLY EGGMAN. EGGMAN.
AYE. GROVE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. LAIRD AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. PADILLA PADILLA.
AYE. STERN. STERN. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO.
BUT WE'LL PUT ON CALL FOR NOW.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, BEFORE WE
MOVE TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR, SINCE
WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL MOVE TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, WHICH ARE
FILED FIVE. THANK YOU. AND THIS
MOVE BY SENATOR LAIRD, FILE
ITEMS NUMBER FIVE, AB 2962 BY
SENATOR. HAPPEN FILE ITEM NUMBER
13. I'M SORRY, FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT, AB 3121 BY ASSEMBLYMAN
HART, FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB
1881 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER 13, AB 2276 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD. FILE ITEM
NUMBER 15, AB 2393 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DIXON AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER 16, AN AB 3007 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOOVER.
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS. MIN MIN. AYE. SATO
ALAN. DALLY. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE.
GROVE. GROVE. AYE HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN. PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE STERN. STERN. AYE THAT VOTE
IS SEVEN ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON. CALL MR. CHAIR, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CATCH UP WITH THE ONE WE
HEARD BEFORE WE HAD A QUORUM?
THANK YOU. SIR, I WOULD MOVE
ITEM NUMBER 14 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WE ARE. WE HAVE A MOTION
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER 14, AB 2285
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON,
ASSISTENTE, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. AB 2285, THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS SENATOR MIN A
MIN. AYE. SATO ALAN. DALI.
EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO HURTADO.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD. AYE
LIMÓN. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
STERN STERN. AYE. THAT. VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. AND WITH THAT, WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR. I SEE WE
HAVE ASSEMBLYWOMAN BAUER-KAHAN.
IS IT KAHAN OR KAHAN? KAHAN.
OKAY. THANK YOU. IN THE ROOM
HERE TO PRESENT FILE ITEMS
NUMBER ONE AND TWO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB 460. YOU CAN
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. I APOLOGIZE FOR MY
TARDINESS. IT'S WONDERFUL TO GO
HOME EVERY DAY, BUT SOMETIMES
TRAFFIC GETS IN MY WAY, SO I
WANT TO START, FIRST OF ALL, BY
THANKING COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
CHAIR FOR THE SUPPORT ON 460.
IT'S BEEN A LONG YEAR PLUS
WORKING ON THIS EFFORT, AND THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE IN
THEIR PARTNERSHIP TO HELP MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD AS IT RELATES
TO WATER POLICY. SO I REALLY
WANTED TO JUST MAKE A HUGE SHOUT
OUT TO THE COMMITTEE ON THIS
ONE, I'LL BE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY AS SET OUT. AND
YOU KNOW, WHEN I BECAME WATER
CHAIR THREE YEARS AGO, I LOST A
LOT OF SLEEP OVER EVERYTHING I
LEARNED ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
WATER IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN YOUR
JOB IS TO SPEND ALL DAY THINKING
ABOUT WHAT WATER WILL LOOK LIKE
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS, AND
YOU'RE BEING TOLD BY SCIENTISTS
THAT IN LESS THAN 25 YEARS THERE
WILL BE NO MORE WATER, NO MORE
SNOW IN THE SIERRAS, WHICH IS,
AS I'M SURE EVERYBODY ON THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS, ONE OF THE
LARGEST SOURCES OF WATER FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU REALIZE
THE IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE AS
LEADERS OF THE STATE TO TAKE
THIS PROBLEM INCREDIBLY
SERIOUSLY. WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN
HAS ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER, WHICH I KNOW IS AN ISSUE
THAT SENATOR HURTADO HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON DILIGENTLY FOR THE
PAST FEW YEARS FOR HER COMMUNITY
. AND SO, AS I LEARNED ABOUT
THAT, IT MEANS A LOT OF THINGS.
HOW DO WE BUILD THE STORAGE
THAT'S NEEDED FOR THE WATER IN
YEARS LIKE THIS, WHEN WE HAVE
PLENTY? HOW DO WE MAKE SURE IT
MOVES IN THE WAY IT NEEDS TO
MOVE FROM COMMUNITY TO
COMMUNITY? BECAUSE AS WE ALL
KNOW, LA DOESN'T GET THEIR WATER
FROM THAT BACKYARD. THEY'RE
MOVING IT ACROSS THE STATE AND
GETTING IT FROM OTHERS. HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE BEING
RESPONSIBLE AND EFFICIENT IN THE
WAYS THAT WE SPEND THE DOLLARS,
THE CALIFORNIANS GIVE US AS IT
RELATES TO WATER? AND SO THIS
REALLY IS AN EFFORT THAT CAME
OUT OF THAT, WHICH IS TO SAY
THAT WHEN WE ARE IN YEARS OF
DROUGHT AND IT'S WONDERFUL THAT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT. BUT WHEN WE
ARE, HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL PLAYING BY THE RULES,
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A TRAGEDY OF
THE COMMONS WHERE SOME ARE
TAKING MORE AND OTHERS HAVE
NONE? IT IS A LIMITED RESOURCE,
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ALL DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
LIVE RESPONSIBLY WITHIN THE
MEANS THAT WE HAVE, BECAUSE
WATER IS A LIMITED GOOD. SO THIS
BILL, YOU KNOW, CAME OUT OF AN
ENSIGN, WENT UP IN SHASTA COUNTY
WHERE WE SAW FOLKS CLEARLY AND
EGREGIOUSLY VIOLATING THEIR
CURTAILMENT ORDERS AND NOT
LEAVING ENOUGH WATER FOR THEIR
NEIGHBORS. IN DOING SO, THE BILL
HAS BEEN LIMITED IN ITS SCOPE
TODAY TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD TO JUST FOCUS ON THE
FINES, BECAUSE THE FINES THAT
WERE CHARGED TO THOSE FOLKS THAT
VIOLATED THE ORDER WERE THE COST
OF DOING BUSINESS. AND IN ORDER
FOR US ALL TO LIVE TOGETHER AND
TO FOLLOW THE RULES, WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE MEANINGFUL
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS FOR THE
RULES ON OUR BOOKS. THAT SHOULD
BE TRUE OF EVERYTHING WE DO IN
THIS LEGISLATURE. IF WE THINK
IT'S MEANINGFUL, IT SHOULD BE
ENFORCEABLE. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS REALLY FOCUSED ON.
AND SO AGAIN, I WANT TO THANK
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO GETTING TO WHERE IT
IS TODAY. AS YOU ALL KNOW, IT
DOESN'T DO EVERYTHING I DREAMT
IT WOULD DO WHEN IT STARTED. BUT
WE'RE MOVING THE BALL FORWARD
FOR CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS
SOMETHING. AND SO ALTHOUGH I
THINK THIS IS JUST A PIECE OF
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO GET
CALIFORNIA TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO
BE TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE WATER
FOR THE FUTURE. I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD, AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO, HOPEFULLY
MOVING IT FORWARD TODAY OUT OF
COMMITTEE. SO WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS KENNETH BRINK, VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE TRIBAL COUNCIL,
AND REGGIE COLLINS, LEGAL AND
POLICY DIRECTOR OF CAL TROUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, CHAIRMAN
HAS STEPPED OUT TO PRESENT A
BILL, AND I HAVE WON THE BOOBY
PRIZE. AND SO LET ME JUST SAY
THAT WE WILL NOTE THAT YOU
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS AND THE TWO WITNESSES
SINCE THEY'RE TO HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES EACH. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT. ARE YOU
OKAY? HELLO. THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, MY NAME IS KENNETH
BRINK. I'M THE VICE CHAIRMAN OF
THE KODIAK TRIBE, FORMERLY A
FISHERIES BIOLOGIST FOR 22
YEARS, I'M IN SUPPORT OF 460. I
DO BELIEVE IT'S VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE SALMON. THE
COHO? THAT'S A THREATENED
SPECIES, NOT JUST. IS IT JUST A
FISH THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PROTECT, BUT WE'RE ALSO TRYING
TO PROTECT THE CULTURE AND THE
LIVELIHOOD OF PEOPLE DOWNSTREAM.
THE SALMON IS A BIG PART OF OUR
CULTURE AND OUR CEREMONIES. IT'S
NOT JUST A FISH THAT SWIMS UP
THE RIVER. IT'S A PART OF OUR
LIVELIHOOD. AND I'M HERE TO
SPEAK FOR THAT FISH BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T HAVE A VOICE. YOU KNOW,
WHEN PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO TAKE THE
WATER FOR A FINE OF $50 A DAY,
UNLIMITED AMOUNT AND, DRY THE
RIVER COMPLETELY UP AND FISH DIE
, AND THEN PRETTY MUCH GOES
INVISIBLE BECAUSE THERE'S NOBODY
OUT THERE TO REGULATE IT. YOU
KNOW, THE SALMON IS, TO KILL A
THREATENED SPECIES I THOUGHT WAS
A PRETTY CAPITAL CRIME. BUT
APPARENTLY IN SISKIYOU COUNTY,
YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH IT PRETTY
EASILY, I DO BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL HELP, REGULATE THE FLOW AND
DETER PEOPLE FROM ILLEGALLY
TAKING WATER, THEY WERE JUST
ABLE TO JUST GO AHEAD AND JUST
DEFY CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS AND
RULES AND JUST GO AHEAD AND PAY
THE FINE. YOU KNOW, LIKE I SAY,
I HEARD IT WAS $50 A DAY AND IT
DOES NOT ADD UP. SO, YOU KNOW,
AND FOR THE PEOPLE DOWNSTREAM,
YOU KNOW, THE SHASTA IS A PIECE
OF THE KLAMATH, AND WE JUST
SPENT 30 YEARS ON DAMMING THE
KLAMATH. WE HAVE OUR GOVERNOR IN
SUPPORT OF THE SALMON RECOVERY.
AND THE SKYE AND THE SHASTA ARE
HUGE PARTS OF THE KLAMATH
RECOVERY. SO TO RESTORE SAU AND
TAKE CARE OF THE SHASTA IS TO
LOOK AFTER THE LARGEST WILD
CHINOOK POPULATION ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER. I, SO I WOULD
REALLY LIKE YOU GUYS TO CONSIDER
MOVING FORWARD 60 BECAUSE IT IS
JUSTICE FOR THE PEOPLE
DOWNSTREAM. IT IS ALSO TIE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S WORK FROM THE
HEADWATERS TO THE OCEAN, THE
PROJECTS GOING TO TIE TOGETHER.
YOU KNOW, THE SOME OF THE
KLAMATH DAM REMOVAL IS JUST ONE
PIECE OF THIS PROJECT. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS REGGIE
COLLINS. I'M THE LEGAL AND
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
TROUT, A STATEWIDE CONSERVATION
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB 460, A CRUCIAL
BILL AIMED AT ENHANCING THE
STATE WATER RESOURCE CONTROL
BOARD'S ABILITY TO MANAGE
CALIFORNIA'S PRECIOUS WATER
RESOURCES EFFECTIVELY. THE
BOARD'S MISSION IS CLEAR TO
PRESERVE, ENHANCE AND RESTORE
CALIFORNIA'S WATER RESOURCES AND
ENSURE THEIR EFFICIENT USE. AB
460 PROVIDES THE STATE BOARD
WITH NECESSARY TOOLS TO DETER
FUTURE WATER. ILLEGAL WATER
DIVERSIONS. AS WE DISCUSSED, THE
SHASTA RIVER WATER ASSOCIATION'S
LEGAL DIVERSION OF WATER IN
AUGUST OF 2022, THERE'S A STARK
REMINDER OF THE CHALLENGES WE
FACE DESPITE CURTAILMENT
NOTICES, THE IRRIGATION DISTRICT
DRAINED HALF THE SHASTA RIVER,
ENDANGERING ECOSYSTEMS,
DOWNSTREAM WATER USERS AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES. THESE WATER
USERS WILLFULLY VIOLATED
CURTAILMENT ORDERS AND AS A
RESULT, FACE PENALTIES OF
CUMULATIVELY PER INDIVIDUAL $50
PER RANCHER. THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY EXAMPLE. IN THE PAST FEW
MONTHS, WE'VE SEEN LARGE SCALE
WATER THEFT IN THE OXNARD PLAINS
AND IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THE MINIMAL PENALTIES CURRENTLY
IN PLACE HAVE PROVEN
INSUFFICIENT TO PREVENT SUCH
HARMFUL BEHAVIOR. AB 460
ADDRESSES THIS BY SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASING THOSE PENALTIES TO
$10,000 PER DAY, AND $2,500 PER
ACRE FOOT OF ILLEGALLY DIVERTED
WATER, MAKING THE COST OF
VIOLATION SUBSTANTIAL ENOUGH TO
DETER FUTURE VIOLATIONS.
CALIFORNIA'S WATER LAWS MUST
EVOLVE TO MEET CONTEMPORARY
CHALLENGES. THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S WATER
STRATEGY UNDERSCORE THE NEED FOR
MODERNIZATION IN AB 460 ALIGNS
WITH THESE RECOMMENDATIONS. I
WANT TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE, MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THOSE IN
OPPOSITION FOR THEIR DEDICATION
TO WORKING THROUGH THIS VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUE TO FIND A
SOLUTION AND A COMPROMISE THAT
ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. IN CONCLUSION, AB
460 IS VITAL FOR THE SUSTAINABLE
MANAGEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S WATER
RESOURCES AND IT STRENGTHENS
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS BY
INCREASING PENALTIES TO DETER
ILLEGAL ACTIONS AND ENSURES THAT
THE STATE BOARD CAN EFFECTIVELY
PROTECT OUR WATER SUPPLIES AND
ECOSYSTEMS. FOR THAT, I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT AB 460 FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR ENVIRONMENT,
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE FUTURE OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THAT COMPLETES THE
STATEMENTS BY THE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. THIS WOULD BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A ME TOO IN
SUPPORT. JUST YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. WELCOME. HI. MY NAME IS
ANNALISA RIVERO AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF TROUT
UNLIMITED CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
RECREATION PARTNERSHIP, THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
FLY FISHERS INTERNATIONAL, AND
FRIENDS OF THE RIVER. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, ALEX LIMA, ON
BEHALF OF THE YUROK TRIBE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. DENNIS
O'CONNOR WITH THE MONO LAKE
COMMITTEE AND ALSO SPEAKING FOR
THE PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE. BOTH VERY DISAPPOINTED
WITH THE DROPPING OF INTERIM
RELIEF, BUT BOTH VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. KIM DELFINO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
WATER FOUNDATION, DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE GOLDEN STATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION. AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ORTEZ POLICY ANALYST
WITH RESTORATIVE DELTA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GABRIELLA
FAZIO IS HERE. CLUB CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. JAN WARREN,
INTERFAITH CLIMATE ACTION
NETWORK OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND SUPPORT IVY BRITAIN,
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION AND PLEASED TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS. GLENN FARRELL, WOULD
YOU HAVE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THE AUTHOR HAS
ACCEPTED TO REALLY FOCUS ON
ENHANCING FINES AND PENALTIES TO
GIVE THE STATE WATER BOARD THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO EFFECTIVELY
DETER ILLEGAL DIVERSIONS. WE'VE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION AND STAND
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL
TODAY. TO FIANCE AGARWAL,
REPRESENTING THE JUNIOR
PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION, WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. ISABELLA
GONZALEZ, POTTER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT. CODY
PHILLIPS WITH CALIFORNIA
COASTKEEPER ALLIANCE AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MARCUS
KING MASON, CALIFORNIA.
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANKS DANIEL BROWN, ON BEHALF
OF UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JUAN
ALTAMIRANO, WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT. M.J.
KUSHNER WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER IN SUPPORT. KEIKO MERTZ
WITH FRIENDS OF THE RIVER IN
SUPPORT. J JEFFERSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT.
WE'VE REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION AND
ARE PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
WITH THE AMENDMENTS BEING
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. CRAIG TUCKER, ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDS OF THE EEL RIVER IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL, ANY OTHER
METOO'S IN SUPPORT? DARRELL
LITTLE, ON BEHALF OF NRDC IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL METOOS THIS IS THE
CHANCE FOR AN OPPOSITION. I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE ARE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES, WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ONE, NARROWING THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL AND TWO,
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WITH THE ACCEPTANCE
OF COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
REMOVING THE OUR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL, AGAIN, I THINK THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP AND WILL DETER
FUTURE EGREGIOUS INCIDENTS LIKE
THE ONE THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CITED IN HER COMMENTS. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
PRIMARY WITH AN AMBIVALENT
SUPPORTER POSE OR NEUTRAL
POSITION? THAT'S THAT'S ALL OF
US. YEAH. THEN THEN LET'S JUST
MOVE TO THE METOOS. OKAY. ON
THIS SIDE. GOOD MORNING. ANDREA
ABARGIL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION.
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR NARROWING THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL. WE REALLY SUPPORT THE
FINES AND WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, WE'RE RECOMMENDING A
REMOVAL OF OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. BRENDA BASS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND WE ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
THE AUTHOR AND TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. DENNIS ALBIANI, ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CLARITA VALLEY
WATER AGENCY, AS WELL AS SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY MWD AS WELL AS A
FEW AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES LIKE
CALIFORNIA SEED AND CALIFORNIA
ORGANIC FEED. WE ARE NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. MORNING,
DON GILBERT, ON BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION, WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE BILL THAT EVERYONE COULD GET
BEHIND. WE REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. DEAN
TALLY, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK HERE.
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION TO
NEUTRAL. THANK YOU. AND JAMIE
MINER ON BEHALF OF SANTA
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT,
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
, PLEASED TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION AND APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS. ALEX BEARING
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU, DITTO TO
WHAT EVERYONE ELSE SAID. AND
ALSO REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION.
THANKS GOOD MORNING. TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
RESPECTFULLY ALSO REMOVING
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MARGIE
LEE, ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF FOOD PRODUCERS,
REMOVING OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
KENDRA DIOGO WITH THE GORKO
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY WATER AGENCY, KINGS RIVER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS AND IRRIGATION
DISTRICT. WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH AQUA AND CæA. THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR. GAIL DELAHUNT WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION. AND
I'M GOING TO BE A DITTO FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE WHO'S JUST GONE
BEFORE ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE AUTHOR. GOOD MORNING.
TAYLOR OCEAN, ON BEHALF OF
VARIETY OF AG ASSOCIATIONS,
HAPPY TO MOVE TO NEUTRAL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING.
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT AND MOJAVE WATER
AGENCY, NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
JULIE MALINOWSKI, ON BEHALF OF
THE CONTRA COSTA WATER DISTRICT,
RECOMMENDING A REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. JENNIFER
WILLIAMS WITH THE EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT. WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THE
AUTHOR HAS TAKEN AND WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION. DOMINIC
TAMARA, HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER EXCHANGE
CONTRACTORS WATER AUTHORITY,
ALSO REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYWOMAN CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF SAN
JOAQUIN, STANISLAUS, FRESNO,
TULARE AND SOLANO, AS WELL AS
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO, LONDON BREED,
ALL REVIEWING THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS AND HOPING TO BE
UPDATING POSITIONS SOON. ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN
IRRIGATION DISTRICT, FORMERLY
MOVING FROM AN OPPOSED TO
NEUTRAL POSITION. AND THANK YOU
FOR KNOWING THE BILL AND WORKING
WITH EVERYONE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, KIARA ROSS. ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF STOCKTON, WE ARE
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS, BUT AT THIS POINT
REMAIN IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
ON THE BILL. FINALLY IT'S THE
LONGEST OPPOSITION SECTION WE'VE
EVER HAD WITH NOBODY BEING IN
OPPOSITION. HI. GOOD MORNING,
CAITLIN JOHNSON WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION,
MOVING TO A NEUTRAL POSITION.
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR.
GOOD MORNING, VICTORIA
RODRIGUEZ, ON BEHALF OF MILK
PRODUCERS COUNCIL. STILL LOOKING
AT THE AMENDMENTS, BUT LOOKING
TOWARDS REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
METOO SECTION? TECHNICALLY
OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE. I WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? MOTION BY
SENATOR HURTADO. ANY SENATOR
EGGMAN? WELL, ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
HAVE NOT VOTED FOR OTHER
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL, BUT I AM
GLAD TO BE SUPPORTING TODAY,
DESPITE MY CITY STILL BEING.
THEY THINK THEY MIGHT BE
OPPOSED, BUT THEY'RE NOT QUITE
SURE. BUT EVERYBODY ELSE, HAS
GONE ON. SO I APPRECIATE THE
WORK AND I APPRECIATE THE
PASSION THAT YOU BRING TO THIS
WORK AND YOUR ABILITY TO
ARTICULATE, THE BILL AND YOUR
POSITION. I LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING. AYE TODAY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. MR. CHAIR. YES, MISTER.
SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. JUST BRIEFLY ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS. I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I'VE SAID TO
YOU BEFORE MANY TIMES, I WANT TO
COLLABORATE WITH YOU ON A LOT OF
THE GOALS THAT YOU HAVE IN MIND.
I RESPECT YOUR EXPERTISE AND
SOMETIMES TO, I THINK, HOPEFULLY
INTELLIGENT MINDS DON'T ALWAYS
AGREE ON THE PATH, BUT YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT TO KEEP WORKING
TOWARDS THE GOALS THAT YOU WANT
TO ACHIEVE IN A WAY THAT WORKS
FOR FOLKS, AND I'M HAPPY TO SEE
A BROAD CONSENSUS HERE TODAY.
AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
EVERYONE. THANK YOU. SENATOR,
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS? SEEING
NONE, YOU MAY CLOSE, I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE MY THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE, BUT ALSO TO OUR
NATIVE PEOPLE FOR BEING HERE.
THEY'VE REALLY BEEN AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE WATER CONVERSATION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE, YOU
KNOW, IN RECENT YEARS. AND I
THINK IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
WHEN THE NATIVE PEOPLE HAD
POSSESSION OF LAND, WE DID A LOT
BETTER WITH OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES. AND I THINK WE SHOULD
BE TAKING THEIR LEAD AND
LEARNING HOW TO, MOVE FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU, WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
HURTADO. DO PASS, AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY. WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR MINH SATO, ALAN
DALI, EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
GROVE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. LAIRD AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. PADILLA PADILLA.
AYE. STERN OKAY. WE HAVE. WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL, AND, AND WE
WILL GET ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. AND
YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL I DO.
THEN WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO, ASSEMBLY BILL 2214. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS,
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2214.
THIS IS A JOINT EFFORT WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA. AND IT
REALLY FOCUSES ON THE PERVASIVE
PROBLEM TO BOTH THE ENVIRONMENT
AND OUR HEALTH OF MICROPLASTICS.
AS YOU MAY HAVE SEEN IN RECENT
DAYS, THERE WAS A LOT OF PRESS
ABOUT HOW A STUDY WAS DONE THAT
SHOWED THE AMOUNT OF
MICROPLASTICS IN HUMAN TESTICLES
AS WELL AS BREAST MILK, AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS PERVASIVE
NOT ONLY IN OUR WATERWAYS, BUT
IN OUR BODIES. AND WE DON'T. I
BELIEVE, FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACTS OF THAT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TO THE HEALTH OF
FUTURE GENERATIONS. BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO GET
OUR ARMS AROUND. AND AS I BEGAN
THE EFFORT TO WORK ON
MICROPLASTICS A LITTLE OVER A
YEAR AGO, WHAT I STARTED TO
REALIZE WAS THAT BECAUSE THE
SOURCE OF MICROPLASTIC ARE SO
DIVERSE, THERE WAS NO ONE AGENCY
IN CHARGE OF ERADICATING
MICROPLASTICS IN OUR IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AND AS A RESULT, IT
FELT LIKE NOBODY WAS IN CHARGE.
SO WE WEREN'T MOVING FORWARD
WITH SOLVING THE PROBLEM. AND SO
I DECIDED THIS YEAR TO TAKE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO THIS
PROBLEM AND REALLY FOCUS ON
EXACTLY THAT, GETTING OUR
AGENCIES TOGETHER, ASKING THEM
TO WORK TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY AND
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM, AND THEN
DECIDING WHO'S IN CHARGE OF THE
PROBLEM. SO SOMEBODY ACTUALLY
WORKS TOWARDS SOLVING IT. SO
IT'S A FAIRLY SIMPLE EFFORT TO
TRY TO GET CALIFORNIA TO MOVE
FORWARD IN ITS MICROPLASTICS,
ERADICATION AND THE AMAZING
POSITIVE IMPACT THAT WILL HAVE
ON OUR ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
HEALTH. SO WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS JENNIFER FEARING WITH
THE OCEAN CONSERVANCY AND ISABEL
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. WELCOME. YOU HAVE
UP TO TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS JENNIFER FAIRING, ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE OCEAN
CONSERVANCY AND THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM. WE'RE PLEASED TO BE
AMONG THE NEARLY TWO DOZEN
ORGANIZATIONS URGING YOU TO VOTE
AYE ON AB 2214, WHICH WILL
LEVERAGE THE DIVERSE EXPERTISE
OF STATE AGENCY STAFF TO
COLLABORATIVELY ADDRESS THE
URGENT ISSUE OF MICROPLASTIC
POLLUTION. ABSENT URGENT
INTERVENTIONS, MICROPLASTICS
WILL CONTINUE TO POSE A THREAT
TO OUR ENVIRONMENT, WILDLIFE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE DISTINCT
TYPES OF TINY FRAGMENTS IN THE
MICROPLASTIC FAMILY COME FROM
VARYING SOURCES, AND THUS
REQUIRE DIFFERENT INTERVENTIONS
TO ADDRESS THEIR ARE
MICROPLASTICS THAT FRAGMENT FROM
DURABLE GOODS AND PACKAGING,
MICRO PLASTICS DERIVED FROM
SYNTHETIC TEXTILES, OFTEN CALLED
MICROFIBERS, AND MICROPLASTICS
DESIGNED TO BE TINY LIKE,
PRE-PRODUCTION PELLETS MADE OF
PLASTIC CALLED NURDLES THAT
ACCOUNT FOR ANNUAL GLOBAL
LEAKAGE OF 230,000 METRIC TONS
ROUND PLASTIC BEADS CALLED
MICROBEADS, ARE INTENTIONALLY
INCLUDED IN SPECIFIC PRODUCTS
LIKE COSMETICS, HOUSEHOLD AND
INDUSTRIAL DETERGENTS, AND
CLEANING PRODUCTS, AND ARE
REGULARLY DISCHARGED INTO OUR
WASTEWATER SYSTEMS AND AQUATIC
AND MARINE ECOSYSTEMS. BECAUSE
THERE IS NO POINT OF CAPTURE AND
MICROPLASTIC FIBERS, THE MOST
ABUNDANT AND WIDESPREAD FORM OF
MICROPLASTIC POLLUTION ARE
PERVASIVE IN THE ENVIRONMENT,
DRINKING WATER, FOOD SUPPLIES,
AND POSE A SERIOUS RISK TO
HUMANS IN PARTICULAR. MOST OF
YOU, THANKFULLY SUPPORTED
ASSEMBLYWOMAN MCKENNA'S BILL
LAST YEAR TO IMPLEMENT A Kò
MICROPLASTICS PREVENTION
RECOMMENDATION THAT WAS INCLUDED
IN THE ADMINISTRATION THÀNH
STATEWIDE MICROPLASTICS
STRATEGY, PUBLISHED IN EARLY
2022. AB 1628 WOULD HAVE
REQUIRED WASHING MACHINE
MANUFACTURERS TO HAVE FILTERS
THAT REDUCE UP TO 90% OF
MICROFIBERS OTHERWISE RELEASED
INTO WASTEWATER, AND THEN THE
ENVIRONMENT. BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM VETOED THAT
BILL, NOTING ONGOING WATER BOARD
ASSESSMENTS AND ASKING THE
AUTHOR TO DEVELOP INCENTIVES. WE
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT TO ENROLL
THE STATE AGENCY'S EXPERTS IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF WORKABLE AND
PRACTICAL OPTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
CROSS-SECTORAL ISSUES WE NEED
TEAMWORK. AB 2214 REQUIRES THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL TO
ESTABLISH AND LEAD AN
INTERAGENCY COORDINATION GROUP
TO IDENTIFY AND RECOMMEND
STATUTORY CHANGES NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE STRATEGY,
BECAUSE, AGAIN, THE POLLUTION
HAS SUCH A MULTIFACETED ASPECT
TO IT, IT DEMANDS THIS
COORDINATED ACTION ACROSS
VARIOUS SECTORS AND
JURISDICTIONS BY BRINGING THE
STATE GOVERNMENT EXPERTS
TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY EXPLICIT
WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
MICROPLASTICS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT. THIS WILL HELP
ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S ONGOING
LEADERSHIP IN EFFECTIVELY
MANAGING AND MITIGATING THESE
ADVERSE IMPACTS. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB 2214. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ISABELLA
GONZALEZ, POTTER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY, JUST HERE TO ADD
OUR VOICE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2214.
IN 2020, THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
PARTNERED WITH UC SANTA BARBARA
TO QUANTIFY THE AMOUNT OF
MICROFIBERS IN CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENT. THE STUDY FOUND
THAT IN 2019, AN ESTIMATED 4000
METRIC TONS, OR 13.3 QUADRILLION
FIBERS YES, QUADRILLION WITH A
C¯ WERE RELEASED INTO
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. THAT NUMBER
REPRESENTS 130,000 TIMES AS MANY
FIBERS AS THERE ARE STARS IN THE
MILKY WAY GALAXY, EQUIVALENT TO
80 MILLION RUBBER DUCKIES. MY
FAVORITE UNIT OF MEASUREMENT IS
RUBBER DUCK, WORTH OF PLASTIC
POLLUTING THE STATE EVERY YEAR
WITHOUT INTERVENTION, ANNUAL
SYNTHETIC MICROFIBER EMISSIONS
TO CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT ARE EXPECTED TO
INCREASE BY 17% BY 2026. THE
ANALYSIS SUGGESTS THAT FULL
ADOPTION OF IN-LINE FILTERS
WASHING MACHINES WILL OFFER THE
LARGEST REDUCTION IN ANNUAL
SYNTHETIC MICROFIBER EMISSIONS
TO NATURAL ENVIRONMENTS. AB 2214
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING BOTH MICROFIBER AND
MICROPLASTIC POLLUTION, TNCS IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE LEADERSHIP
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BAUER-KAHAN
AND MCKENNA. WE REQUEST YOUR
RESPECTFUL SUPPORT OF AB 2214.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
THIS WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANYBODY TO DO A ME TOO AND
SUPPORT YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. WELCOME CHEN WARREN,
INTERFAITH CLIMATE ACTION
NETWORK OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
IN FULL SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
CHRISTINA SCARINGE WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
AND SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, KIM
DELFINO ON BEHALF OF AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA. AND SUPPORT MARQUISE
KING MASON, CALIFORNIA.
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANKS GOOD MORNING, ANANYA
KARAGEORGIOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
JUNIOR PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
SYLVIA SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. KYLE FARRAR,
WESTERN PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT
FRACTRACKER ALLIANCE, IN FULL
SUPPORT. MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
REID FOR DAVIS, AND I LIVE IN
LÀ. AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON AB 2214 TO ADDRESS THE MICRO
PLASTICS CRISIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR TRAVELING HERE
TODAY TO DO THAT, DOCTOR BONNIE
HAMILTON SPEAKING IN FULL
SUPPORT FOR THE PHYSICIAN FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WITH A ME TOO. IN
SUPPORT? THEN WE WOULD MOVE TO
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? I HAVE
NO PRIMARY WITNESS LISTED. CAN I
GO? YES, MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS,
MANDY ISAACS LEE, ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL, WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL OPPOSED POSITION ON
THIS BILL, BUT WE'RE IN A LITTLE
BIT OF A TWEENER POSITION, WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGED WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE FOR MONTHS ON AMENDMENTS
THAT WE BELIEVE WILL TIGHTEN UP
THE BILL AS IT IS IN PRINT, PART
OF THE PRINCIPLES THAT GUIDE OUR
AMENDMENTS ARE THAT WE ARE
KEENLY AWARE THAT WHATEVER THE
OPC IS GOING TO RECOMMEND TO THE
STATE IN THE FORM OF STATUTORY
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL MAKE WAY
FOR FUTURE LEGISLATION. AND WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT
THE OPC IS PROVIDING TO THE
STATE IN THE FORM OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE DONE IN A
WAY THAT WERE WELL INFORMED. THE
SPIRIT OF OUR REQUEST ARE ARE
MAINLY BECAUSE WE WANT THE STATE
TO FOCUS ON THE LARGER
CONTRIBUTOR, DÍAS, SO THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS CAN REMOVE THE
LARGEST AMOUNT OF MICROPLASTIC
FROM THE ENVIRONMENT. RIGHT NOW,
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL NAMES
NOT ONLY OUR INDUSTRY, BUT OTHER
INDUSTRIES THAT REPRESENT A TINY
PORTION OF THE OVERALL
MICROPLASTICS LITTER IN THE
ENVIRONMENT. FOR OUR INDUSTRY IN
PARTICULAR, WE REPRESENT ABOUT
LESS THAN 2% OF THE LITTER. AND
SO OUR CONVERSATIONS AS OF
YESTERDAY HAVE BEEN GOING VERY,
VERY POSITIVELY. WE DID NOT
SUBMIT A LETTER FOR THAT REASON.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR. I'M ALSO MINDFUL
THAT SEVERAL OF YOU ALSO SIT ON
THE NEXT COMMITTEE THAT THIS
BILL IS REFERRED TO, AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET THOSE
AMENDMENTS IN BY THAT POINT. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
SO WE'RE SEEING NO OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM. LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS? SENATOR LAIRD? DO
OPPOSITION METOOS DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION METOOS IN THE ROOM?
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THIS, SENATOR
LAIRD, I HAVE A RATHER WONKY
QUESTION. AND THAT IS THIS,
YOU'RE CALLING ON THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL TO DO THIS IN
THE BILL, BUT IT COVERS THE
ENTIRE LAND AS WELL, RIGHT? I
MEAN, THIS ISN'T DEFINED TO JUST
OCEANS. YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IT
FOR THE ENTIRE STATE. THAT'S
RIGHT. SO, I MEAN, WE WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
BRING EVERYONE TOGETHER, AND WE
THOUGHT THIS WAS THE BEST WAY TO
DO IT. OBVIOUSLY, IT IS AN OCEAN
PROBLEM AS WELL. SO WE THOUGHT
THIS WAS A GOOD SOURCE OF
CONVENING. BUT YES, IT WOULD
ADDRESS BOTH LAND BASED AND
OCEAN BASED. OKAY, GREAT. THANK
YOU, ANYONE ELSE? YES. SENATOR
EGGMAN, I GUESS AM I, MY STAFF
NOTES ALSO REFLECT THAT. LIKE,
WHY GO AFTER THE SMALLEST
PERCENT AND MY WASHING MACHINE,
RIGHT? RIGHT. WHY NOT DO
TEXTILES AND TIRES, SO ONE POINT
OF CLARIFICATION, WHICH IS YOUR
WASHING MACHINE PROBABLY IS THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF AS MENTIONED,
MICROFIBERS ARE, WE BELIEVE THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF THE WASHING
MACHINES IS WHY WE WERE GOING
LAST YEAR WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KINDER'S BILL, BUT WE'RE NOT
THERE. SO, BUT YEAH, SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
WITH, THE WIENER, I GUESS THE
OPPOSITION, BECAUSE SHE'S NOT
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION, IS AMENDING
THE BILL TO NOT CALL OUT THOSE
EXACT, INDUSTRIES, BUT INSTEAD
INSTRUCT THE OPC TO FOCUS ON THE
MICROPLASTIC SOURCES THAT ARE
THE LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO HUMAN
HEALTH IN THE ENVIRONMENT,
SPECIFICALLY. SO THERE REALLY IS
FOCUSED ON EXACTLY WHAT I THINK
YOU WANT ME TO BE FOCUSED ON,
WHICH IS THE LARGEST
CONTRIBUTORS. SO THAT'S THE
AMENDMENT. WE'RE WORKING ON THE
LANGUAGE IS IN PROGRESS. OKAY.
I'LL BE GLAD TO SUPPORT TODAY
AND BE WATCHING FOR THAT
PROGRESS. SENATOR. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROVE, THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE WHERE YOU'RE GOING. I
DO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. BUT I
THINK THE THING THAT BOTHERS ME
MOST ABOUT BEING IN THE BUILDING
AND LISTENING TO SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT COMES THROUGH,
IS THAT WE BAN THINGS WITH THAT
TECHNOLOGY AND SOLUTIONS INSTEAD
OF A GRADUAL SOMETHING TO WAIT
TILL SOMETHING COMES UP. BECAUSE
ON THE LIST OF THE LIST OF ITEMS
THAT I HAVE, LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCKTON SAID, OBVIOUSLY
TEXTILES AND TIRES, BUT THE LIST
OF STUFF THAT I HAVE, YOU KNOW,
IF THIS BAN TAKES PLACE FOR
MICROPLASTICS, IT'S ALL CONSUMER
PRODUCTS, INCLUDING RINSE OFF
AND LEAVE ON COSMETICS. SO I
REALIZE THAT SOME PEOPLE DON'T
WEAR A LOT OF MAKEUP. I HAPPEN
TO DO THAT BECAUSE I'M 60 AND I
LIKE TO COVER UP MY WRINKLES. SO
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS, IS DO I
GO TO NEVADA TO BUY MY
COSMETICS? BECAUSE COSMETICS
WILL NO LONGER BE AVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY'LL BE A
BANNED ON THE MICROPLASTICS OR
THE DISPOSABLE. AND THERE'S NO
TECHNOLOGY REPLACES, WHICH IS,
I'M ASSUMING, WHY THE PRODUCTS
INDUSTRY IS TRYING TO NEGOTIATE
A DIFFERENT AMENDMENT SO THEY
COULD BE EXCLUDED, WHICH WOULD
BE A GOOD THING, BY THE WAY. BUT
THERE'S ALSO INDUSTRIAL
DETERGENTS, MEDICAL HOUSEHOLD
INDUSTRIAL DETERGENTS, MEDICAL
DEVICES, MEDICATIONS, FOOD
PRODUCTS, PAINTS, INDUSTRIAL
COATINGS, WAXES, POLISHES,
DECORATIVE GLITTERS. MY
GRANDDAUGHTER IS ALL 11 OF THEM
WILL PROBABLY NOT APPROVE OF
THAT. AND TEXTILES, WHICH I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE IN IN,
STOCKTON AND THEN ALSO 3D
PRINTING, LASER PRINTING, TONER,
REALIZE WE DO A LOT OF EMAIL AND
WE'RE TRYING NOT TO WE'RE
PHASING OUT PAPER, BUT STILL,
YOU KNOW, 3D PRINTING WAS ONE OF
THE MOST INGENIOUS THINGS OF THE
LAST. YOU KNOW, TEN YEARS FOR,
BEING ABLE TO DO 3D PRINTING
VERSUS USING STEEL PRODUCTS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE TO DO THAT,
THEY'RE ALSO IN CONTROLLED
RELEASE FERTILIZER APPLICATIONS
FOR OUR FARMERS. WHOLESALE
BANNING OF THIS DOESN'T ACCOUNT
FOR THE INNOVATIONS THAT I THINK
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
REPLACE THESE PRODUCTS, AND THE
OPC, I THINK WAS DOING BASED ON
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED,
WORKING ON GETTING IT. YOU KNOW,
PHASED OUT, BUT NOT AN ALL OUT
BAN. DO YOU HAVE CONCERNS OVER
ANY OF THAT? NO, NO, I DIDN'T
WANT TO INTERRUPT YOU. SO IF YOU
WERE DONE, SENATOR, NO. SO THE
BILL JUST SO, YEAH, I WEAR
COSMETICS AS WELL AS I'M SURE
YOU CAN TELL, BECAUSE I'M NOT 20
ANYMORE EITHER, SENATOR, BUT, SO
I AM NOT HERE TO BAN COSMETICS,
LEAVE ON COSMETICS, ANY TYPE OF
COSMETICS. AND THE BILL ITSELF
REALLY DOESN'T DO THAT. I THINK
IT DOES WHAT I HOPE I THINK
YOU'RE SAYING YOU WANT US TO DO,
WHICH IS TO BRING THE EXPERTS
TOGETHER TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM IN A WAY THAT
MAKES THE MOST SENSE. I MEAN,
ONE OF THE REASONS AND I KNOW
SENATOR ALLEN IS IN HERE, BUT,
YOU KNOW, HIS GREEN CHEMISTRY
DIVISION, WHICH I THINK HAS BEEN
INGENIOUS, IS SO SMART IS
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THE EXPERTS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS AND
HOW TO DO IT WITHOUT REGRETTABLE
ALTERNATIVES, WHICH IS SOMETHING
ELSE THAT IS REALLY CRITICAL.
AND SO THE BILL DOESN'T ITSELF
BAN ANYTHING. OR IN FACT
REGULATE ANYTHING. IT ASKS THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE CHARGED WITH
THE DIFFERENT SOURCES OF
MICROPLASTICS TO GET TOGETHER,
TO FIGURE OUT A PATH FORWARD AND
TO SAY WHO'S IN CHARGE OF WHAT
THAT PATH FORWARD LOOKS LIKE. SO
WE DON'T HAVE A DIFFUSION OF
RESPONSIBILITY THAT HAS LED TO
THIS PROBLEM, WHERE WE DON'T
SEEM TO BE TRYING TO TACKLE ANY
OF IT. AND TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU, WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS IS BILLS INTRODUCED TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT, TO BAN COSMETIC LEAVE ON
COSMETICS. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH. I
THINK THE RIGHT APPROACH IS TO
HAVE THE EXPERTS FOCUSED ON
THIS, TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT THE
PATH FORWARD THAT IS HEALTHY FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT, HEALTHY FOR
PEOPLE, AND ALLOWS US TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE CALIFORNIA
THE WAY WE NEED TO. AND SO
NOTHING IN HERE WOULD BAN ANY OF
THE THINGS LISTED. DO YOU THINK
OPC HAS CHARGED FOR THIS IN
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION IS NOT
DOING THAT JOB? SO RIGHT NOW OPC
HAS THIS MUCH OF IT AND SO DO A
LOT OF OTHER AGENCIES. SO DTSC,
CALRECYCLE AND OTHERS AND SO
EACH OF THEM IS TRYING TO DO
THEIR PART. BUT THEY'RE NOT
WORKING TOGETHER. IN A WAY I
THINK THAT IS TRULY SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM. AND SO THIS JUST REALLY
BRINGS THEM TOGETHER TO ALLOW
THEM TO SOLVE IT IN A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE WAY. SO THAT'S THE
PROBLEM I'M TRYING TO SOLVE.
THANK YOU. YEAH. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
PADILLA. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS,
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN? RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR. AYE. VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. THANK YOU. SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY FROM
SENATOR PADILLA. ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MIN A MIN. AYE. SATO ALAN DALI.
EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. STERN A STERN. AYE
THANK YOU, THE VOTE COUNT IS SIX
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL, WE'LL MOVE NOW TO THE NEXT
FILE ITEM IN OUR FILE ITEM
ORDER. AND THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. I SEE ASSEMBLYWOMAN
PAPPIN IN THE AUDIENCE,
PRESENTING AB 1359 CAN PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SENATOR AND, MEMBERS.
SO GEOTHERMAL ENERGY PRESENTS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR GREEN
ENERGY. AB 1359 IS A SIMPLE BILL
THAT WILL JUMP START GEOTHERMAL
ENERGY PRODUCTION. IT FOCUSES ON
MAKING THE SEQUA PERMITTING OF
EXPLORATORY WELLS, LOCAL. IT
WILL REPEAL THE REQUIREMENT THAT
CAL GEM BE THE LEAD AGENCY TO DO
A SECRET REVIEW OF EXPLORATORY
WELLS BY WAY OF BACKGROUND,
BEFORE DEVELOPMENT OF A
GEOTHERMAL FIELD CAN BEGIN IN
EARNEST, THE DEVELOPER NEEDS TO
DRILL EXPLORATORY WELLS TO
GATHER DATA AND CONFIRM
FEASIBILITY. UNDER SEQUA, THE
EXPLORATION PHASE AND THE
BUILDING OF A GEOTHERMAL FIELD
ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY. THEY'RE
TREATED AS TWO DIFFERENT
PROJECTS. UNFORTUNATELY AN OLD
MISGUIDED PROVISION OF LAW
DESIGNATES THE STATE GEOLOGICAL
ENERGY MANAGEMENT DIVISION, OR
CAL GEM, AS THE LEAD AGENCY FOR
SEQUA FOR EXPLORATORY WELLS,
RATHER THAN A LOCAL AGENCY
ACTING AS A LEAD TO DO THE SEQUA
REVIEW. THIS PROVISION WAS
INTENDED ORIGINALLY TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND GET
GEOTHERMAL PLANTS ONLINE FASTER,
BUT HAS ENDED UP WITH PROJECTS
LANGUISHING IN CAL CHEN
PURGATORY BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN
BEGIN. COUNTIES ALREADY
TYPICALLY SERVE AS A LEAD AGENCY
ON THE GEOTHERMAL FIELD PROJECTS
THEMSELVES, AND ARE WELL
EQUIPPED TO SERVE AS THE LEAD
AGENCY FOR THE EXPLORATORY
EXPLORATORY DRILL APPLICATIONS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THIS BILL
WILL NOT WEAKEN SEQUENT IN ANY
WAY. IN FACT, THIS MAY BE THE
ONLY SEQUA BILL IN WHICH THE
SPONSORS WANT TO BE TREATED,
JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER SEQUA
PROJECT BY HAVING THE
EXPLORATORY SEQUA SUBMISSIONS
REVIEWED LOCALLY HERE. TO
TESTIFY WITH ME TODAY IS MR.
MILES HORTON. ON BEHALF OF
SONOMA CLEAN POWER. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS, THANKS TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND THANKS
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPPIN FOR
PUTTING FORWARD THIS THOUGHTFUL
LEGISLATION. I'M MILES HORTON ON
BEHALF OF SONOMA CLEAN POWER. WE
ARE A COMMUNITY OWNED POWER
PROVIDER SERVING SONOMA AND
MENDOCINO COUNTIES. ONE THING
WE'RE REALLY PROUD OF IS WE'RE
PRETTY AHEAD OF THE CURVE ON
CLEAN ENERGY. WE'RE ACTUALLY
OVER 90% CLEAN IN OUR PORTFOLIO
TODAY. BUT WHAT WE'RE RUNNING
INTO IS THERE ARE TIMES YOU
KNOW, LIKE NIGHT, WINTER WHEN
THERE'S NO SUN, THERE'S NO WIND
AND BATTERIES ARE DEPLETED. AND
WE'RE STILL RELYING ON NATURAL
GAS DURING THOSE PERIODS. AND
BECAUSE WE'RE PAYING THIS SORT
OF INCREASINGLY KIND OF AGING
NATURAL GAS SYSTEM JUST TO STAND
BY, EVEN AS OUR SHARE OF
RENEWABLES IN OUR PORTFOLIO HAS
GONE UP, OUR PAYMENTS TO NATURAL
GAS HAVE ACTUALLY GONE UP AS
WELL. AND SO, YOU KNOW, THE
STATE'S GOING TO BE IN A SIMILAR
BOAT. AS WE GET CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO AN ALL KIND OF
RENEWABLE GRID WHERE WE'RE JUST,
YOU KNOW, PAYING THIS NATURAL
GAS SYSTEM BASICALLY AS A WHOLE
SECOND GRID JUST TO KIND OF
STANDBY. AND SO LOOKING AT THIS
PROBLEM, OUR ANALYSTS IDENTIFIED
NEXT GENERATION GEOTHERMAL POWER
AS A KEY PART OF THE SOLUTION
FOR MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AND SAVING OUR CUSTOMERS MONEY.
THERE'S A LOT OF POTENTIAL TO
USE NEW NEXT GEN GEOTHERMAL
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN BE USED IN
MORE PLACES THAN CONVENTIONAL
RESOURCES, USE LESS WATER,
DELIVER A LOT OF OTHER BENEFITS,
AND PROVIDE THOSE ATTRIBUTES
WE'RE CURRENTLY GETTING FROM
FOSSIL FUELS. BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
THERE'S A KIND OF A
SUPERFICIALLY MINOR BUT REALLY
ACTUALLY EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
ANYBODY TRYING TO USE NEXT GEN
GEOTHERMAL IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
SECTION 3007 15.5, WHICH THIS
BILL PROPOSES TO REPEAL. THIS IS
FUNCTIONALLY BANNED. NHIÀU
GEOTHERMAL POWER IN THE STATE
OUTSIDE OF IMPERIAL COUNTY,
WHICH HAS A SPECIAL
DISPENSATION. SO, AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPPIN MENTIONED, THE YOU
KNOW, THE SPECIFIES THAT CAL JIM
HAS TO BE THE LEAD AGENCY SINCE
THE STATE ADOPTED A GOAL OF 100%
CLEAN ENERGY. CAL JIM HAS
APPROVED ZERO NEW GEOTHERMAL
EXPLORATION WELLS IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY, MEANWHILE, WHICH HAS A
SYSTEM WE WANT FOR THE WHOLE
STATE. THEY'VE APPROVED A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER JUST IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS, AB 1359 IS
REALLY JUST A STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL THAT RETURNS GEOTHERMAL
EXPLORATION TO THE NORMAL SEQUA
PROCESS, SAME AS ANY OTHER
PROJECT. THIS IS NOT SEQUEL
STREAMLINING, AND I'LL JUST
CLOSE WITH, YOU KNOW, YOU SEE
REALLY BROAD SUPPORT FROM THE
INDUSTRY. IT WAS TOO LATE FOR
THE ANALYSIS, BUT THE CLIMATE
CENTER ACTUALLY WEIGHED IN IN
SUPPORT. I THINK THERE'S BROAD
RECOGNITION OF THE PROBLEM AND A
DESIRE TO LET THESE NEXT GEN
TECHNOLOGIES HELP US MEET OUR,
OUR CLIMATE GOALS. SO THANK YOU.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ME TOO. TESTIMONY HI. GOOD
MORNING. KENDRA HURST, THE
CLIMATE CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY LEAD.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION? ARE SEEING NONE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. THE MEMBERS? ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? I'D MOST WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAIRD,
SEEING NO SENATOR GROVE, I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THERE'S A
LOT OF TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEING
DEVELOPED RIGHT NOW UNDER
UNDERGROUND STORAGE AND STEAM,
AND HOW IT'S LAST ALMOST 400
DAYS VERSUS JUST FOUR HOURS IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. I THINK
IT'S GREAT TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN
BE DEVELOPED. IF THEY COULD,
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE INVESTORS
WILLING TO PARTICIPATE, BUT
THEY'RE SCARED TO DEATH. THEY'LL
NEVER GET A PERMIT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO THEY'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN INVESTING IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT THEY ARE DOING
IT IN TEXAS. AND I, I THINK
YOU'VE OPENED UP A REAL SOLUTION
HERE. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE. ANYONE ELSE? ALL
RIGHT. I HAVE ONE COMMENT HERE,
THE GEOTHERMAL IS OBVIOUSLY A
POTENTIALLY IMPORTANT RENEWABLE
ENERGY RESOURCE IN THIS STATE,
AND IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE
AN IMPORTANT SOURCE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. SO I'M SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY FOR THOSE REASONS.
AND ALSO BECAUSE THIS BILL DOES
NOT WEAKEN ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW,
BUT SIMPLY SHIFTS THE SECRET
LEAD AGENCY ROLE TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. BUT WITH THAT,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I AM
GOING TO LET TEXAS BEAT US OR
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN EYE
VOTE. CAN'T LET TEXAS BEAT US.
OKAY THANK YOU, WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR LAIRD. THE MOTION
IS Dð PAST ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS. MEN, I MEN I
SALADO ALLEN. DALLY, I DALLY I
EGGMAN EGGMAN I GROVE, GROVE I
HURTADO HURTADO I LAIRD LAIRD I
LEMON PADILLA PADILLA I STERN A
STERN I. ALL RIGHT. THE COUNT IS
EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYWOMAN.
NOTES. OKAY, AND SO I THINK WE
HAVE WE'RE GOING TO GO OUT A
FILE ORDER BECAUSE, ASSEMBLYMAN
HART IS ALLOWING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CONNOLLY TO GO FIRST, MAYBE
THAT'LL GET MADE UP IN THE
SOFTBALL GAME, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CONNOLLY, PRESENTING FILE ITEM
NUMBER 12, AB 2196 ON BEAVER
RESTORATION. ASSEMBLYMAN, YOU
CAN PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. A
HUGE THANK YOU TO MR. HART, GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
WANT TO START BY THANKING
CHAIRMAN AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE FOR THEIR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON THESE AMENDMENTS,
WHICH HAVE MADE THE BILL
STRONGER AND MORE CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOALS AND VISION OF THE
DEPARTMENT. WITH THAT, I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2196
TODAY, WHICH SIMPLY CODIFIES THE
CDF EXISTING BEAVER RESTORATION
PROGRAM, THE IMPORTANCE OF
SOLIDIFYING THE PERMANENCE OF
THIS PROGRAM LIES IN THE
INCREDIBLE IMPACT OF THE NORTH
AMERICAN THAT THE NORTH AMERICAN
BEAVER CAN HAVE ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. ACCORDING TO CDF,
THE BEAVER IS, QUOTE, BOTH AN
ECOSYSTEM ENGINEER HELPING TO
CREATE AND MAINTAIN DIVERSE
HABITAT THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
AND A KEYSTONE SPECIES FILLING A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
MAINTAINING THE ECOSYSTEM FOR
THE OTHER SPECIES THAT DEPEND ON
IT. DAM COMPLEXES CAN HELP
CHANGE WATER FLOW, HELPING TO
CREATE HABITATS FOR RARE AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES, AND CAN
REDUCE THE INTENSITY OF FLOODS,
IMPROVE SOIL HEALTH, REVERSE
EROSION CREATES SUBTERRANEAN
WATER RECHARGE. SIX CHESTER
CARBON AND STOP OR REDUCE THE
SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES, SOMETHING
THAT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN
MY DISTRICT. THESE BENEFITS ARE
PART OF THE STATE'S CLIMATE
SMART STRATEGY AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE'S
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
STRATEGY. RECOGNIZING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OF THESE
ANIMALS, THE ADMINISTRATION AND
CDF W HAVE PRIORITIZED BEAVER
COEXISTENCE AND NONLETHAL
RESPONSES WITH THE CREATION OF
THE BEAVER RESTORATION PROGRAM,
WHICH RECENTLY ACTUALLY RECEIVED
$2 MILLION FOR NON-LETHAL BEAVER
DAMAGE MITIGATION PROJECTS TO
PROMOTE AND ENABLE BEAVER
COEXISTENCE. AB 2196 AGAIN
SIMPLY CODIFIES THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM IN STATUTE TO ENSURE
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS JENNIFER FEARING,
REPRESENTING THE BILL'S SPONSORS
AND ANNALISE RIVERA WITH CAL
TROUT. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS. JENNIFER
FEARING AGAIN HERE. NOW ON
BEHALF OF THE WATER INSTITUTE AT
OCCIDENTAL ARTS AND ECOLOGY
CENTER, URGING YOUR YES VOTE ON
AB 2196. DESPITE THE MANY
BENEFITS THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNELLY DESCRIBED THAT BEAVERS
PROVIDE, UP UNTIL THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS, CALIFORNIA BEAVER
POLICY FOCUSED SOLELY ON
RECREATIONAL HUNTING AND LETHAL
NUISANCE MANAGEMENT. IN
RESPONSE, MY CLIENT OCCIDENTAL
ARTS LAUNCHED A BRING BACK THE
BEAVER CAMPAIGN TO EDUCATE
CITIZENS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEAVER TO IMPROVE WATER SUPPLY
FOR HUMANS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND INCREASE RESILIENCE TO
DROUGHT AND CLIMATE CHANGE. WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH AGENCY
SCIENTISTS, ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS, CONSULTING
BIOLOGISTS, AND INTERESTED
CALIFORNIANS TO SUPPORT EXISTING
BEAVER COLONIES AND, WHERE
APPROPRIATE, REESTABLISH BEAVER
TO ENHANCE WATERSHED RESTORATION
AND SALMON RECOVERY EFFORTS. THE
PACE OF CHANGE IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS, AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT
CONTINUES. THAT'S WHY OAC IS
PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY MORE
THAN 40 ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2196. WE WORK AS
PRACTITIONERS, LAND MANAGERS,
FARMERS, ADVOCATES, AND IN OTHER
WAYS TO COLLABORATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
ON THIS EFFORT TO RESTORE
BEAVERS. WHILE IN SOME CASES,
BEAVERS WILL RETURN TO THEIR OWN
AREAS ONCE THEY THAT THEY ONCE
INHABITED RELOCATE. THÀNH IS
ALSO PART OF THE RESTORATION
STRATEGY, ALONG WITH COEXISTENCE
, HABITAT ENHANCEMENT AND
EXPANSION, AND PROCESS BASED
MIMICRY TO HELP ENSURE THAT THE
FULL COMPLEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS ASSOCIATED WITH BEAVER
RESTORATION REMAINS A STATE AND
DEPARTMENT PRIORITY BEYOND THE
CURRENT BEAVER BELIEVING
ADMINISTRATION, IT IS IMPORTANT
AND VALUABLE TO CODIFY THE CORE
ACTIVITIES DESCRIBED IN THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT
CREATED THE BEAVER RESTORATION
PROGRAM AT THE DEPARTMENT. WE
APPRECIATE THAT AB 296 PURSUES
THIS OBJECTIVE AND ENSURES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP AND
EFFORT OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
WILL CONTINUE AND ENSURE A
LEGACY OF THIS NEW AND ENDURING
CHAPTER OF ECOLOGICAL
LEADERSHIP. MY CLIENT, SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY AND NATIONAL
WILDLIFE FEDERATION, ALSO URGE
YOU TO VOTE AYE ON AB 2196. I
COULD AND OFTEN DO GO ON AND ON
ABOUT BEAVERS, BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME, I WILL STOP
HERE AND I'LL BE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M ANNALISA RIVERO,
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
WITH CALIFORNIA TROUT. CAL TROUT
STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB 2196
BECAUSE OUR SCIENTISTS AND
PARTNERS KNOW FIRSTHAND THE
PROFOUND ECOLOGICAL BENEFITS
BEAVER PROVIDE FOR TROUT, SALMON
AND OTHER FRESHWATER FISH.
BEAVERS ARE REMARKABLE ANIMALS
WHO POSITIVELY IMPACT THE
ENVIRONMENT IN A MYRIAD OF WAYS,
AS DESCRIBED WELL IN THE
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS
PROVISIONS IN AB 2196. INDEED,
THE ADMINISTRATION'S NEW SALMON
STRATEGY INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING.
BEAVER CAN BE IMPORTANT ALLIES
IN SALMON HABITAT RECOVERY.
SALMON AND BEAVER EVOLVED
TOGETHER. BEAVERS CREATE DAMS
THAT IN MANY CASES ALLOW FISH
PASSAGE WHILE CREATING DEEP,
COLD POOLS OF WATER THAT ARE
IDEAL NURSERIES FOR JUVENILE
SALMON. FOR YEARS, SALMON
RESTORATION PROGRAMS HAVE
SUPPORTED BEAVER ANALOG DAMS,
WHERE HUMANS ADD WOODY DEBRIS TO
NORTH COAST STREAMS TO IMPROVE
SALMON HABITAT. IT IS TIME TO
LET NATURE'S BEST ENGINEERS TO
DO SOME OF THIS RESTORATION WORK
IN CERTAIN AREAS AROUND THE
STATE. CALTRANS AGREES AND
THINKS AB 2196 IS SIMPLE.
CODIFICATION OF THE EXISTING
PROGRAM IS HELPFUL TO CONTINUE
POSITIVE MOMENTUM FOR SALMON,
TROUT AND OTHER SPECIES
RESTORATION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ME TO
TESTIMONY, SEEING A LINE? OKAY
GO AHEAD, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, PAT MORAN WITH AARON
REED AND ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS, UAW,
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS. BOB
REEB WITH REEB GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF SOLANO
COUNTY WATER AGENCY, IN SUPPORT
AND REMINDING THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD CONTROL
ASSOCIATION IS FOUND NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL AND APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR IN
GETTING TO THAT POINT. THANK YOU
, MEGAN MICKELBERG ON BEHALF OF
THE MIDPENINSULA OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT, THANK YOU, ISABELLA
GONZALEZ POTTER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND PROUD BEAVER
BELIEVER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA DAVIS. I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE FOR THE BEAVER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THAT'S A HARD
ACT TO FOLLOW, KIM DELFINO
REPRESENTING AUDUBON CALIFORNIA
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE, TROUT
UNLIMITED, AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
SHERRY PEMBERTON, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT ONE
DAY TO RELOCATE BEAVERS ON LANDS
UNDER OUR JURISDICTION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LILY SCURRIA, ON
BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTION COMMITTEE OF WEST MARIN
AND CLEAN WATER ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GENESIS GONZALES, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
LENNY KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MARQUIS
KING MASON, CALIFORNIA.
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANKS THANK YOU. MICHAEL.
JARED, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS AND THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR BIODIVERSITY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. CHRISTINA SCARINGE
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GABRIELA FAZIO
WITH SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SEEING NONE IN THE ROOM. DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
QUITE A LOT OF SUPPORT. NO
OPPOSITION. YOU'VE BEEN VERY
BUSY AS A BEAVER, GOING BACK TO
THE DÍAS. YEAH. THANK YOU. I'LL
BE HERE ALL WEEK, YEAH. SENATOR
DELI, SO I MIGHT HAVE SAID, IT,
I NOTICED THAT. YOU HAVE. YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION. BUT I
DID WANT TO, YOU KNOW, THE NORTH
STATE WHERE WE HAVE, IRRIGATION
CANALS THAT BEAVERS MOVE INTO
AND SOMETIMES, OBSTRUCT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH MOVING
WATER AROUND, THIS ISN'T GOING
TO PROHIBIT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
MANAGE THEIR CANALS. BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE PROBLEMS, WE HAVE TO TRY
TO RELOCATE THEM. AND IT'S HARD.
THEY'RE VERY EFFECTIVE AT
BUILDING DAMS AND STOPPING WATER
WHERE WE WANT WATER TO GO. SO I
NOTICED THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
OFTEN I KNOW THAT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FOLKS WERE PROBABLY
INTERESTED IN THAT AS WELL,
BECAUSE WE'VE CONSTRUCTED THOSE
THOSE WATERWAYS. SO CAN YOU
MAYBE ADDRESS THAT, THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. BUT MISS FERRIN
CAN CONFIRM, MR. CHAIR. YEAH,
YEAH. OF COURSE. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. ACTUALLY, THIS DID
THIS DID COME UP IN THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FOLKS AND THAT WE
ACTUALLY ADDED LANGUAGE TO THE
BILL THAT TO AVOID AND ALLEVIATE
ISSUES WAS A LANGUAGE THAT WE
ADDED TO ADDRESS THAT CONCERN.
I'LL JUST SAY THE PROGRAM ITSELF
IS REALLY BENEFITING FROM THE
KIND OF COLLABORATION AND
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT LANDOWNERS
TO MAKE SURE IT'S BUILT OUT. AND
I'LL SAY THE DEMAND FOR BEAVERS
ON OTHER STATE LANDS GIVES YET
ANOTHER AVENUE FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
HAVING ISSUES, A WAY FOR THOSE
BEAVERS TO POTENTIALLY BE
REMOVED AND RELOCATED TO
WATERSHEDS WHERE THEY CAN DO
THEIR THING AND BE APPRECIATED
FOR IT. COOL. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, WE HAVE SENATOR EGGMAN AND
THEN SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU.
AND I WON'T DO ANY DAD JOKES,
THOSE ARE THOSE HAVE BEEN
COVERED, BUT TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. BEAVERS ARE GOOD. NUTRIA
ARE BAD. RIGHT? BECAUSE NUTRIA
ARE THE ONES THAT GET INTO OUR
OUR LEVEES AND SO, AS I
UNDERSTAND, THE PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED IN THAT SAME AREA.
SO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE'RE
DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN NUTRIA
AND BEERS ARE YET AGAIN CALLING
OUR EXPERT? WELL, FUN FACT THE
WOMAN AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE WHO RUNS WAS TAPPED
TO RUN THE BEAVER RESTORATION
PROGRAM, ALSO RUNS THE NUTRIA
ERADICATION PROGRAM. SO HER
RODENT KARMA IS BEING BALANCED
BY HER LEADERSHIP IN THESE TWO
AREAS. NUTRIA ARE AN INVASIVE
SPECIES. THEY DON'T ACTUALLY
PRODUCE THE SAME KINDS OF WATER
BENEFITS THAT SCIENCE AND
PRACTICE SHOWS THAT BEAVERS ARE
ABLE, WHO ARE A NATIVE SPECIES
IN CALIFORNIA, TO PRODUCE SO I
THINK THE SCIENTISTS AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS WELL AWARE OF THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE TWO AND
ARE WORKING TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS OF ONE AND PROMOTE THE
BENEFITS OF THE OTHER. OKAY.
YEAH. IT'S JUST IT'S JUST
INTERESTING YOU GOT TO KEEP THAT
IN BALANCE, BECAUSE IF YOU LET
THE NUTRIA OUT, THEN WE'VE GOT
WE'VE GOT PROBLEMS IN THE LEVEES
. THANKS FOR THE QUESTION,
SENATOR. SENATOR LAIRD, I WAS
JUST GOING TO SAY THAT, ONE OF
THE SUPPORTERS IS THE SAN LUIS
OBISPO BEAVER BRIGADE, AND I HAD
NEVER HEARD OF THEM. AND WE CAN
MONTHS AGO, THEY INVITED ME OUT
TO THE SALINAS RIVER IN
ATASCADERO. AND WE HIKED TO
WHERE THE BEAVERS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN SORT OF
RESTORING THE HABITAT AND THE
POOLS AND AN AND IT JUST WORKS
AGAINST EVERYTHING. THEY'RE IN A
GOOD WAY. AND I JUST DIDN'T KNOW
THIS EXISTED. AND THEY
REINTRODUCED THEMSELVES THERE
DECADES AND DECADES AGO. AND
THEY HAVE BEEN GOOD NEIGHBORS TO
EVERYBODY, WHETHER IT'S LOCAL
FARMERS, WHETHER IT'S THE FISH.
THERE WAS EVEN SOME BENEFIT ON
FLOOD CONTROL THAT I FOUND HARD
TO IMAGINE, SO, I THINK THIS IS
GREAT. AND IT AND THERE'S REALLY
NEEDS TO BE EDUCATION BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK I MEAN, I HAD THIS
EXPERIENCE THAT STRANGE THAT
THIS OVERTURNED, WHICH IS 40
YEARS AGO WHEN I WENT TO TIERRA
DEL FUEGO, THEY INTRODUCED
BEAVERS. AND WHEN THEY DID IT,
IT DIDN'T OCCUR TO THEM THAT
THERE WERE NO PREDATORS. AND SO
THE BEAVERS HAD TAKEN OVER THE
BACK COUNTRY AND WERE TAKING
DOWN TREES AND BUILDING DAMS AND
DOING THINGS THAT WERE NOT
CONSTRUCTIVE TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THAT WE GET TO
REALIZE THE GOOD BENEFITS OF
THIS. SO I WOULD MOVE THE BILL
IF THERE'S BEEN NO MOTION YET,
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD, ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE ON THE
DAIS, WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR LEHR. ASSEMBLYMAN, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES. THANK
YOU. I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THIS IS KIND OF A FUN BILL, AND
ONE YET THAT HAS ALSO MULTI
BENEFITS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR LAIRD, THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MIN A MIN. AYE. SALADO.
ALLEN. DALLY SALLY. AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE STERN. STERN. AYE.
THE VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, ASSEMBLYMAN. ALL
RIGHT. WE GOT A COUPLE OF BILLS
COMING UP FROM ASSEMBLYMAN
HEARTFALL. ITEMS NUMBER SIX AND
SEVEN, FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX IS
AB 1866. ASSEMBLYMAN HART, YOU
CAN PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 1866, WHICH
ADDRESSES THE URGENT CLIMATE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS OF IDLE OIL
WELLS. AB 1866 REQUIRES OIL
OPERATORS TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO PLUG THE
ESTIMATED 40,000 IDLE OIL WELLS
IN CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL ALSO
REMOVES THE OPTION TO PAY AS
LITTLE AS $150 PER WELL, TO
AVOID SUBMITTING A PLAN ON OVER
HALF OF THE IDLE WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT PRODUCED OIL
IN DECADES, ACCORDING TO STATE
DATA. THE NUMBER OF IDLE WELLS
CONTINUES TO GROW YEAR AFTER
YEAR. IT MAY TAKE OVER A CENTURY
TO PLUG ALL IDLE WELLS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW, MANY OF THESE WELLS
ARE AT HIGH RISK OF BECOMING
ORPHAN, WHICH MEANS THAT THEY
WILL BE LEFT WITHOUT A FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBLE OWNER. A PROACTIVE
APPROACH IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS FROM THE
ESTIMATED $10 BILLION IN COSTS
TO PLUG THESE WELLS SHOULD THEY
BECOME ORPHANED. THE BENEFITS OF
AB 1866 EXTEND BEYOND TAXPAYER
PROTECTION. PLUGGING IDLE OIL
WELLS PRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY TO STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND CREATE
JOBS. A RECENT STUDY REVEALED
THAT PLUGGING THESE WELLS COULD
CREATE OVER 24,000 JOBS
STATEWIDE. IDLE OIL WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA ACT AS A MAJOR SOURCE
OF METHANE GAS EMISSIONS.
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATE OCEAN
AND AIR POLLUTION. BY ONE
ESTIMATE, ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
THE UNPLUGGED OIL WELLS ARE
LEAKING METHANE, A CLIMATE SUPER
POLLUTANT OVER 80 TIMES STRONGER
THAN CARBON DIOXIDE. AB 1866
ALSO REQUIRES OPERATORS TO
PRIORITIZE PLUGGING WELLS WITHIN
3200FT OF WHERE COMMUNITIES LIVE
, WORK, AND PLAY. THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
HIGHER RATES OF CANCER, BIRTH
DEFECTS, AND OTHER ILLNESSES DUE
TO OIL PRODUCTION. THE FACTS ARE
CLEAR THIS SERIOUS PROBLEM IS
GETTING WORSE AND CAN'T BE
IGNORED. AB 1866 IS NECESSARY TO
SOLVE THE IDLE WELL CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS PROACTIVE
SOLUTION WILL PROTECT TAXPAYERS,
CREATE THOUSANDS OF JOBS AND
SAFEGUARD COMMUNITIES. WITH ME
TODAY IS KYLE FARRAR WITH
FRACTRACKER AND CHRISTINA
SCARINGE WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH.
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU, GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIRPERSON MINH AND
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS KYLE FARRAR. I'M THE
WESTERN PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT THE
NONPROFIT FRACTRACKER ALLIANCE.
WE FOCUS ON DATA TRANSPARENCY
AND SUPPORT SMART LEGISLATION
LIKE THIS. SO I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF 1866 AND WANT TO
PROVIDE MY EXPERTISE ON THE OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY'S COST OF
CLEANUP AND THE RISK OF IDLE
WELLS TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 100,000
UNPLUGGED WELLS IN CALIFORNIA,
AND IT WOULD TAKE MORE THAN $23
BILLION TO PROPERLY PLUG THESE
WELLS AND RESTORE THE SITES TO
THE PRIOR CONDITION. BUT THE
INDUSTRY HAS ONLY SET ASIDE A
TINY FRACTION OF FINANCIAL
RESOURCES IN BONDS. PRODUCTION
IS DECREASING, AND ACCORDING TO
INDUSTRY REPORTS, MOST PROFITS
WILL BE REALIZED WITHIN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS. IMPORTANTLY THESE
PROFITS WILL NOT EVEN COVER HALF
OF THE FUNDS NEEDED FOR THE
INDUSTRY TO PAY FOR CLEANUP.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE CURRENT LAWS
FOR IDLE WELLS AREN'T WORKING.
NUMBER OF IDLE WELLS KEEP
INCREASING BECAUSE OPERATORS ARE
ALLOWED TO PAY A NOMINAL FEE.
INSTEAD OF PLUGGING A WELL,
OPERATORS CAN VOLUNTARILY SUBMIT
A PLUGGING PLAN FOR THEIR OLDEST
IDLE WELLS, BUT THOSE PLANS ONLY
REQUIRE OPERATORS TO PLUG 4 TO
6% OF THE WELLS AND JUST THEIR
OLDEST WELLS, AND THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN IDLE FOR AT LEAST
EIGHT YEARS. ONLY ABOUT 56 OUT
OF THE ROUGHLY 1200 OPERATORS IN
THE STATE. THAT'S LESS THAN 5%
ACTUALLY CHOSE TO SUBMIT ANY
PLAN AT ALL THIS LAST YEAR. SO
EVEN IF ALL THE OPERATORS OPTED
TO SUBMIT A PLAN AND PLUGGED
WELLS AT THE MINIMUM RATES, IT
WOULD TAKE OVER A CENTURY TO
PLUG JUST THE 40,000 IDLE WELLS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE. NOW,
THAT DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE ADDITIONAL 60,000
OPERATIONAL WELLS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WILL BE IDLED IN THE
FUTURE. THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
ALREADY PRODUCING LOW MARGINAL
VOLUMES UNDER 1866. OPERATORS
CAN NO LONGER OPT OUT OF THE
PLUGGING REQUIREMENTS. THOSE
REQUIREMENTS WILL BE RAMPED UP
TO 10 TO 20% OF ALL IDLE WELLS.
THIS WILL LEAD TO AT LEAST 6000
WELLS BEING PLUGGED IN JUST THE
FIRST YEAR. NEARLY 5000 OF THOSE
WELLS WILL BE PLUGGED BY THE TOP
SIX LARGEST OPERATORS IN THE
STATE. IN CONTRAST, IN 2021,
ONLY 27 WELLS WERE 2700 WELLS
WERE PLUGGED, PLUGGING ALL THE
WELLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THAT'D
BE GREAT. ABSOLUTELY INCLUDING
THE ONES CURRENTLY ACTIVE RESULT
IN MORE THAN 50,000 JOBS.
ACTUALLY ACCORDING TO A SIERRA
CLUB REPORT. AND THOSE NUMBERS
ALIGNED WITH MY OWN
CALCULATIONS. THE DATA SHOWS
THAT WE MUST ACT MORE
AGGRESSIVELY IN 1866, JUST DOES
JUST THAT BY RAMPING UP,
PLUGGING REQUIREMENTS ON ALL
OPERATORS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING TO THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTINA SCARINGE WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
WE PROUDLY SPONSOR AB 1866, A
CRITICAL BILL TO TACKLE THE
BALLOONING IDLE WELL CRISIS HEAD
ON TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. ADDRESS A
LOOMING FISCAL BOMBSHELL. CREATE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS FOR
TRANSITIONING WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES, AND TO FIGHT THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. THIS BILL IS A
RARE QUADRUPLE WIN FOR THE
STATE. CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT
40,000 IDLE WELLS AND ANOTHER
60,000 ACTIVE WELLS THAT WILL BE
IDLE SOON. MOST HERE DON'T
PRODUCE ENOUGH TO EVEN BE
CONSIDERED A BREAK. EVEN
STRIPPER WELL, BUT ALL POSE
SERIOUS THREATS TO OUR HEALTH,
ECONOMY AND ENVIRONMENT. WELLS
OFTEN LEAK BENZENE AND OTHER
HARMFUL CHEMICALS. AN ESTIMATED
TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA'S IDLE
WELLS LEAK METHANE SUMMIT
EXPLOSIVE LEVELS, POLLUTING
CLIMATE BONDS THAT ENDANGER
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS A SERIOUS
FISCAL RISK. OIL AND GAS
COMPANIES ARE LEGALLY AND
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE TO PLUG
THEIR WELLS AND RESTORE WELLS
SITES, BUT IT FAILED TO SET
ASIDE THE NECESSARY FUNDS TO DO
SO. THIS LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
SPENT AT LEAST 100 MILLION
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO PAY FOR
THEIR INDUSTRY CLEANUP
OBLIGATIONS. IT'S A PROJECTED 23
BILLION TO PROPERLY CLEAN THEM
ALL, BUT INDUSTRY BONDS COVER
ONLY ABOUT 1. IF COMPANIES TRY
TO EVADE THEIR DUTIES THROUGH
BANKRUPTCY OR OTHER BAD FAITH
MANEUVERING, BILLIONS FALL TO
THE PUBLIC EACH YEAR. WE FAIL TO
ADDRESS TO ACT INCREASES THE
TOTAL COST AND THE RISK TO
TAXPAYERS. AB 1866 PROTECTS
CALIFORNIANS HEALTH, COMMUNITIES
AND POCKETBOOKS BY MANDATING
THEY CLEAN UP AT LEAST A PORTION
OF THEIR WELLS, EACH YEAR. IT
ENDS THE STATUS QUO INCENTIVE
FOR COMPANIES TO CHOOSE A MINOR
FEE TO AVOID THE GREATER COST OF
CLEANUP. THIS BILL IS
PROPORTIONAL, EXPECTING MORE
FROM THOSE WITH THE MOST WHO
BENEFITED THE MOST. IT
PRIORITIZES PLUGGING THOSE MOST
DANGEROUS TO FRONT LINE
COMMUNITIES AND PROTECTS
TAXPAYERS BY PLACING THE FINAL
FINANCIAL BURDEN WHERE IT
BELONGS ON THE POLLUTERS WHO
CREATED AND PROFITED FROM THIS
MESS. THIS IS A JOB CREATOR.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS FOR
TRANSITIONING WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES FOR DECADES TO COME
WITH THANKS TO THE AUTHOR, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ME TO TESTIMONY. LIMIT
IT TO YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION,
POSITION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
KENDRA HARRIS, THE CLIMATE
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, SAVANNAH
JORGENSEN, ON BEHALF OF THE
LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC
POLICY, CALIFORNIA, IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TINA
GALLAGHER FOR 350 SACRAMENTO AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JAN
WARREN, INTERFAITH CLIMATE
ACTION NETWORK A CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU M.J. KUSHNER WITH COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, KATHY KERRIDGE FOR 350 BAY
AREA STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
DOCTOR BONNIE HAMILTON FOR
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY, SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA FOR CLIMATE REALITY,
CALIFORNIA COALITION, AND FOR
CLIMATE REALITY, BAY AREA
CHAPTER IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GABRIELA
FAZIO IS HERE. CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JOSH GEIGER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF SANTA BARBARA AND
VENTURA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MARK FENSTERMAKER FOR
EARTHJUSTICE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEGAN MICKELBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
DARRELL LITTLE, ON BEHALF OF
NRDC IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SYLVIA SOLIS, CHAU,
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF GOLETA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
RAJNIKANTH, WITH THE JUNIOR
PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, ERIN RIGALI
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
DOCTOR WILLIAM PEVEC, CLIMATE
HEALTH NOW, A COALITION OF OVER
900 CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE THANK YOU PATIENTS. THANK
YOU, MARQUIS KING MASON,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS.
AND I HAVE A LAUNDRY LIST,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE PHYSICIAN FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY. LÀ STAND LÀ AND
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER.
THANKS THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
JUST ONE. OR DO WE HAVE TWO,
TWO. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH. AND YOU CAN CHAIR
AND MEMBER SEAN WALLENTINE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION, RODENT
KARMA WAS MENTIONED EARLIER. I
TAKE OFFENSE TO THAT. AS AN OIL
LOBBYIST, YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
LAUGH. IT'S OKAY. HEY, THE IDLE
WELL MANAGEMENT PLAN PROGRAM WAS
DEVELOPED IN 2016 BY THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOSS WILLIAMS,
UNDER THE WATCHFUL EYE OF MR.
CHAIR, SENATOR JOHN LAIRD, WHO
WAS THE RESOURCES SECRETARY AT
THE TIME. AND I'M HAPPY TO
REPORT TO YOU ALL GOOD NEWS THAT
THE PROGRAM IS WORKING
SPLENDIDLY. OPERATORS WHO ARE
MEMBER MEMBERS OF OUR TRADE
ASSOCIATION ARE ARE AGGRESSIVELY
PLUGGING IDLE WELLS. AND IN FACT
, WE'VE PLUGGED A RECORD NUMBER
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS ALONE,
WE'VE PLUGGED 11,032 OIL WELLS,
SPENDING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
OUR DOLLARS TO PLUG THOSE WELLS.
AND WE HAVE EXCEEDED THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT CAL GEM
REQUIRES IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE
IDLE WELL MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. SO
WHEN I SAW THIS BILL INTRODUCED,
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED BECAUSE
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WE
COMPLEMENT CAL JIM ABOUT. AND
CAL JIM ACTUALLY COMPLEMENTS US
ABOUT BECAUSE WE'RE ACTUALLY
EXCEEDING THE REQUIRED,
PERCENTAGES. WHAT WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE HAPPEN IS TO BE LOCKED
IN TO THE EXTRA CREDIT, SO TO
SPEAK, THAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
AND SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY
GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT YOU
HAVE ALL ASKED OF US, AND THEN
LOCK US INTO A MUCH HIGHER PACE,
WHICH IS THEN GOING TO BANKRUPT
US AND DO EXACTLY WHAT THE
SUPPORTERS SAID WOULD HAPPEN,
AND THAT THAT WOULD MEAN WE
WOULD LEAVE IDLE WELLS. I DO
WANT TO MAKE A POINT TOO, ABOUT
THE FEE OPTION. I'VE HEARD THE
USE OF THE WORD AVOID IN 2016,
WHEN THE IDLE WELL MANAGEMENT
PLAN WAS WAS THOUGHTFULLY
DEVELOPED BY THIS COMMITTEE, AND
THIS LEGISLATION FEATURE, THE
FEE OPTION WASN'T TO AVOID AN
IDLE WELL MANAGEMENT PLAN. THE
FEE OPTION WAS SO THAT OPERATORS
HAD FLEXIBILITY TO LOOK AT IDLE
WELLS, WHICH ARE ASSETS WHICH
CAN CONTINUE TO START TO WRAP
UP. OKAY SO I'M IN THE WEIRD
POSITION OF ASKING THE AUTHOR
AND THIS COMMITTEE TO KEEP THE
FEE. THE OIL INDUSTRY IS ASKING
YOU TO KEEP A FEE. WE WOULD LIKE
THE FLEXIBILITY OF THE FEE. AND
THERE'S $25 MILLION IN THE WAF,
WHICH IS 100% OUR MONEY, WHICH
WE'VE DEPOSITED THERE. SO THAT
ORPHAN WELLS CAN BE PLUGGED BY
CAL JIM. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, PAUL DERA, REPRESENTING
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. I THINK THERE'S A
CONFLATION OF ISSUES WITH A
NARRATIVE THAT IS VERY
MISLEADING. THERE IS NO CRISIS
WITH EXISTING IDLE WELLS. IDLE
WELLS ARE PERMITTED. THEY ARE
REGULATED. THEY ARE TESTED. SO
IF TWO THIRDS OF IDLE WELLS ARE
ARE RELEASE METHANE, THAT'S NEWS
TO ME. AND THEY BETTER BE SHUT
DOWN. I WOULD SUPPORT SHUTTING
ALL OF THOSE WELLS DOWN THAT ARE
LEAKING, TO AN EXTENT THAT THAT
IS COMPLETELY UNTRUE. THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN IN THE
CONFLATION OF AN ISSUE, I
BELIEVE, IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN AN IDLE WELL AND AN
ORPHAN. WELL, AN IDLE WELL, AS I
SAID, IS REGULATED, AN IDLE WELL
IS AN ASSET. AND AS WE LOOK AT
OUR OUR PRODUCTION PORTFOLIO, WE
ARE LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVE USES
FOR THOSE IDLE WELLS, INCLUDING
HYDROGEN STORAGE, RENEWABLE
ENERGY, WATER PROJECTS, SO BY
PREMATURELY PLUGGING IN AN IDLE
WELL TAKES THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
AWAY. NOT, NOT, NOT TO SAY CCS
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY LOOKING AT. SO I
THINK THE NARRATIVE OF IDLE
WELLS BEING BEING HAZARDOUS AND,
AND IS IN A CRISIS STATE IS A
FALSE NARRATIVE, WE, WE I MEAN,
WE WILL HELP. I MEAN, WE WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR BEFORE AND HIS
OTHER BILLS, HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR ON ADDRESSING THE
REAL PROBLEM, WHICH IS 5300
WELLS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED BY
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY TO BE
ORPHAN WELLS WHICH DO NOT HAVE A
RESPONSIBLE, OPERATOR TO PLUG
AND ABANDON THAT. WELL, THAT'S
THE PROBLEM. IDLE WELLS ARE NOT.
THANK WE URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ME TO TESTIMONY,
NAME, AFFILIATION, OPPOSITION,
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. CLIFTON
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS, SENATOR GROVE, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
GUESS, REPRESENTING THE FACTORY
FLOOR OF CALIFORNIA, 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL, PRODUCE OCEAN, I
GUESS. WELL, IT'S MUCH LOWER NOW
WITHOUT PERMITS, BUT, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE WORKING HARD FOR NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND SOME OF THE STUFF
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, LIKE
THE OPPOSITION SAID, WHEN IT
LOOKS AT, YOU KNOW, THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ORPHAN AND
IDLE WELLS AND ORPHAN, WELL, IS
SOMEONE WHO HAS ABANDONED THAT
WELL AND IT'S GONE. AND THAT'S
WHY THE INDUSTRY IT'S THIS IS NO
GENERAL FUND MONEY. SO WHEN THE
WHEN THE OPPOSITION SAYS
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE ON THE
LINE, THAT'S NOT TRUE. CAL JIM
IS 100% INDUSTRY FUNDED. THEY
DON'T GET ONE DIME FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. AND THERE'S $25
MILLION IN THERE TO ADDRESS THE
5300, ABANDONED WELLS, THE IDLE
WELLS THAT ARE EITHER IDLE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
PERMIT, IDLE BECAUSE IT'S AN
ASSET AND THEY'RE TRYING TO, YOU
KNOW, REINVIGORATE THAT. WELL
THE IDLE WELL IS STILL SOMETHING
THAT IS VERY VIABLE. THERE'S
ALSO NEW TECHNOLOGY LIKE THE
BILL THAT WE JUST PASSED TO,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPINEAU'S BILL
TO ALLOW GEOTHERMAL AND TO LET
IT GO TO LOCAL JURISDICTION SO
THAT WE CAN DEVELOP GEOTHERMAL.
THERE'S NEW TECHNOLOGY IN KERN
COUNTY WITH AN ORGANIZATION THAT
IS BRINGING IN, STEAM GENERATED
JUST LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN
UNDERSTOOD ON MAKING SURE THAT
THAT'S TRAPPED INSIDE THE OIL,
THE CAVITY ITSELF, WHERE WE
CAN'T PRODUCE OIL ANYMORE
BECAUSE WE'RE IMPORTING IT FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES ON THE USE
THAT WE HAVE EVERY DAY. BUT TO
TRAP THAT STEAM THERE, AND IT
PROVIDES ALMOST 400 DAYS OF
BATTERY STORAGE, LIKE 400 DAYS
OF STORAGE, NOT FOUR HOURS.
THEY'VE TESTED IT IN TEXAS.
THEY'RE WORKING ON IT. THEY WANT
TO DEVELOP IT HERE. THERE'S
RESOURCES TO DEVELOP HERE. WE
HAVE THE FIELDS TO DEVELOP IT
HERE. BUT WE CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET A PERMIT OR BILLS
LIKE THIS WILL PASS. THAT DIDN'T
ALLOW YOU TO USE THOSE ASSETS,
BECAUSE ONCE YOU DUMP CEMENT
DOWN THIS HOLE, IT'S OVER. IT
TAKES A LOT TO GET IT BACK. SO
HAVING IDLE AND ORPHAN IN THE
SAME SENTENCE IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS EVEN CONDUCIVE, AND IT'S
NOT BENEFICIAL TO THE RENEWABLE
ENERGY INDUSTRY, AND IT'S NOT
BENEFICIAL TO THE ABANDONED
FIELDS THAT OR THE FIELDS THAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
ALMOST NONOPERATIONAL BECAUSE OF
THE PERMIT SITUATION AND
TRANSITIONING OFF OF
DOMESTICALLY PRODUCED FUEL HERE
AND IMPORTING IT FROM FOREIGN
SOURCES, SO TO SAY THAT, IT'S
LIKE I SAID, TAXPAYER FUNDED IS
COMPLETELY WRONG BECAUSE THERE
IS $5,300 ON THE FEE. 50 EXCUSE
ME, $25 MILLION ON THE FEE
PROGRAM THAT HASN'T BEEN USED
THAT WILL TAKE CARE OF THOSE
TRULY ORPHAN WELLS THAT THE
OPERATORS HAVE JUST LEFT, THE
OTHER THING IS, IS THAT DO YOU
THINK THAT, DO YOU THINK THAT IT
CAUSES CONFLICT WITH SB 1433,
WHICH IS A LIMÓN BILL THAT WAS
JUST PASSED, I BELIEVE LAST YEAR
, WE ACTUALLY WE JUST GOT IT
THROUGH AND I THINK THE GOVERNOR
JUST SIGNED IT. WE JUST PASSED
IT OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT
GRAVITY BASED WELLS. SO SO,
THEY'RE TAKING A LOT OF IDLE
WELLS, AND THEY'RE TURNING THEM
TO GRAVITY BASED WELLS. AND THAT
WAS A BILL THAT A SENATOR ON OUR
SIDE HAD. AND WE ALL PASSED THAT
BILL. AND THEN YOUR BILL
CIRCUMVENTS THAT. SO CAN YOU
EXPLAIN WHY YOU WOULD DO THAT, I
GUESS I WOULD START WITH, SAYING
THAT THE IDLE WELLS ARE IDLE FOR
A REASON BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
PRODUCING OIL AND THAT THE
COMPANIES HAVE A CHOICE UNDER
THIS LEGISLATION, OF WHICH IDLE
WELLS TO ADDRESS OVER A TEN YEAR
PERIOD. SO THEY GET TO DECIDE
WHICH OF THOSE ASSETS THEY WANT
TO, YOU KNOW, PLUG NOW VERSUS IN
THE FUTURE AND THAT THE NUMBER
OF ALTERNATIVE ENERGY PROJECTS
THAT WOULD BE USING IDLE WELLS
IS A VERY SMALL NUMBER, AND THE
COMPANIES WOULD BE ABLE TO
PRESERVE THOSE ASSETS THEY THINK
ARE ADEQUATE TO MEET THAT FUTURE
NEED BY MAKING THE CHOICE
INTERNALLY WITH THEIR COMPANY AS
TO WHICH OF THESE IDLE OIL WELLS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO CLOSE.
THERE ARE LITERALLY THOUSANDS,
40,000 IDLE WELLS IN CALIFORNIA.
THOSE REPRESENT HOLES IN THE
GROUND THAT LEAK THAT NEED TO BE
PLUGGED IN ORDER FOR THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY SYSTEMS THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING, WHERE YOU'RE
USING PRESSURIZED GAS, YOU CAN'T
HAVE A BUNCH OF, IDLE OIL, WELL,
HOLES INTO THOSE CAVERNS THAT
ARE GOING TO HOLD PRESSURIZED
GAS. THEY HAVE TO BE CLOSED, IN
ORDER FOR THAT SYSTEM TO WORK.
SO I THINK THESE THINGS CAN WORK
VERY WELL TOGETHER. AND REALLY,
WHAT THIS IS DOING IS SAYING,
YOU KNOW, TO INDUSTRY, YOU KNOW,
PLAN AHEAD, FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THE
IDLE WELLS THAT YOU HAVE THAT
AREN'T IN PRODUCTION. IT DOESN'T
AFFECT THE OIL WELLS THAT ARE IN
PRODUCTION. YOU HAVE A CHOICE.
YOU CAN PUT THESE WELLS BACK
INTO PRODUCTION IF YOU DECIDE
THAT THERE IS A USE FOR THEM.
IT'S NOT DRIVING THAT CHOICE.
THEY HAVE THAT DECISION. BUT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN LIMBO AND THE
WELLS ARE NOT BEING, PROPERLY
ABANDONED IN THE WAY THAT THEY
SHOULD BE. YOU CAN'T EVEN GET IN
A MAINTENANCE PERMIT, SO YOU
HAVE TO IDLE A WELL OR PUT
SOMETHING OUT ASIDE, BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A MAINTENANCE
PERMIT OR A SHALL ISSUE FROM
CAL. JIM. SO I THINK THE, IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN, THE LAST RIG,
THERE'S ONLY THREE OPERATIONAL
RIGS THAT I KNOW OF IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT I WOULD
LIKE SOMEBODY TO ADDRESS THAT,
THAT RUNS AN OIL FIELD, IF YOU
WOULD. IS THAT TRUE? WHAT IS THE
WHAT IS THE NUMBER? BUT THROUGH
THE CHAIR. I'M SORRY. YES. YOU
MAY ANSWER THE QUESTION. THANK
YOU, SENATOR GROVE THERE. I
DON'T KNOW THE EXACT AMOUNT, BUT
THERE ARE FEW. THERE ARE FEW.
OKAY, SO WE WENT FROM AND I
GUESS I JUST SAY THAT I TOOK A
TOUR OF A FIELD IN MY DISTRICT
AND USED TO RUN ACROSS THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE, SECOND CHANCERS. AND
I DIDN'T. WE DIDN'T SEE ONE WORK
CREW BECAUSE THERE'S SO FEW
WELLS OPERATING LIKE DRILLING
RIGS OPERATING. AND I GUESS MY
OTHER THING IS, IS THAT WHEN
THERE WAS A NEGOTIATED DEAL ON
SB 1866, EXCUSE ME, WHEN THERE
WAS A NEGOTIATED DEAL WITH THE
PREVIOUS PIECE OF LEGISLATION,
THÀNH, SORRY, THE PREVIOUS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE WHAT WAS NEGOTIATED IN 2016
WAS WAS THE OIL WELL MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM. A LOT OF OUR SMALLER OR
MID-LEVEL INDEPENDENT OPERATORS
HAVE OR ABANDONED A LOT OF THOSE
WELLS, LIKE THEY TOOK THE
INITIATIVE TO DO THAT, LIKE FOR
INSTANCE, IT WAS ONLY REQUIRED
FOR A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE, WHICH
IS LOWER, BUT THEY'VE OR LIKE
SIPP OPERATORS HAVE DONE, YOU
KNOW, 28% OF THEIR WELLS. SO I
GUESS YOU'RE GOING TO HOLD THEM
TO A HIGHER STANDARD. BUT
THEY'RE THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO TRANSFER SOME OF THE
WELLS. THEY'VE ALREADY THEY'VE
ALREADY CLOSED OR YOU KNOW, YOU
KNOW, ABANDONED PROPERLY INTO
THIS NEW LAW THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET PASSED, AND THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT
PREVIOUSLY BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO GET CREDIT FOR
THAT, AND THEY'VE ALREADY GONE
TO THE EXPENSE TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. DOES THAT I MEAN, ARE
YOU AWARE OF THAT OR DOES THAT
BOTHER YOU AT ALL OR. I'M
ENCOURAGED BY THAT. I THINK THAT
IT'S GOOD THAT THE INDUSTRY IS
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
IDLE WELLS THAT THEY HAVE, AND
PLUGGING THEM PROPERLY, AND WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS SAY CONTINUE
THAT. SO IF THE IF THE POINT
BEING MADE BY THE OPPONENTS IS
THAT WE'RE DOING IT, THEN THIS
BILL ISN'T GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM. THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO, BUT THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO GET CREDIT. THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO GET CREDIT FOR THE PAST, BUT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET CREDIT FOR
THAT SAME WORK GOING FORWARD.
BUT THEY AND THE POINT IS WE
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. WE CAN'T JUST LET IT SIT
UNATTENDED FOR THE NEXT 40
YEARS. THERE'S AN IMPERATIVE TO
FIX THESE WELLS THAT THESE
COMPANIES DRILLED IF THEY
BELIEVE THEY ARE, ASSETS THAT
ARE NO LONGER PRODUCTIVE, THEN
THEY NEED TO CLOSE THOSE WELLS.
IF THEY ARE PRODUCTIVE, THEY CAN
OPEN THEM UP AND THAT THAT'S
THEIR CHOICE. THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO DRILL. IT'S NOT THEIR CHOICE.
A LOT OF THESE WELLS ARE IDLE
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET PERMITS
TO OPERATE THEM. BUT IF THINGS
CHANGE IN CALGARY, I'M EXERCISES
THE SEQUA, PROGRAM THAT THEY'RE
PUTTING IN PLACE. AND I MEAN, I
KNOW THERE WILL BE CHALLENGES
LEGALLY, THEN THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO OPEN UP SOME OF THESE WELLS,
BUT YOU'RE REQUIRING THEM TO
SHUT THEM DOWN BEFORE THAT EVEN
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAPPEN.
THIS BILL HAS A TEN YEAR
LIFESPAN THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
CHOOSE WHICH WELLS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO ABANDON AND PLUG OVER
THAT TEN YEAR PLAN. SO THE
BILLS, THE WELLS THAT ARE
MARGINAL THAT THEY MAY CONSIDER
REOPENING, WE'LL HAVE THERE WILL
BE TIME TO WORK WITH THEM TO GET
THE PERMITS TO REACTIVATE THOSE
WELLS AND THIS IS A NEW
REGULATORY SCHEME WITHIN CAL
GEMS TO HANDLE THIS ISSUE. SO I
THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, IN A
PERFECT WORLD, THOSE TWO THAT
SAME REGULATORY AGENCY WOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE TWO ISSUES
AND HOW THEY'RE CONNECTED. OKAY.
JUST LIKE I SAID, I JUST
DISAGREE WITH THE FACT THAT YOU
THAT THESE STATEMENTS ARE MADE
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, METHANE LEAKED
WELLS THERE ARE THERE ARE NONE.
IF THERE ARE, I'D LIKE TO SEE
THE FACTS AND THE PROOF OF THAT,
THERE, YOU KNOW, THE OIL
INDUSTRY HAS AGAIN ON THE 2016
LEGISLATION, THEY'VE ABANDONED
MORE AND INPUTTED $25 MILLION
INTO THIS FUND SO THAT IF
SOMEBODY DID LEAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND, LIKE, ACTUALLY
MAKE AN ORPHAN, WELL, THAT THERE
WOULD BE RESOURCES PAID BY
INDUSTRY TO COVER THAT. AND
AGAIN, CAL JIM IS 100% INDUSTRY
FUNDED AND SO TO SAY THAT THE
TAXPAYERS ARE ON THE HOOK FOR
THIS IS JUST NOT CORRECT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR GROVE. I THE ONLY
THING I WOULD ADD IS THAT THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE BEEN ON THE HOOK
FOR PLUGGING ABANDONED OIL
WELLS. THERE IS NOT SUFFICIENT
FUNDING IN THAT PROGRAM TO COVER
ALL OF THE ORPHAN OIL WELLS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THERE
ARE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOLLARS,
STATE GOVERNMENT DOLLARS GOING
TO PLUG THOSE WELLS. WE'LL HAVE
TO DISAGREE. BUT THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE. WE
HAVE QUITE A LONG QUEUE HERE. SO
I'M GOING TO MOVE TO DALLI TO
EGGMAN LAIRD. ANYONE ELSE WANT
TO? SHE SCOOPED YOU STERN. THANK
YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU,
ASSEMBLYMAN. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FIRST. NUMBER ONE. I
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE. YOU TALK
ABOUT IDLE. WELL, WHICH IS CAN
STILL BE IN PRODUCTION, AND IT
MAY NOT BE RIGHT NOW, BUT IT
COULD BE IN PRODUCTION. SO I
WANT TO I WANT TO BE BACK IN
PRODUCTION. RIGHT. SO AND THEN I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT ORPHANED AND
ABANDONED. SO I SIT ON SUB TWO
WHICH IS THE FINANCES THAT GOES
THROUGH FOR NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND WE TALK A LOT WITH KALGAN
ACTUALLY COMES TO OUR OUR
MEETINGS. AND I'VE BEEN ON THAT
COMMITTEE FOR SOME TIME, AND
I'VE BEEN VERY FRUSTRATED WITH
THE FACT THAT, WITH KALGAN AND
GETTING THESE ABANDONED AND,
AND, AND ORPHANED WELLS NOT
IDLE. SO YOUR BILL IS FOCUSED ON
IDLE WELLS, WHICH I THINK IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
TALKED ABOUT HERE, BECAUSE THOSE
WELLS ARE ACTUALLY AN ASSET. CAN
THEY CAN REPURPOSE THOSE OR THEY
CAN USE THEM FOR PRODUCTION. SO,
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WE HEARD THE
TESTIMONY. SO MY QUESTION IS, IS
THE DATA THAT YOU, THAT YOU YOU
PUT OUT IN YOUR IN YOUR
PROPONENTS PUT OUT IS THAT ON
IDLE WELLS OR THAT'S ON ORPHAN
AND ABANDONED WELLS, I DON'T
KNOW SPECIFICALLY WHICH POINT
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE, BUT IT'S
PROBABLY ALL OF THE ABOVE. WELL,
IT MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE,
BECAUSE IF IT'S ABANDONED, THAT
MEANS THAT THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE
A FUND THAT THE THAT THE THAT
THE OIL COMPANIES PUT INTO THAT,
THAT PLUG ABANDONED WELLS THAT
THEY DIDN'T, WEREN'T EVEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR. SO THERE'S A
FUND FOR THAT. NUMBER ONE,
THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER FUND THAT
THEY PUT IN MONEY FOR THEIR
FOOTING, A BIG BILL HERE FOR
SOME OF THEIRS. THAT'S NOT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY. SO I WANT TO
MAKE IT. WE NEED TO BE TALKING
ABOUT WHICH BUCKETS ARE COMING
UP. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT IDLE
WELLS, THAT'S AN ASSET. THAT'S
AN ASSET THAT THEY MAY USE IN
THE FUTURE, AND SO I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. SO NOW WHAT DOES
YOUR BILL ADDRESS IDLE,
ABANDONED OR ORPHANED OR ALL OF
THE ABOVE. IDLE WELLS ONLY IDLE
WELLS. AND YOUR POINT THAT IT IS
AN ASSET IS TRUE. IT IS ALSO A
LIABILITY. AND IT CAN BE BOTH.
AND THE POINT IS FOR THE OIL
COMPANIES TO DECIDE WHAT THEY
ARE AND TO PLUG PROPERLY THE
IDLE WELLS THAT ARE NO LONGER AN
ASSET THAT ARE LIABILITY BEFORE
THEY BECOME ORPHAN WELLS THAT
FALL TO THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH THE
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN
CONTRIBUTED BY THE OIL
COMPANIES, THAT IS INADEQUATE TO
MEET THAT NEED. WELL, I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I WANT TO
COMMEND THE OIL COMPANIES FOR,
NUMBER ONE, TAKING CARE OF
ABANDONED WELLS THAT YOU WEREN'T
EVEN RESPONSIBLE FOR. AND, AND
ORPHAN WELLS, AND I SIT ON SUB
TWO FOR THE LAST THREE BUDGET
CYCLES, THE OIL COMPANIES HAVE
PUT UP THE MONEY TO HAVE CALGAN
HIRE THE FOLKS TO COME OUT AND
ACTUALLY REGULATE THEM. AND YOU
KNOW HOW MANY THEY HIRED IN THE
LAST THREE BUDGET CYCLES? 12.
BUT THEY'VE PAID FOR 50, ALMOST
50 A YEAR. I THINK IT WAS IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. SO I JUST
WANT TO I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL BECAUSE I THINK I
THINK THAT WE'RE WE'RE YOU KNOW,
WE TALK ABOUT THE, THE CLIMATE
AND ALL THE PROBLEMS. AND I
THINK THE OIL COMPANIES HAVE
STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE AND
THEY'RE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
AND TO THEIR TESTIMONY, THEY
GAVE 11,000 WELLS HAVE BEEN
PLUGGED SINCE 2016. THAT'S
THAT'S AWESOME. BUT BEFORE THAT
THERE WAS VERY FEW PLUGGED. AND
WE'VE MOVED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND I THINK WE NEED
TO GIVE THEM A CHANCE, TO, TO
CONTINUE TO DO WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND ALLOW THEM TO USE
THOSE ASSETS, THOSE THE, THE
IDLE WELLS AS POTENTIAL
GENERATION FOR ELECTRICITY AND
ALSO STORAGE FACILITIES. SO I
JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT THERE.
I THINK WE NEED TO GET THE FACTS
OUT. A LOT OF TESTIMONY WAS
THROWN AROUND HERE TODAY. BUT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IDLE WELLS,
NOT ORPHANED OR ABANDONED WELLS,
WHICH THEY HAVE STEPPED UP TO
THE PLATE FOR. FOR THOSE
REASONS, I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL. I THINK WE NEED TO
REALLY FOCUS ON CAL CHEN, WHO
HAS POSITIONS OPEN AND CAN'T GET
THOSE POSITIONS FILLED, AND
THAT'S ON US THERE. IF YOU WANT
TO DO A BILL, THERE'S A BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET THOSE,
THEIR OBLIGATIONS FILLED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR DALLI.
SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK YOU. I'M
NOT GOING TO BELABOR THIS POINT,
BUT I BUT I WILL SAY THAT I ALSO
AM CONFUSED WHY YOU'RE GOING
AFTER JUST IDLE AND NOT ORPHANED
AND ABANDONED, BECAUSE THOSE, AS
WE KNOW, ARE THE REAL PROBLEM,
AND THE IDLE WELLS ARE ARE ARE
STILL PART OF SOMEONE'S ASSET
PORTFOLIO. I, THIS IS KIND OF AN
ASIDE, BUT I THINK IT'S RELATED.
I CO-OWNED SOME LAND, ON A CABIN
UP IN THE MOUNTAINS AND WILDFIRE
TOOK IT OUT A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, WE SOLD OFF OUR PART. I
THOUGHT WE SHOULD SELL OFF THE
WHOLE PIECE, BUT MY FRIEND
DIDN'T WANT TO SELL, AND IT'S
SITTING THERE, BUT IT'S HER
ASSET, RIGHT? SO HOW FAR BE IT
FROM ME TO TELL HER WHAT SHE
SHOULD DO WITH HER OWN ASSETS?
SHE'S MANAGING IT. SHE'S TAKING
CARE OF IT. SO TO ME, THIS IS
ANALOGOUS TO THIS, WHERE WE ALL
KNOW OUR BIGGER PROBLEMS WITH
THE ORPHAN AND ABANDONED. PLUG
11,000 OF THEM THIS YEAR. NOW
WE'RE STARTING GOING OUT TO THE
IDLE, WHICH AGAIN TO ME IS STILL
PART OF SOMEBODY'S PORTFOLIO OF
ASSETS. SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK YOU
THOUGH. THANK YOU, SENATOR
EGGMAN. SENATOR LAIRD, I JUST
HAD A QUESTION. AND, SENATOR
GROVE AND YOU HAD AN EXCHANGE
THAT GOT UP TO IT, BUT ONE OF
THE OPPONENTS SAID THAT THEY
WERE DOING ALL THIS WORK, AND
THEY WERE WORRIED. YOUR BILL
WOULD ARTIFICIALLY SET A LEVEL
OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING THAT WOULD
PENALIZE THEM FOR DOING IT.
COULD YOU RESPOND TO WHETHER
THAT'S THE CASE OR, OR, WHETHER
YOU HAVE ADDRESSED THAT CONCERN
IN YOUR BILL? YES, I THINK WE
HAVE ADDRESSED THAT CONCERN IN
THE BILL. THERE ARE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF OIL COMPANIES THAT ARE
OPERATING THAT HAVE, IDLE WELLS.
AND THE RESPONSIBILITY IS
GREATER ON AN ANNUAL BASIS FOR
COMPANIES THAT ARE BETTER
CAPITALIZED AND A FINANCIAL
POSITION. WE THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO KIND OF MAKE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN COMPANIES
THAT ARE REALLY WELL OFF
FINANCIALLY MODERATE COMPANIES
AND SMALLER COMPANIES, AND GIVE
THEM DIFFERENT TARGETS OVER THE
COURSE OF THE TEN YEAR PERIOD
FOR THEM TO, PROPERLY PLUG THEIR
IDLE WELLS. AND SO I THINK THAT
THE COMPANIES THAT WERE
DESCRIBED BY THE OIL COMPANIES
THAT ARE DOING A GOOD JOB SHOULD
JUST CONTINUE TO DO A GOOD JOB
ON THE TIME SCALE AND FRAMEWORK
THAT HAS BEEN CREATED BY THIS
LEGISLATION AND THAT THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE AFTER. AND
THAT STILL I'M A LIKE THEIR
DISCRETION TO CHOOSE TO USE THAT
ASSET IF THEY WANT TO PUT IT
BACK INTO PRODUCTION, THEY HAVE
THAT RIGHT. AND ABILITY TO DO
THAT UNDER THIS LEGISLATION. I'M
A I'M A LAY PERSON ON THIS, SO I
DON'T UNDERSTAND. BUT IF THEY
WERE INVESTING AT A HIGH LEVEL
AND THEY WERE FRONT LOADING ALL
THEIR INVESTMENT AND THEN THEY
DO A LOT WOULD YOUR BILL THEN
REQUIRE THEM TO CONTINUE AT THAT
LEVEL THEY WERE DOING, EVEN
THOUGH THEY FRONT LOADED, FRONT
LOADED AND SPENT THAT MONEY? NO,
IT IS A, YOU KNOW, TEN YEAR
PERIOD WITH A PERCENTAGE BY
YEAR, DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
THE COMPANY THAT THEY HAVE TO
PLUG, SO THAT OVER TIME THE
WELLS WILL BE PLUGGED, BUT THAT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THEM TO MAINTAIN
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF PLUGGING
THAN THEY WERE DOING PREVIOUSLY
IN RELATION TO THIS TIME PERIOD.
AND THE METRICS IN THE BILL, I
THINK THAT I APPRECIATE THAT. I
THINK THE QUESTION WAS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE IF THEY IF
THEY FRONT LOADED ALL THEIR
INVESTMENT AND THOUGHT THEY WERE
DONE AND THEN THE BILL REQUIRES
THEM TO DO IT WHEN THEY'VE SPENT
ALL THAT MONEY ALREADY, DOES
THAT DISADVANTAGE THEM? THAT'S
WHAT I WAS SORT OF TRYING. WELL,
THEY'RE, THEY'RE THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO PLUG THE BILLS OR
THE WELLS THAT THEY DETERMINED
TO BE, AND NOT ASSETS THAT, YOU
KNOW, THEY COULD CHOOSE TO
OPERATE A. WELL, THAT'S, THAT'S
THE CHOICE IS THAT THEY CAN TAKE
AN IDLE WELL, PUT IT BACK INTO
PRODUCTION. IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO BE PLUGGED, BUT IF
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
KEEP AN IDLE, WELL INOPERABLE
AND NOT WORKING, IT NEEDS TO BE
PLUGGED. AND THAT'S THE POINT OF
THE BILL. WELL, I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR YOUR BILL. BUT IF IT
TURNS OUT THEY SAY THAT DOESN'T
QUITE ADDRESS THEIR ISSUE. I
JUST HOPE YOU CONTINUE TO TALK.
I WILL CONTINUE TO TALK. I THANK
YOU WITH THEM. THANK YOU.
SENATOR LEHRER. HAVE BEEN
IMPROVING THE BILL AS IT WENT
ALONG. THANK YOU, SENATOR. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THOUGHT I WOULD
JUST RAISE IT. ONE FACT FOR THE
RECORD, I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
ON THIS AND THE IMMEDIACY OF THE
IMPACT IN YOUR BACKYARD. MR.
HART. LAST WEEK IN BAKERSFIELD,
IF WE'RE LOOKING FOR AN EXAMPLE
OF, A FAILURE OF WELLS NOT BEING
IDLE, WELLS NOT BEING MAINTAINED
ADEQUATELY OR MONITORED AFTER
TWO YEARS OF ACTUALLY MORE THAN
TWO YEARS, FROM A THERE'S A 20,
22 ORDER FROM CAL JAM THAT WAS
DEFIED IN THE FRUITVALE OIL
FIELD. BUT JUST LAST WEEK,
PEOPLE'S SPRINKLERS IN WEST
BAKERSFIELD STARTED SHOWING UP
WITH OIL COMING OUT OF THEM AND
GAS COMING OUT OF THEM IN THEIR
WATER. CAL WATER HAD TO
LITERALLY DISCONNECT THE ENTIRE
WATER SYSTEM FROM, FROM A
CONNECTION TO A NEARBY OIL FIELD
WHERE THE OPERATOR HAD NOT BEEN
HANDLING THEIR IDLE WELL ASSETS
PROPERLY. THEY HAD A BACKFLOW
INCIDENT AND A BUNCH OF METHANE
GAS SHOT OUT OF THEIR GAS FIELD
RIGHT INTO THE WATER SUPPLY OF
WEST BAKERSFIELD. NOW WE GET TO
GO TO COURT AND GO TRY TO CHASE
DOWN THE MONEY FROM SOME SMALL
TEXAS OPERATOR THAT GOT HOLD OF
THAT ASSET FROM SOME LARGE OIL
COMPANY YEARS BACK, AND A
SUBSIDIARY, AND SOMEONE WENT
BANKRUPT AND DIVESTED AND
DIVESTED. AND THEN SUDDENLY NOW
WE'VE GOT GRIFFIN RESOURCES THAT
CAL JAM IS THE STATE AND THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE TO GO CHASE DOWN
TO TRY TO MAKE THE CITY OF WEST
BAKERSFIELD WHOLE. BY THE WAY,
WAYNE VAN HORNE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL SITTING RIGHT THERE, IS
DRINKING OUT OF THOSE DRINKING
FOUNTAINS. THIS IS NOT BAD FACTS
. THIS IS BAD MANAGEMENT. AND
THIS IS A SUBSIDY THAT OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
PROVIDING TO THE OIL INDUSTRY
AND THE MOST PROFITABLE INDUSTRY
IN THE WORLD, WITH THEIR HEALTH
AND THEIR LIVES. SO NOT ONLY DO
I THINK THIS THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY, BUT THE MAJORS OUT
THERE, WHO LOVE TO POINT TO
THESE SMALL OPERATORS AS THE BIG
PROBLEM, MEANWHILE, WRITING DOWN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF ASSETS
LIKE CHEVRON JUST DID LAST
QUARTER. AND RAISING UP THEIR
HAND AND SAYING, WE DON'T HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS WORK
ANYMORE. I'M ACTUALLY ENCOURAGED
BY SOME OF THE WORK WE'VE BEEN
SEEING OUT OF CRC TO TAKE SOME
OWNERSHIP OVER SOME OF THESE
ASSETS AND START TO DEVELOP SOME
NOVEL APPROACHES THAT I THINK
ARE WORTH LOOKING AT, NOT JUST
THE ENERGY STORAGE UNDERGROUND,
BUT BUT ALSO, BUT ALSO LOOKING
AT CARBON CAPTURE. AND I DON'T
SEE THAT THIS BILL TAKES THAT
OPTION OFF THE TABLE. I WOULD
HAVE CONCERNS IF IT DID, BUT I
THINK YOUR TEN YEAR PLAN LEAVES
PLENTY OF ROOM FOR THAT. THAT
KIND OF MANAGEMENT PLAN, SO, YOU
KNOW, I GET THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF FIREPOWER ON THE OTHER SIDE
AND THAT EVERYONE LOVES TO BLAME
A STATE AGENCY. BUT THE BILLIONS
ARE WITH THIS INDUSTRY THAT HAS
CONTINUED TO SHIRK
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THESE ASSETS
AND USE THEM WHEN THEY'RE
PROFITABLE AND BAIL ON THEM WHEN
THEY'RE NOT. AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO LOOK AT IDLE WELLS, NOT
JUST THE ABANDONED WELLS,
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT
LEAVE WEST BAKERSFIELD AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES IN
VENTURA COUNTY AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND LA COUNTY, AND ALL
THE REST SO VULNERABLE. SO I'LL
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
SEYARTO. I HAVE A DIRECT
RESPONSE. THANK YOU. COMMENTS
MADE ABOUT MY CITY. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND WAIT. IF YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK, I HAVE A
QUESTION. SO IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS, GIVEN THE, EFFORT THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE TO GET
THESE OIL WELLS CAPPED, THEY'VE
DONE 11,032. HOW IS THIS GOING
TO MAKE IT GO ANY FASTER THAN
THEY'RE ALREADY CAPABLE OF DOING
AND PLAN TO DO IS THEY GOT
ANOTHER 2000 IN THE HOPPER READY
TO CAP, IS THIS GOING TO PUT THE
BRAKES ON WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING AND THEN HAVE TO RETOOL TO
BE ABLE TO COMPLY WITH WHATEVER
THIS LAW WANTS TO DO WITH THIS
BILL WANTS TO ACCOMPLISH HOW HOW
IS THIS BILL GOING TO MAKE IT
ANY BETTER THAN WHAT THEY'RE
DOING? AND I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE ANECDOTAL OR NOT ANECDOTAL.
THEY ACTUALLY DO HAPPEN. THERE
ARE INSTANCES WHERE SOMETHING
GOES DRASTICALLY WRONG AND
PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEIR ASSETS DO
THAT, BUT I DON'T SEE HOW THIS
BILL IS GOING TO, IT'S KIND OF
LIKE COMING IN AND, AND DOING
SOMETHING AFTER SOMETHING'S
ALREADY DONE. AND, AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS DOES ANYTHING BUT
COMPLICATE IT EVEN MORE. AND SO,
HOW WHAT NUMBER ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR? THAT'S THE NUMBER THAT
NEEDS TO BE CAPPED BEFORE WE
STOP TRYING TO MAKE THEM GO EVEN
FASTER. I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. AND I WOULD ANSWER IT
BY SAYING THAT THE COMPANIES
THAT HAVE, PLUGGED THE IDLE
WELLS THAT HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED
IN THE HEARING TODAY ARE DOING
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
FROM THIS BILL. AND THIS BILL
SAYS YOU NEED TO HIT A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE, DEPENDING ON THE
VIABILITY AND THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES THAT YOUR COMPANY HAS
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS. THE
MID-RANGE OIL COMPANIES HAVE A
DIFFERENT STANDARD, AND THE
SMALLER COMPANIES HAVE A LOWER
STANDARD. AND SO THE IDEA IS TO
PUSH ALL OF THE COMPANIES,
WHETHER THEY'RE HIGHLY
CAPITALIZED OR MODESTLY
CAPITALIZED OR VERY LITTLE
CAPITALIZATION, TO DO THEIR
SHARE OVER TIME. AND I SUSPECT
THE COMPANIES THAT HAVE DONE THE
REALLY GREAT WORK ARE THE MOST
FINANCIALLY RESOURCE COMPANIES.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE IT
CONSISTENT. WE DON'T WANT JUST
THE BIG OPERATORS TO BE PLUGGING
IDLE WELLS. WE WANT EVERYBODY
THAT HAS IDLE WELLS TO STEP UP
TO THAT RESPONSIBILITY. THAT'S
THE REASON FOR THE TIERING AND
FOR THE TIME FRAME TO MAKE THEM,
TO ADHERE TO A PROGRAM THAT
WOULD ULTIMATELY CLOSE ALL THE
IDLE WELLS OR RETURN THOSE WELLS
INTO PRODUCTION OR REPURPOSE
THEM FOR SOME OTHER PURPOSE,
THAT WOULD BE PART OF THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY PORTFOLIO. SO I
THINK HONESTLY, THIS IS JUST A
SIMPLE, PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
ISSUE. WE DON'T WANT IDLE WELLS
TO MIGRATE INTO THE CATEGORY OF
ABANDONED WELLS AND ORPHAN WELLS
WHERE THE STATE PICKS UP THE
FINANCIAL TAB. SO THIS IS THIS
IS SAYING RIGHT NOW, WHILE THESE
COMPANIES HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO THE JOB OF TAKING CARE OF
THEIR ASSETS AND TURNING THEM
INTO PRODUCTIVE ASSETS OR TO
PROPERLY PLUG THEIR ABANDONED
ASSETS THAT ARE LIABILITIES,
THEY OUGHT TO DO THAT. OKAY. I
THINK WE ALREADY HAVE A PROCESS
THAT SEEMS TO BE WORKING AND I
DON'T WANT TO COMPLICATE IT WITH
MORE BILLS ON TOP OF BILLS THAT
ARE ALREADY BEEN DONE. AND SO
I'M NOT GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY. BUT I APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SARATOGA. NOW,
SENATOR GROVE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADDRESS? I WOULD THANK YOU. THE
ISSUE IN BAKERSFIELD WAS A TEXAS
COMPANY THAT WAS HIRED BY AN
OPERATOR AND AN OPERATOR, THE
TEXAS COMPANY. WE NEEDED A
PRESSURE LINE TEST. THEY FAILED
TO CLOSE A VALVE. THIS IS NOT A
LEAKY WELL. IT'S NOT A POORLY
CONSTRUCTED, WELL, IT WAS A IT
WAS A CONTRACTOR THAT CAME IN
FROM ANOTHER STATE THAT DID A
PRESSURE TEST, AND THEY FAILED
TO CLOSE THE VALVE, WHICH CAUSED
THE OIL LIKE OIL CONTAMINANTS TO
GO INTO THE WATER. THEY FLUSHED
IT OUT. THEY ISOLATED IT, AND IT
HAS BEEN FIXED, I KNOW THAT CAL
GEM IS GOING TO FIND THAT THAT
TEXAS OPERATOR. BUT TO SAY THAT
THERE'S JUST THESE OIL LEAKY
WELLS ALL OVER AND CONTAMINATING
THE CITY OF BAKERSFIELD OR WEST
BAKERSFIELD IS JUST NOT A TRUE
STATEMENT. IT WAS A VALVE THAT
WAS NOT CLOSED. AGAIN JUST
CORRECTING THE RECORD FOR FALSE
STATEMENTS. IT CONTINUE TO COME
OUT OF PEOPLE'S MOUTHS, WHEN IT
ADDRESSES THIS INDUSTRY. ALSO,
THE COMMENT THAT THIS TREATS ALL
OIL COMPANIES THE SAME SMALL AND
MID-LEVEL PRODUCERS WILL BE HELD
TO A HIGHER STANDARD BECAUSE
IT'S ON A PRO RATA SHARE OR PRO,
A PRO BASIS SHARE, AND IT WILL
COST SMALLER OPERATORS VERSUS
LARGER OPERATORS A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY BECAUSE YOU HAVE
LARGER, LARGER OPERATORS WITH
LARGER RESOURCES, AND THE
SMALLER OPERATORS AND MID-LEVEL
OPERATORS WILL NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT,
WHICH MAY CREATE MORE ORPHAN
WELLS, WHICH IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT I KNOW WE WANT TO DO, BUT
IT IS SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
ONLY SET ASIDE. SO MUCH OF THEIR
RESOURCES EVERY YEAR WITHOUT
GAINING DRILLING PERMITS TO BE
ABLE TO PRODUCE INCOME. YOU
CAN'T JUST KEEP PUTTING MONEY
OUT THE DOOR. IT'S A SIMPLE
BUSINESS MATTER, AGAIN, JUST
WANT TO CORRECT THE RECORD ON
THE BAKERSFIELD STATEMENT FROM
MY COLLEAGUE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE, SOME MEMBER, YOU DON'T
NEED TO RESPOND, BUT IF YOU'D
LIKE TO, I'M NOT GOING TO. OKAY,
I WILL JUST CLOSE HERE BEFORE
YOU CLOSE BY. JUST NOTING THAT I
DO THINK THERE IS A PROBLEM,
CONTRARY TO THE STATEMENTS OF
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES UP HERE
THAT THAT WE ARE FACING IN THE
STATE, THAT THE CURRENT PROCESS
IS NOT WORKING. AND I UNDERSTAND
THE PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE. CERTAINLY, WE'VE MADE
SOME PROGRESS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS, FOLLOWING THE REFORMS
THAT INSTITUTED THE CURRENT IDLE
WELL MANAGEMENT PROCESS, BUT
EVEN AS WE PLUGGED, SEVERAL
THOUSAND OLDER IDLE WELLS,
THOUSANDS OF OTHER OIL AND GAS
WELLS BECAME IDLE AT THE SAME
TIME, THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CURRENT PROGRAM HAS REVEALED
SIGNIFICANT WEAKNESSES IN THIS
PROGRAM. AND SO I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR ONCE
AGAIN TAKING ON THIS CHALLENGE
OF ADDRESSING A VERY, VERY REAL
PROBLEM. I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH AND MEET WITH AND NEGOTIATE
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED. BUT WITH THAT,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
, HART, ASSIST. WE HAVE A
MOTION, I THINK, FROM SENATOR
STERN. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS.
JUDICIARY TO JUDICIARY,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR SHERMAN, I MEAN, I
SALADO. SALADO. NO. ALLEN.
DALLY. NO. DALLY NO. EGGMAN
GROVE. GROVE. NO HURTADO. LAIRD.
LAIRD I LIMÓN. PADILLA. PADILLA
I STERN A STERN I. THE COUNT IS
FOUR THREE. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMAN HART. AND YOU HAVE
THE NEXT BILL AS WELL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN, AB 2298, YOU CAN
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I THINK
THIS BILL IS EASIER. THIS PAST
APRIL, A DEAD GRAY WHALE WASHED
ASHORE IN THE BAY AREA.
SCIENTISTS FOUND THAT THE 40
FOOT ADULT WHALE HAD INJURIES
CONSISTENT WITH BLUNT FORCE
TRAUMA FROM A VESSEL STRIKE. THE
INJURIES FOUND ON THE GRAY WHALE
UNDERSCORE THE RELENTLESS
CHALLENGES THESE ENDANGERED
SPECIES FACE ACROSS THE GLOBE.
IN ADDITION TO THE THREAT OF
SHIP STRIKES, SHIPPING NOISE CAN
DISRUPT WHALE NAVIGATION,
FEEDING PATTERNS, AND SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS. RESEARCH POINTS
TOWARD A STRAIGHTFORWARD BUT
IMPACTFUL SOLUTION IN SLOWING
DOWN SHIPS. AB 2298 WILL
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
PROTECTING BLUE WHALES AND BLUE
SKIES, A STATEWIDE VOLUNTARY
VESSEL SPEED REDUCTION PROGRAM.
THE LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE
SHIPPING COMPANIES WITH FORMAL
RECOGNITION AND ENDORSEMENT FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
SLOWING THEIR SPEEDS TO LESS
THAN TEN KNOTS, REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND SAFEGUARDING
WHALES. AB 2298 WILL HELP
PREVENT BOAT STRIKES, REDUCE
DISRUPTIVE NOISE THAT HAMPERS
WHALE COMMUNICATION, AND LOWER
CARBON EMISSIONS ALONG THE
COAST. SPEAKING IN SPORT TODAY
IS ALAN ABS, WHO'S REPRESENTING
THE BAY AREA QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS ALAN ABS. I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICER FOR THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT, ALONG WITH THE SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND VENTURA
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICTS. WE ARE CO-SPONSORS OF
AB 2298. AB 2298 WOULD ESTABLISH
A PROCESS TO EXPAND THE EXISTING
VOLUNTARY VESSEL SPEED REDUCTION
PROGRAM, KNOWN AS THE PROTECTING
BLUE WHALES AND BLUE SKIES
PROGRAM FOR OCEAN GOING CARGO
SHIPS ALONG THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA COAST. I'D REALLY
LIKE TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR EXCELLENT ANALYSIS OF
THIS BILL. THIS BILL WOULD
RECOGNIZE THE DECADE LONG WORK
INITIATED BY THE SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND VENTURA COUNTY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICTS, AND
CREATE A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO
EXPAND THE EXISTING VOLUNTARY
VESSEL SPEED REDUCTION PROGRAMS
TO COVER THE REST OF THE STATE.
THE PROGRAM WAS CREATED IN 2014,
ORIGINALLY IN SANTA BARBARA AND
VENTURA COUNTIES, EXPANDED TO
PORTIONS OF THE BAY AREA, AND
HAS RESULTED IN INCREASED SLOW
SPEED TRANSITS FROM 30% OF SHIPS
IN ITS INCEPTION TO OVER 80% IN
2023. THESE EXISTING VOLUNTARY
PROGRAMS REDUCE AIR POLLUTION IN
COASTAL COMMUNITIES, REDUCE
UNDERWATER NOISE AND REDUCE
THREATS OF SHIP STRIKES TO
SEVERAL SPECIES OF WHALES, SOME
OF WHICH ARE LISTED AS
ENDANGERED SPECIES. OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN EMBRACED BY
INTERNATIONAL SHIPPING
COMPANIES, WHO ROUTINELY TOUT
THEIR PARTICIPATION AND, AS THE
ANALYSIS NOTES, EXPANDING THIS
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM TO OTHER PARTS
OF THE COAST AND RECOGNIZING
PARTICIPATION BY SHIPPING
COMPANIES WOULD INCREASE MARINE,
MAMMAL AND AIR QUALITY BENEFITS.
AND I'LL MENTION AGAIN THE
PROGRAM'S VOLUNTARY AB 2298 IS
SUPPORTED BY COASTAL AIR
DISTRICTS, THE MARINE SANCTUARY
FOUNDATION, OCEAN AND MAMMAL
PROTECTION GROUPS, AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. I'D LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL? METOO TESTIMONY. CHEN
WARREN. INTERFAITH CLIMATE
ACTION NETWORK OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY, SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU. BRENDAN TUIG, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION,
THAT'S THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS FROM ALL 35 LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ISABELLA GONZALEZ POTTER WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JOSH, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA
BARBARA IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU,
EMILY CAMPBELL FROM SANTA MARIA
AND LIGHTHOUSE BAPTIST CHURCH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BROCK
CAMPBELL, LIGHTHOUSE BAPTIST
CHURCH IN SANTA MARIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BALTAZAR
CONEJO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MARINE SANCTUARY
FOUNDATION, WHO ADMINISTERS THE
EXISTING PROGRAM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF
THE JUNIOR PHILANTHROPIST
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CHRISTINA SCARINGE
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION?
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
JUST ONE. ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE UP
TO FOUR MINUTES. IF YOU'D LIKE.
GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, SYLVIA SOLIS SHORE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION,
WE HAD A SUPPORT POSITION ON
THIS BILL, BUT DUE TO RECENT
AMENDMENTS, WE MUST REGRETFULLY
OPPOSE THIS VERSION. WHILE WE
SUPPORT VOLUNTARY VESSEL SPEED
REDUCTION PROGRAMS, WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL SHOULD OFFER A STATE
ADMINISTERED PROGRAM TO ENSURE
GREATER SUCCESS AND
PARTICIPATION. WE WOULD PREFER
TO SEE THE SET OF VOLUNTARY
RULES APPLIED STATEWIDE, RATHER
THAN TEN DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
ALONG THE COAST, RUN BY TEN
SEPARATE AIR DISTRICTS. SO THAT
IS OUR CONCERN TODAY. BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR BREVITY AND YOUR
POSITION, ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM, ME TO TESTIMONY.
OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS, WE HAVE
A MOTION AND WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM SENATOR SATO. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY,
BECAUSE JUST THE MAMMAL LIFE,
THE MARINE LIFE ASPECT ALONE,
MAKES IT VERY SUPPORTABLE. I'M A
LITTLE CURIOUS ABOUT WHERE THEY
ARRIVED. BECAUSE WE DO HAVE ALL
THE DIFFERENT, YOU KNOW, AIR
QUALITY DISTRICTS. AND, WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE TONNAGE OF
EMISSIONS, A SLOWER GOING VESSEL
THAT TAKES TWO HOURS LONGER TO
GET TO A DESTINATION AND WHAT
THAT PUTS OUT VERSUS A VESSEL
THAT'S GOING FASTER. WHERE DID
WE DO STUDIES ON THAT? SO WE
KNOW WHAT THE DIFFERENCE IN
TONNAGE OF RELEASE INTO THE AIR
IS. AND I'LL BET YOU THAT'S A
QUESTION THAT THE AIR QUALITY
PEOPLE KNOW. AND SO I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT THAT. YES, SENATOR, THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION, SO I'M NOT A
I'M NOT A MARITIME EXPERT, BUT
BUT SIMPLY SIMPLY SPEAKING, WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE SPEED OF A
LARGE SHIP TRAVELING THROUGH THE
WATER, THE AMOUNT OF POWER IT
TAKES TO INCREASE THAT VESSEL
SPEED RISES AT AN EXPONENTIAL
LEVEL COMPARED TO THE INCREASE
IN SPEED. SO, IN OTHER WORDS, IF
YOU'RE GOING FROM TEN KNOTS TO
12 KNOTS, IT MIGHT TAKE THIS
MUCH POWER. BUT IF YOU'RE GOING
FROM 12 KNOTS TO 14 KNOTS, IT
TAKES THIS MUCH POWER. SO THE
POWER NEED RISES AS THE SPEED
RISES THAT THE POLLUTION COMING
FROM THOSE VESSELS IS LINEAR
WITH THE POWER NEEDS OF THE
ENGINE. AND SO WHEN YOU GET DOWN
TO WHEN YOU START SLOWING THE
SPEEDS DOWN FROM 20 KNOTS TO 16
KNOTS TO TEN KNOTS, YOU GET A
DISPROPORTIONATE BENEFIT IN
REDUCTIONS OF AIR POLLUTION.
OKAY, OKAY. SO WE DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT WHAT THE DIFFERENCE IN
TONNAGE IS REALLY BETWEEN. SO
WHAT WHAT TO VARY. SO WHAT WHAT
I CAN SAY THOUGH IS FOR FROM THE
VESSELS THAT PARTICIPATED IN THE
PROGRAM IN 2023, WE'VE ESTIMATED
FROM THE REPORTING THAT WE
RECEIVED, I BELIEVE THAT IT WAS,
THAT IT WAS OVER, 200 TONS OF
NOX FROM FROM THOSE SLOWER OCEAN
GOING VESSELS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE ANSWER TO THAT, THE
OPPOSITION THAT WASN'T
OPPOSITION BEFORE BROUGHT UP A
VERY GOOD POINT, HAVING TEN
DIFFERENT AGENCIES DOING
DIFFERENT REGULATIONS AS THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET DOWN THE COAST, I
THINK THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
ONEROUS FOR THEM. AND WOULD
APPRECIATE THEM WORKING WITH
THEM, TO MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN RIGHT NOW. SUPPORT THE
BILL WITH THAT, YOU KNOW, HOPE
THAT THAT THAT WILL HAPPEN. SO
ANYWAY, THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR
ADDRESSING THIS. AND I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS FROM YOU.
THANK YOU. SO I THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE DAIS? OKAY, I WILL JUST
SAY I SUPPORTED THIS, WHEN IT
WAS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR, THE SAME TYPE OF BILL. AND
I SUPPORT IT AGAIN TODAY. I WILL
NOTE THAT I THINK THE OPPOSITION
RAISES SOME GOOD POINTS, BUT
GIVEN THE DOUBLE REFERRAL, THE
COMMITTEE COULD NOT POSTPONE
HEARING THIS BILL. SO I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. BUT I
DO HOPE AND URGE THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH OPPONENTS
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS WITHIN
THE FRAMEWORK OF THE CURRENT
BILL, WITH THAT, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH INDUSTRY TO FIND A PLACE.
THIS IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
THAT'S BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
SUCCESSFUL. WANT IT TO BE EVEN
MORE SUCCESSFUL AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMAN HART, DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL? OH, I'M
SORRY, SENATOR LAIRD DID IT
ALREADY. MY APOLOGIES FOR
GETTING THAT MEMORABLE MOMENT,
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL, AB
2298. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ASSISTANCE. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR MIN. I MEAN, I
CELADO I SURDO I ALAN DALLI.
DALLI I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I. GROVE.
GROVE I HURTADO. LAIRD. LAIRD I
LIMÓN. PADILLA. PADILLA I.
STERN. STERN I 880. THAT VOTE
COUNT IS EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYMAN. THANK YOU, WITH
THAT, WE WILL GO TO OUR NEXT
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN
BENNETT, FOR YOUR PATIENCE, YOU
HAVE TWO BILLS BEFORE US TODAY.
FILED ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2079,
AND FILE NUMBER 11, YOU CAN
PROCEED WITH AB 2079 WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. ASSEMBLYMAN.
TWO AFTER THIS. SO. THREE.
THREE. THREE. TOTAL THIS THIS
ONE. THE OTHER MINUTE. ONE. THIS
ONE'S GOING TO BE A LONG ONE,
THOUGH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS, THERE ARE TWO
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS THAT THIS
BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS.
AND ONE IS THE SIMPLE FACT THAT
WE HAVE SO MANY PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE FARM WORKER WELLS
GOING DRY BECAUSE HIGH CAPACITY
WELLS ARE BEING DRILLED, IN
PROXIMITY, IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
THOSE WELLS, THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
REASON A WELL GOES DRY, BUT IT
IS ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
REASONS. AND THE OTHER IS WE
HAVE SUBSTANTIAL LAND SUBSIDENCE
THAT CONTINUES, IN MANY PARTS
OF, OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS NOW
SIGNIFICANT AND SERIOUS. I WOULD
LIKE TO REALLY FOCUS ON AND ASK
YOU TO IMAGINE BEING A FARM
WORKER FAMILY WHO'S, WELL, HAS
JUST GONE DRY. YOU LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY WITH 25 OR 30 OTHER
FARM WORKER FAMILIES. YOU HAVE A
WELL THAT IS YOUR COMMUNITY.
WELL AND WHEN IT GOES DRY, YOUR
ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF YOUR
FAMILY, YOUR ABILITY TO GET A
SHOWER FOR YOUR CHILDREN IN THE
EVENING BEFORE THEY GO TO BED,
OR IN THE MORNING BEFORE THEY GO
OFF TO SCHOOL, YOUR ABILITY TO
COOK, TAKE CARE OF YOURSELF ALL
OF US TOOK IT FOR GRANTED THIS
MORNING WHEN WE GOT UP THAT THE
TAP WOULD BE ON AND WE WOULD
HAVE THE WATER THAT WE NEED FOR
THE BASIC FUNCTIONS OF LIFE. IT
IS ESSENTIAL. ONE OF OUR
ESSENTIAL TASK IS TO TRY TO
PROTECT PEOPLE WITH THOSE BASIC,
FUNDAMENTAL NEEDS THAT ARE OUT
THERE FROM INAPPROPRIATE THINGS
HAPPENING TO THEM. AND SO THE
SOLUTION FOR THE FARM WORKER,
WELL, THAT WE HAVE IN THIS BILL
IS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD. AND WE
EVEN HAVE A GREAT FLEXIBLE
OPTION. AND THAT IS YOU SHOULD
NOT PUT A HIGH CAPACITY WELL
WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF A
DRINKING WATER. WELL, NOT ALL
WELLS, JUST DRINKING WATER WELLS
THAT SERVE THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE OUT THERE. WE EVEN GIVE
AN EXEMPTION FOR COUNTIES AND
THAT EXEMPTION IS IF YOU'VE GOT
AN ORDINANCE THAT'S BETTER, THAT
IT WILL ADDRESS THE PROBLEM, YOU
CAN DO IT, THE SECOND ISSUE THAT
IS OUT THERE IS THAT THE
COUNTIES THAT ARE APPROVING THE
MOST HIGH CAPACITY WELLS ARE THE
ONES THAT HAVE THE MOST LAND
SUBSIDENCE IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO
IT JUST DOES NOT MAKE SENSE THAT
WE KEEP PUTTING MORE HUNDREDS OF
NEW HIGH CAPACITY WELLS IN AREAS
THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT LAND
SUBSIDENCE, THAT ARE OUT THERE.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT ALSO.
WHAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE TO YOU
IS THAT WE PUT THIS BILL INTO
PRINT IN FEBRUARY. WE HAVE BEEN
OPEN WITH EVERYBODY WE KNOW.
IT'S A BILL THAT HAS SIGNIFICANT
STAKEHOLDER INTEREST. THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES,
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY OPEN TO MEETING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS, TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THEIR CONCERNS, REALLY
TRYING TO ADDRESS ALL OF THE
ISSUES. WE'VE WE'VE HAVE
EXEMPTIONS FOR SMALL WELLS,
EXEMPTIONS FOR WATER BANKING,
EXEMPTIONS FOR, YOU KNOW, ONE
THING AFTER ANOTHER. THE MOST
RECENT EXEMPTION WAS THE
EXEMPTION THAT I JUST MENTIONED
TO YOU, WHICH PEOPLE SAID, YOU
KNOW, HEY, WHAT IF A QUARTER
MILE IS NOT WHAT WE WANT TO DO
IN OUR COUNTY? YOU YOU HAVE THE
OPTION A COUNTY HAS THE OPTION.
SO IF A COUNTY HAS NO
SUBSTANTIAL LAND SUBSIDENCE AND
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS COME UP
WITH THEIR OWN ORDINANCE. BUT
THE ONE THING THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE, THE ONE THING THAT
WE CAN'T COMPROMISE AWAY, IS, IS
TO DO NOTHING, TO SIT THERE AND
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT NEW HIGH
CAPACITY WELLS CAN BE PLACED
RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET FROM A
FARM WORKER COMMUNITY OF 40 OR
50 FAMILIES AND RUN THEIR, WELL,
DRY. AND YOU CAN DO IT WITH JUST
A MINISTERIAL PERMIT. THAT MEANS
IF YOU FILL THE FORM OUT RIGHT,
YOU GET PERMISSION. A HIGH
CAPACITY, WELL THAT CAN PUMP
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF GALLONS OF
WATER A MINUTE. NO REVIEW AT ALL
. JUST SINK IT IN THE GROUND
WITH A MINISTERIAL REVIEW. WE
CAN'T COMPROMISE THAT WAY. AND
SO IT'S IT. I HAVE TO I WISH DWR
WOULD HAVE MORE TIME TO TALK
THAN THE TWO MINUTES THEY HAVE,
BECAUSE THEY COULD MORE
ACCURATELY TELL YOU THIS STORY.
BUT THERE IS A FARM WORKER
COMMUNITY. THE WELL WENT DRY.
DWR WENT IN THERE, WORKED WITH
THAT COMMUNITY TO SINK THEIR
WELL DEEPER, TO REPAIR THEIR
WELL, AND CAN IMAGINE THE JOY ON
THE FAMILY'S FACES OF THAT.
FINALLY THEIR WELL CAME BACK AND
THEY WERE ABLE TO HAVE WATER
AGAIN, LITERALLY RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET AFTER DWR WENT IN AND
REPAIRED THAT FARM WORKER WELL,
LITERALLY RIGHT ACROSS THE
STREET, THEY PUT A NEW HIGH
CAPACITY WELL IN AND THEY HAD
LOTS OF OTHER OPTIONS. AND
SHORTLY AFTER THAT, THAT, WELL,
THE DWR HELPED THEM REPAIR WENT
DRY AGAIN. IT'S A SIMPLE FACT,
AND I THINK THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT POINT THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE TO YOU. IT'S A
SIMPLE FACT. THE POWERFUL PEOPLE
THAT CONTROL WATER IN CALIFORNIA
ARE NOT PROTECTING THE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND I WANT TO
REPEAT THAT. IT'S A FACT THE
POWERFUL PEOPLE THAT CONTROL
WATER ARE NOT PROTECTING THEM.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE IN SOME YEARS
, MORE THAN A THOUSAND DRINKING
WATER WELLS GOING DRY, THAT WE
HAVE THIS CONTINUED PROBLEM. AND
YEAR AFTER YEAR WE'VE BROUGHT IT
UP. WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AND THEY REFUSE. IT IS THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
FINALLY SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
AND WHEN I SAY IT'S THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY, WE HAVE COME UP
WITH THE MOST SIMPLE, DIRECT,
EASY TO WORK WITH BILL. WE
CONTINUE TO BE OPEN TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT ANY OTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT THAT THEY MIGHT
OFFER, THAT THEY HAVEN'T OFFERED
SINCE FEBRUARY WHEN WE WHEN WE
BROUGHT THIS UP. BUT THE STATE
MUST FINALLY END THIS CONCEPT,
THAT NEW HIGH CAPACITY WELLS
HAVE NO REVIEW AT ALL, JUST
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL. AND WHEN I
SAY THE STATE NEEDS TO TAKE
ACTION RIGHT NOW, TODAY, IT IS
YOU. YOU ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT CAN STAND UP FOR THOSE FARM
WORKERS TODAY AND SAY, WE WILL
DO SOMETHING TO TRY TO CHANGE
THE STATUS QUO AND SO ON BEHALF
OF THE FARM WORKERS WHOSE WELLS
WILL GO DRY IF WE TAKE NO
ACTION, WE'LL GO DRY IN THE NEXT
YEAR. IF WE TAKE NO ACTION, I
RESPECTFULLY HOPE THAT YOU WILL
LISTEN CAREFULLY TO THE TWO
WITNESSES THAT I HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, I
ASK THAT YOU SHARE WHATEVER
CONCERNS YOU MAY STILL HAVE.
PLEASE LET DWR ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS RATHER THAN HOLD ON TO
THEM QUIETLY. LET US GIVE US ONE
MORE CHANCE TO KNOW WHAT IT IS
THAT WE COULD SAY THAT COULD
HELP YOU AS YOU WRESTLE WITH
THIS. AND SO WITH THAT, I HAVE
PAUL GOSLIN FROM DWR AND KYLE
JONES AS THE TWO WITNESSES.
THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. AND SENATORS, PAUL
GOSLIN, DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
SUSTAINABLE WATER MANAGEMENT,
WE'RE PROUDLY SPONSORING THE
BILL. AND I DO WANT TO JUST GIVE
A FRAME OF REFERENCE. THIS IS A
DROUGHT RESILIENCY BILL THAT
COMES FROM THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT WAS ISSUED OVER TWO YEARS
AGO. AND IF WE REMEMBER, IT'S
HARD TO REMEMBER THAT WE WERE IN
THE THROES OF A DROUGHT THAT
HADN'T BEEN SEEN IN OVER A
CENTURY IN CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT
WE HAD, WHAT WE KNOW IS DURING
DROUGHTS, WE DO SEE AN UPTICK IN
DRY WELLS AND SUBSIDENCE. BUT
WHAT WE STARTED TO EXPERIENCE,
TOO, IS OVER THE YEARS, THOSE
RATES OF SUBSIDES AND DRY WELLS
HAS SYSTEMATICALLY BEEN RAMPING
UP TO NEW HISTORIC LEVELS. SO
SITTING IN IN MARCH OF 2022, WE
KNEW THAT SOME ACTION NEEDED,
NEEDED TO BE DONE. SO, AS
SUBSIDENCE INCREASED, THE NUMBER
OF WELLS, IT WAS, TAKING ACTION
TO, MINIMIZE THOSE IMPACTS. AND
WE'VE SEEN THE RATES OF
SUBSIDENCE TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE AND EMERGE IN NEW AREAS
LIKE THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY. A
LOT OF EMPHASIS DOWN IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY, BUT IT'S
STARTING TO SPREAD, AND THERE
NOT THE SUBSIDENCE IS NOT ONLY
COSTING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
STATE, FEDERAL AND LOCAL MONEY.
AGAIN, WE'RE STARTING TO CHASE
OUR TAIL AROUND, BUT CAUSING
CUTTING OFF OF WATER SUPPLIES
AND PUTTING THE PUBLIC AT RISK
FROM LEVEES AND THE CORCORAN
LEVEE IS A REAL GOOD EXAMPLE
THAT WAS RAISED IN 2018. TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN 2022, IT
HAD ALREADY DROPPED FOUR FEET,
PLACING THE COMMUNITY AT RISK.
SO IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A
HYPOTHETICAL PROBLEM WE HAVE.
IT'S A REAL WORLD PROBLEM
FACING, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE.
FRIANT-KERN CANAL IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WHERE WATER SUPPLIES
GETTING CUT OFF AT A TIME WHEN
SURFACE WATER DELIVERIES ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
SUSTAINING GROUNDWATER BASINS
AND WE'VE SEEN HISTORIC LEVELS
OF DRY WELLS SINCE 2020. THERE
HAVE BEEN OVER 3000 DRY WELL
REPORTS, AND THESE IMPACTS ARE
NOT LIMITED TO HIGH AND MEDIUM
PRIORITY BASINS OR CRITICALLY,
OVERDRAFTED BASINS. IN FACT,
WE'VE SEEN OVER 300 REPORTS OF
DRY WELLS IN LOW AND VERY LOW
BASINS SINCE 2000 AND EVEN
DURING THE WET YEAR OF 2023, WE
HAD OVER 600 REPORTS OF DRY
WELLS. SO THE SYSTEM IS
CONTINUING TO RAMP UP AND, WE'VE
HAD DRY WELL REPORTS IN 44 OF
THE 58 COUNTIES APPRECIATE IT.
AM I DONE? YEAH. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANKS. GOOD MORNING,
KYLE JONES WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER POLICY AND LEGAL
DIRECTOR. AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE AGUA COALITION, WHICH IS A
COMMUNITY OF IMPACTED RESIDENTS
FOR MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES IN
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND ON
THE CENTRAL COAST, INCLUDING THE
COMMUNITY OF DUCOR, THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED,
ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT AB 2079
TODAY. WE ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
PASS THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER IN
2012, AND WE SEE THIS BILL AS A
LONG THAT PROCESS TO GET THERE,
I WANTED TO NOTE AHEAD OF THE
HUMAN RIGHTS WATER IN THE CODE
IS ACTUALLY WATER CODE 106,
WHICH NOTES THAT DOMESTIC WATER
USE IS THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, TOO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN DENIED
ACCESS TO SAFE WATER. WE HAVE
SMALL, UNSUSTAINABLE WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE AT THREAT
BECAUSE THEY RELY ON SHALLOW
GROUNDWATER WELLS THAT ARE
CONSTANTLY AT RISK DUE TO
PUMPING AND NEW WELLS GOING IN
WITHOUT ANY NOTICE TO THE
COMMUNITY, WITHOUT ANY ABILITY
FOR THEM TO CONTACT THEIR
COUNTIES AND SAY, WE NEED DON'T
PUT THIS THERE, WE NEED YOUR
HELP, THIS IS IMPACTING PEOPLE
LIKE JESUS BENITEZ IN WEST
GOSHEN, WHO HAD A FARM WORKER OR
AN AG. WELL, GO ACROSS THE
STREET FROM HIM AND HE HAS TO
LISTEN TO HEAR WHEN THAT WELL
GOES ON, BECAUSE WHEN THAT GOES
ON, HIS WELL AND HIS HOME HAS
TROUBLE KEEPING UP, AND HE'S
WORRIED BECAUSE HE HAS ALREADY
HAD TO PAY FOR REPLACE PUMPS,
LIKE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MENTIONED,
COMMUNITIES LIKE DUCOR WHERE WE
FINALLY WORK TO GET STATE FUNDED
SOLUTIONS ONLY TO HAVE THEM
TAKEN AWAY FROM US BECAUSE THE
COUNTIES AREN'T PUTTING ANY
EFFORT OR CARE, AND THEY'RE JUST
CONDUCTING MINISTERIAL
PERMITTING OF WELLS. SO AB 2079
TRIES TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES IN
THE WAY THAT IS SHOULD BE
PROTECTED UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW.
IT STILL ALLOWS THEM TO DO
MINISTERIAL PERMITTING, BUT JUST
NOT NEAR COMMUNITIES WHERE WE
KNOW IMPACTS ARE LIKELY TO
OCCUR. AND IF THEY WANT TO
FIGURE OUT A MORE A NUANCED WAY
TO GO ABOUT THAT, THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT AND WORK WITH
A PUBLIC PROCESS TO GET AN
ORDINANCE THAT WOULD THEN GET
THEM EXEMPTED FROM THE BILL. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THIS IS ONLY
NEW WELLS. THIS IS NOT,
REPLACEMENT WELLS ARE ALREADY
EXEMPTED BY THE BILL. SO WE'RE
JUST TALKING ABOUT NEW OR
DIFFERENTLY LOCATED WELLS WHERE
IMPACTS CAN OCCUR. IF YOU COULD
START TO WRAP UP. YEAH, I JUST
WANT TO SHARE FOR Dð CORPS, THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ANY WARNING. THEY
JUST SAW THE TOWER GO UP AND THE
WELLS START TO GET DRILLED. AND
THEN THEY STARTED FEELING
IMPACTS. SO WE JUST ASK FOR
PROTECTION TODAY AND URGE YOU TO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY, DO
WE HAVE ANY ME TWO, WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL? THANK YOU.
MICHAEL. JARED, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURAL
NETWORK, WITH RECENT AMENDMENTS,
WE ARE NOW IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. WE LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE DEPARTMENT FOR
WORKING WITH US. WE BELIEVE THIS
WILL HELP STOP SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS FROM HAVING DRY WALLS AS
WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. M.J. KUSHNER, ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, KIM DELFINO,
ON BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY RAJNIKANTH WITH A
JUNIOR PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GABRIELA
PALACIO IS HERE AT CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MARQUIS MASON, CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS, ALSO ON
BEHALF OF NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL. THANKS. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. ARE
THERE TWO OF YOU? YES. OKAY. TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS, BOB REEB WITH
REEB, GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY WATER COALITION
AND OTHER CLIENTS, I WILL FOCUS
ON PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL THAT
PROHIBIT A COUNTY FROM APPROVING
A PERMIT FOR A LARGE DIAMETER
HIGH CAPACITY. WELL, THIS BILL
APPLIES A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH TO EVERY GROUNDWATER
BASIN IN CALIFORNIA, WHETHER
THAT BASIN IS ADJUDICATED IS
CLASSIFIED AS VERY LOW OR LOW
PRIORITY, OR IS BEING MANAGED
THROUGH A GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN APPROVED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. THE BILL'S PREMISE IS
THAT THE MERE ACT OF DRILLING A
WELL LEADS TO LAND SUBSIDENCE OR
INTERFERENCE WITH A NEIGHBORING
WELL. WE DISAGREE, AND I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR MAY ALSO DISAGREE.
LOOKING AT THE LEADING
DECLARATION OF THIS BILL, IT
STATES THE GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTION FROM LARGE DIAMETER,
HIGH CAPACITY WELLS CAN
INTERFERE WITH NEARBY DRINKING
WATER WELLS AND RESULT IN
IMPACTS TO CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM SUBSIDENCE.
SO THE BILL SPEAKS TO
GROUNDWATER EXTRACTION, NOT
PERMITTING A NEW WELL, WE
SHOULDN'T BE BANNING NEW LARGE
DIAMETER, HIGH CAPACITY WELLS
ACROSS THE STATE. WE SHOULD RELY
ON THE MANAGEMENT ENTITIES IN
ADJUDICATED BASINS AND BASINS
SUBJECT TO SIGMA TO REGULATE
GROUNDWATER EXTRACTIONS. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY PUT INTO
PLACE THE LOCAL MECHANISMS TO
REGULATE GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTIONS. WE SAY LET THEM
WORK, ONE FINAL POINT DRILLING A
LARGE DIAMETER WELL DOES NOT
ENSURE HIGH YIELD. IN FACT,
DOUBLING THE DIAMETER OF A WATER
WELL ONLY INCREASES THE YIELD BY
ABOUT 10. THEREFORE, ADDING A
DEFINITION OF STATE LAW IGNORES
THE HYDRAULICS OF LOCAL
GROUNDWATER BASINS, WHICH IS A
GREATER FACTOR IN THE AMOUNT OF
WATER FLOWING INTO THE WELL THAN
THE SIZE OF THE WELL. IT ALSO
IGNORES THE LENGTH AND
EFFICIENCY OF THE WELL SCREEN.
TRULY, WELLS ARE OFTEN DRILLED
LARGER, NOT FOR MORE VOLUME, BUT
TO ACCOMMODATE A LARGER PUMP
SIZE NECESSITATED BY BASIN
HYDRAULICS, AND YOU CAN START TO
WRAP UP FOR THESE AND OTHER
REASONS, WE ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. CHRIS ANDERSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES. AND
WE HAVE A POSITION OF OPPOSING
THIS AMENDED THE GROUNDWATER
MANAGERS THAT AQUA REPRESENTS
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PREVENTING
WELL INTERFERENCE AND CORRECTING
DECADES OF SUBSIDENCE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL WILL NOT
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS EITHER OF
THOSE ISSUES. THIS BILL WOULD
PREVENT APPROVAL OF CERTAIN NEW
WELLS IN AREAS THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED MORE THAN HALF A
FOOT OF SUBSIDENCE SINCE 2015,
OR ARE WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF
A DOMESTIC WELL, DWR'S REPORT
WHICH WHICH THIS BILL SPAWNS
FROM, DOES NOT RECOMMEND OR
JUSTIFY THESE THRESHOLDS. AND
IT'S HARD TO SEE HOW THESE
NUMBERS ARE ANYTHING MORE THAN
ARBITRARY. A HALF A FOOT OF
SUBSIDENCE SINCE 2015 IS NOT A
MAGIC NUMBER THAT CORRELATES TO
IMPACTS TO INFRASTRUCTURE.
ADDITIONALLY, BANNING WELLS
WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF A
DOMESTIC WELL IS AN UNWORKABLE
MANDATE THAT WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
EXPOSE WELL PERMITTING AGENCIES
TO LITIGATION. EVEN DWR'S OWN
DOMESTIC WELL DATA CONTAINS
INACCURACIES, INCLUDING THE
PRECISE LOCATIONS OF WELLS,
WHETHER IDENTIFIED WELLS ARE IN
FACT DOMESTIC WELLS, AND WHETHER
THESE WELLS ARE STILL ACTIVE.
ADDITIONALLY, ONE OF THE STATED
GOALS OF THIS BILL WAS TO KEEP
THE WELL PERMITTING PROCESS
MINISTERIAL AND NOT
DISCRETIONARY AS TO NOT TRIGGER
SEQUA. HOWEVER, AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT, THESE
MORATORIUMS MAY VERY WELL
TRIGGER SEQUA, WHICH WOULD
EXPOSE WELL, PERMITTING AGENCIES
TO LITIGATION EVERY TIME THEY
CONSIDER A NEW APPLICATION. THIS
BILL COULD HAVE BEEN A
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE THE WELL PERMITTING
PROCESS BY THINKING CRITICALLY
ABOUT HOW TO INTEGRATE SIGMA AND
LOCAL MANAGEMENT PRACTICES INTO
THIS PROCESS. UNFORTUNATELY,
THIS BILL IS A BLANKET, ONE SIZE
FITS ALL MORATORIUM ON APPROVAL
OF NEW WELLS THAT WILL HARM
LOCAL ECONOMIES AND WHILE
FAILING TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
IN FACT, THE LIST OF WELLS
EXEMPTED FROM THIS BILL, WHICH
IS A MILE LONG, IS A TACIT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT THESE
PROVISIONS ARE UNWORKABLE. WATER
POLICY IN CALIFORNIA REQUIRES
NUANCE. THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE
NUANCE OR ACCOUNT FOR LOCALIZED
CIRCUMSTANCES. IT'S A PUNITIVE
MEASURE AT A TIME WHEN GSA'S ARE
TRYING TO MEANINGFULLY CORRECT
THESE ISSUES, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE IT, IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUEUE OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO DO METOOS, IF
YOU HAVE A POSED POSITION ON IT,
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. THANKS CLIFTON WILSON,
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR SOLANO, SAN
JOAQUIN SOLANO DEL NORTE,
FRESNO, AND STANISLAUS, AS WELL
AS THE SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN
IRRIGATION DISTRICT, ALL IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CATHERINE
FREEMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, REPRESENTING ALL 58
COUNTIES AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE 40 RURAL
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. BRENDA BASS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. MARGIE LEE, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF FOOD
PRODUCERS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, TAYLOR
OCEAN, ON BEHALF OF A VARIETY OF
AGRICULTURAL TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, GAIL DELAHUNT WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, TRICIA
GRANGER, AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU, DEAN TALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. ANTONIO
ALFARO WITH THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT OPPOSED.
THANK YOU, ANDREA ABERGEL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. LILY MCKAY
ON BEHALF OF SAN LUIS DELTA
MENDOTA WATER AUTHORITY,
ELSINORE VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT, AND UNITED WATER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT IN OPPOSED
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, ALEX
BARRON, CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR, AND SENATORS
ROSANNA CARVACHO ELLIOTT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION, ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. IVY BRITAIN, NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. KENDRA DIOGO WITH THE
GUAYAQUIL GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COUNTY WATER AGENCY, KINGS
RIVER CONSERVATION DISTRICT,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS AND MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. JAMIE MINER ON BEHALF OF
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT, RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MELISSA
SPARKS KRANZ WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. THREE
OF OUR OTHER CLIENTS ARE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. AND THAT WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT, DESERT
WATER AGENCY IN SOLANO COUNTY.
WATER AGENCY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS. NOW, I DO
WANT TO REMIND YOU ALL, WE HAVE
A HARD STOP AT NOON. WE'RE NOT
ROLLING OVER. SO IF WE COULD TRY
TO KEEP THIS PORTION CONCISE,
SEEING NO OTHER. NO QUESTIONS,
SENATOR LAIRD. WELL, ARE WE TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, WHATEVER
YOU'D LIKE. YOU REMEMBER? WELL,
IT'S. WE'RE UNDER A TIME, THING
HERE IN IN. I THINK THIS IS
PROBABLY THE MOST COMPLEX BILL
THAT'S IN FRONT OF US TODAY. SO
I'M SORRY THAT THAT'S THE CASE.
I THINK THAT THE TO TRY TO
DISTILL THIS, MANY TIMES WE GET
TO DROUGHT EMERGENCIES AND I HAD
TO BE IN CHARGE IN A SIGNIFICANT
ONE WHERE WATER SYSTEMS WERE
DRYING OUT AND PEOPLE SAID
EXACTLY WHAT THEY SAID HERE
TODAY, WHICH IS WE CAN TAKE CARE
OF THIS. WE PLAN FOR THIS. AND
THEN WE WERE TRUCKING IN WATER
TO COMMUNITIES, ALL OVER THE
STATE WHERE THE WATER SYSTEMS
WERE GOING DRY, AND I THINK
WHAT'S TRYING TO BE DONE HERE IS
GIVE TOOLS, SO THAT THIS IS IN
ADVANCE, BECAUSE WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IS THERE WOULD BE NO
SELF-RESPECTING DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THAT WANTED TO SIT
THERE AND SUE THEIR OWN
CONSTITUENTS WHEN THIS WAS GOING
ON, WHEN IN FACT, THERE WAS A
DAY PREPARATION DONE FOR, FOR
WHEN THAT EMERGENCY WAS
HAPPENING. AND IT IS MOSTLY IN
DISADVANTAGED AREAS AND THAT IS
WHO PAYS THE PRICE. IF THERE'S
NOT THE ADVANCED THING. NOW, I
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL IS
UNBELIEVABLY COMPLEX, AND THERE
ARE CERTAIN THINGS I EVEN WONDER
IF THEY'RE THE RIGHT CHOICES
THAT ARE BEING MADE IN HOW TO
GET AT THIS. AND SO I, I'M NOT
SURE THIS BILL IS GOING TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT TODAY, BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE YOU THE CHANCE TO
CONTINUE WORKING SO THAT THOSE
THINGS WOULD ACTUALLY BE WORKED
OUT. AND AS WE SAID IN THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR, WHEN YOU
HAD A BILL ON A SIMILAR SUBJECT,
THERE IS A SENSE IN SOME PLACES
IN THE STATE THAT THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT MEANS WE TAKE THE
TOUGH STEPS IN THE MIDDLE OF
2039 AND THEN SOMEHOW GET IN
BALANCE IN 2040. AND IT REALLY
IS A SERIES OF STEPS THAT HAVE
TO BE TAKEN UP TO THEN. AND THE
ONE THING IS, IS THAT I THINK IN
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION, THERE'S
REALLY BEEN A, OH, SOMEBODY'S A
GOOD PERSON. AND SOMEBODY IS A
BAD PERSON. I THINK WHEN YOU'RE
MANAGING SCARCITY AND EVERYBODY
DEPENDS ON IT, IT MIGHT BE EASY
TO SAY SOME PEOPLE ARE BAD, BUT
EVERYBODY IS STRUGGLING AND THAT
HAS TO BE RECOGNIZED AS PART OF
THIS. SO I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL TODAY. BUT I RECOGNIZE
THE ISSUES THAT STILL, MIGHT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. I JUST
WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
WORK ON THEM. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SENATOR EGGMAN AND THEN SENATOR
PADILLA. I'LL BE BRIEF, I WON'T
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. I'VE GOT MY COUNTIES
AGAINST IT. I GOT MY INDUSTRY'S
AGAINST IT. I'VE GOT MY CITIES
AGAINST IT. EVERYBODY'S AGAINST
IT IN MY DISTRICT, NOBODY'S FOR
IT. AND I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY WE CAN'T DO THIS THROUGH THE
GSA'S GIVE THE GSA'S THE POWER
TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS. AND
THROUGH SIGMA, WHICH WAS
ALREADY, YOU KNOW, CONTROVERSIAL
ENOUGH. AND IT'S THE SYSTEM WE
HAVE IN PLACE. SO I'D LIKE TO
SEE US BE ABLE TO MAKE IT WORK
WITH WHAT WE HAVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
PADILLA, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. BRIEFLY AS WELL. I'D
ECHO MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS TO A DEGREE. I THINK
THERE'S SOME DEBATE AS TO WHO
THIS IMPACTS OR NOT. AND I DON'T
THINK THAT SHOULD BE THE METRIC
THAT WHICH WE LOOK THROUGH THIS
AND CONSIDERING OUR VOTE AND
COMMITTEE HAS TO BE WHETHER IT'S
GOOD POLICY OR NOT, THERE'S A
LOT WHERE YOU'RE TRYING TO GO,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT I CAN
SUPPORT, THERE'S A LOT OF
ELEMENTS OF THE BILL THAT I CAN
VERY MUCH SUPPORT, BUT I, YOU
KNOW, LOOKING AT CERTAINLY
SUBSIDENCE RESTRICTIONS AND THE
METHODOLOGY OR LACK THEREOF OR
RATIONALE OR LACK THEREOF OF
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
SOME OF THE PARTS OF THE STATUTE
THAT'S DRAFTED THAT EXEMPT
CERTAIN AREAS, IS COMPLETELY
UNCLEAR, AND THAT'S POINTED OUT
IN THE ANALYSIS. AND I THINK
THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY FAIR. IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
I KNOW I MEAN, WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF DIALOG IN MY OFFICE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AS TO WHY THE BLANKET
APPROACH. I UNDERSTAND THERE
MIGHT BE FISCAL ECONOMIES THERE,
BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO SEEK TO
ADDRESS THE AREAS THAT ARE
LEGITIMATELY PROBLEMATIC, THEN
WE SHOULD DO IT RIGHT. AND THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN JUST A
BLANKET APPROACH. I MEAN, IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
DON'T HAVE A MODEL STATUTE AS A
BASELINE AND THAT WE HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE DATA THAT DRIVES THE
DETERMINATIONS THAT ARE THE
BASIS FOR SOME OF THIS LANGUAGE.
AND SO THERE'S A LOT I CAN
SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO GO
I DON'T TAKE ISSUE WITH SOME OF
THE IMPACTS THAT YOUR BILL TRIES
TO ADDRESS. THAT'S NOT AT ALL.
THE QUESTION IS TO HOW WE GET
THERE. AND SO UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE OF THAT I HAVE TO STAY
OFF THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR PADILLA. I'M SEEING NO
ONE ELSE. I'LL JUST FINISH THIS
UP BY SAYING, I DO THINK THERE'S
A NEED FOR A BILL LIKE THIS,
DWR'S REPORT MAKES CLEAR THAT
THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS ON, WELL,
PERMITTING HAVE NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL, AND THAT, WELL,
PERMITTING JEOPARDIZING WATER
WELLS AND IN HEAVILY SUBSIDED
AREAS CONTINUES, I THINK YOUR
BILL TRIES TO FIND THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN LOCAL CONTROL
AND FLEXIBILITY WHILE ADDRESSING
A VERY REAL PROBLEM, AND APPLAUD
YOUR EFFORTS. I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY, AND
IF THE BILL DOES NOT MOVE OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE, I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP WORKING ON
THIS, MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT,
WOULD YOU LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR STERN, BUT GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT, I WOULD LIKE
WILL YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS?
I GUESS THAT'S THE OTHER
QUESTION. YES, I DO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. AND I
APPRECIATE THE FRANK DIALOG. I
THINK THAT THE POINT I WOULD
LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH BECAUSE
OR JUST A FEW VERY, VERY BRIEF
POINTS, ONE WE JUST HEARD AGAIN,
IN THIS HEARING, MANY PEOPLE
COME UP IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. WE DIDN'T HEAR ANYBODY
COME UP WITH THE SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM, THAT HAS BEEN FESTERING
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR. NOT
ONE SOLUTION, NOT ONE. DO THIS.
AND THIS IS HOW WE'LL SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. AND THAT IS THE
PROBLEM. THE FACT IS THAT THE
MOST POWERFUL PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE THE ABILITY TO COME UP
WITH THE SOLUTIONS, ARE NOT
DOING IT. AND SO I GREATLY
RESPECT THE SUGGESTION THAT WHY
CAN'T WE HAVE THE GSA'S DO IT?
THE GSA'S COULD DO THIS. THE
COUNTIES COULD DO THIS. THEY
COULD SAY, YOU CAN'T PUT A HIGH
CAPACITY, WELL, RIGHT NEXT DOOR
TO A FARM WORKER DRINKING WELL,
PARTICULARLY ONE WE JUST
REPAIRED. THEY SIMPLY ARE NOT.
AND SO IF YOU LET THIS BILL DIE
AGAIN, THIS YEAR, BECAUSE, BY
THE WAY, WE HAD A BILL THAT
SPECIFICALLY SAID ONLY ONE THING
YOU TALK ABOUT OVERLY COMPLEX, A
BILL ONLY DID ONE THING. IT JUST
SAID GSA SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SAY YES OR NO TO NEW WELLS.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK I'M HEARING
FROM SOME PEOPLE. RIGHT. AND
THAT BILL DIDN'T MAKE IT. THE
POWERFUL WILL KEEP SAYING, OH,
IT'S TOO COMPLEX. OH, IT NEEDS
MORE WORK. OH, IT DOES THIS, OH
IT DOES THAT. AND THEY WILL
ALWAYS BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
BECAUSE GROUNDWATER IS
COMPLICATED. AND THE PEOPLE ON
THE OTHER SIDE WHOSE WELLS ARE
GOING DRY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO LOBBY YOU. WEEK IN
AND WEEK OUT, DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BUILD A COALITION
THÀNH AND BRING PEOPLE FROM ALL
OVER THE STATE IN OPPOSITION.
OAN. AND THAT'S REALLY THE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE, IS THAT THEY
REFUSE TO COME UP WITH THE
REALISTIC SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM. AND WE'VE HEARD IT
AGAIN TODAY. UNFORTUNATELY EVEN
WHEN DWR HAS COME UP WITH AN
EXCEEDINGLY SIMPLE THIS IS IT, A
QUARTER MILE OR YOU DO IT
YOURSELF, I CAN'T THINK OF
ANYTHING MORE SIMPLE THAN THAT
QUARTER MILE BAND, BUT YOU CAN
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN A
QUARTER MILE. JUST DO IT
YOURSELF. AND YOU KNOW, WE'VE
HEARD WELL, THAT'S WHAT COUNTIES
DON'T WANT TO DO. AN ORDINANCE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. NOBODY WANTS
TO TACKLE ON THE MOST POWERFUL
WATER PEOPLE IN THE STATE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF YOUR STAFF, CHAIR IN TERMS OF
WORKING WITH US, I RESPECTFULLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF DWR TO
TRY TO GET THERE. AND THE MOTION
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMAN BENNETT, WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR STERN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MINH. I MEAN, I SEE NO ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE. DALLI. DALLI. NO.
EGGMAN EGGMAN. NO. GROVE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO. HURTADO. NO. LAIRD
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. PADILLA
PADILLA. NO. STERN. STERN AYE.
FOR ONE. 2345. OKAY THE VOTE
COUNT IS FOUR FIVE. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. ASSEMBLYMAN BENNETT,
YOU HAVE THE NEXT BILL AS WELL,
IF I ITEM NUMBER 11, AB 3162,
YOU CAN PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, AB
3162 IS A BILL TO PROTECT,
INTELLIGENT, SEA DWELLING
ANIMALS FROM UNNECESSARY
CRUELTY. THE TIME TO DO THIS
BILL IS NOW BEFORE AN INDUSTRY
STARTS TO FORM, TO FORM
OCTOPUSES AND. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR. AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME TO SUPPORT THE BILL
IS SO SAN MADAM AT AND NICHOLAS
SACKETT SUDAN IS FROM THE ANIMAL
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND, AND NICHOLAS
IS FROM THE COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION OAN. THANK YOU. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH, BUT IF
YOU TAKE LESS, THAT'S ALSO
GREAT. YOU GOT IT, GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SUSAN MADINET, HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND, ALDF IS A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 3162 BECAUSE
OCTOPUS FARMING FARMING IS
FUNDAMENTALLY UNSUSTAINABLE,
ENVIRONMENTALLY HARMFUL AND
INHUMANE. UNLIKE MANY OTHER
FARMED ANIMALS, OCTOPUS ARE
CARNIVOROUS. THEY MUST CONSUME
THREE TIMES THEIR WEIGHT IN
OTHER MARINE ANIMALS, LIKE FISH,
TO SURVIVE SO INTENSELY,
INTENSIVELY FARMING THEM ON AN
INDUSTRIAL SCALE WILL CREATE
ADDITIONAL PRESSURES ON ALREADY
POTENTIALLY DEPLETED WILD FISH
POPULATIONS. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS ARE
AFFILIATED WITH THE WASTE AND
TOXIC GASES SUCH AS NITROGEN AND
PHOSPHORUS, THAT WOULD BE
PRODUCED BY THE WASTE CREATED
FROM OCTOPUS THEMSELVES, AND
COULD HAVE DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS
ON THE SURROUNDING WATERWAYS.
AND AS AS SCIENCE IS CONTINUING
TO DEVELOP, WE HAVE LEARNED THAT
THAT OCTOPUS ARE HIGHLY
INTELLIGENT, SENTIENT BEINGS,
AND FORCING THESE THESE BEINGS,
WHICH ARE SOLITARY ANIMALS INTO
CONFINED SPACES WITH, OTHER
OCTOPUS COULD POTENTIALLY LEAD
TO STRESS, AGGRESSIVE ACTIVITY,
AND HARMFUL BEHAVIOR, THE CASE
AGAINST OCTOPUS FARMING IS CLEAR
AND COMPELLING. AB 3162 IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEND A CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT OCTOPUS FARMING HAS
NO PLACE IN CALIFORNIA, AS A
PROACTIVE PROHIBITION, THIS
POLICY WILL IMPOSE VERY LIMITED
COSTS TO THE STATE, IF ANY,
WHICH IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE CURRENT FISCAL OUTLOOK
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING WHILE
PROTECTING AN IMPORTANT MARINE
CREATURE. AND FOR THESE REASONS,
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OKAY, NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR NICHOLAS SOCKET
FOR SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION. INTENSIVE FARMING
OF CARNIVOROUS SPECIES SUCH AS
SALMON CAN CAUSE HAVOC ON
RELATED WILD SPECIES DUE TO
PATHOGENS. COMPETITION GENETIC
ABNORMALITIES AND OTHER FACTORS.
AFTER A 2017 DISASTER THAT
RELEASED 260,000 NON-NATIVE
ATLANTIC SALMON SALMON INTO
PUGET SOUND, WASHINGTON BANNED
THE PRACTICE. CALIFORNIA ALREADY
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR FINFISH TO BE
FARMED DUE TO THE NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AND
DANGERS POSED TO WILD
POPULATIONS. THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
EXTENDING THOSE COMMON SENSE
POLICIES TO OCTOPUS. RECOGNIZED
SEAFOOD CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS
HAVE ALREADY CONDEMNED THE IDEA
OF OCTOPUS FARMING, RAISING
THESE CONCERNS AS AS WELL AS
NEGATIVE WELFARE IMPACTS IT
COULD HAVE ON THIS COMPLEX
ANIMAL. IN 2021, THE UK VOTED TO
RECOGNIZE OCTOPUS SENTIENCE AND
EXTEND THEM PROTECTIONS UNDER
THEIR ANIMAL WELFARE LAWS BY
SUPPORTING A BAN ON OCTOPUS
FARMING, CALIFORNIA CAN SEND A
POWERFUL MESSAGE THAT WE VALUE
COMPASSION, SUSTAINABILITY AND
STEWARDSHIP OVER SHORT TERM
GAIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
AND KEEP IN MIND, WE HAVE FIVE
MINUTES BEFORE KICKED OUT OF
THIS ROOM. WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL
AFTER THIS. GO AHEAD. CHRISTINA
SKARINGER WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE HUMANE
SOCIETY, UNITED STATES. AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MICHAEL. JARED, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY, SORRY, CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR BIODIVERSITY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE MOVE. THE
BILL. WE MOVE THE BILL. I'LL
JUST NOTE THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT ALTER THE ABILITY OF
CALIFORNIANS TO FISH FOR WILD
OCTOPUS, EITHER COMMERCIALLY OR
RECREATIONALLY. I HAD A WHOLE
THING ABOUT HOW OCTOPI IS NOT
THE CORRECT PLURAL, BUT WE'LL.
I'LL SKIP THAT. THANK YOU. SO,
LIMÓN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR EGGMAN. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MIN A MIN. AYE. SALADO.
SALADO. AYE ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE.
DALLY. NØ. DALLY NO. SENATOR.
EGGMAN. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GROVE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. HURTADO.
AYE. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. LEMON.
LEMON. AYE. PADILLA PADILLA.
AYE. STERN. STERN. AYE I WANT TO
GO INTO DALLY. IS I OKAY? I
DON'T KNOW HOW. UNANIMOUS.
UNANIMOUS. OKAY. THAT VOTE IS
UNANIMOUS, AND THE BILL IS OUT.
OKAY, WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL
ITEM OF THE DAY, FILE ITEM
NUMBER 17. SENATOR PADILLA, ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT VÌ TÂM
SGR 16? AND I WOULD MOVE THIS
FINE BILL. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES. I
APPRECIATE THE INTERRUPTION. I'M
HAPPY TO WAIVE PRESENTATION, AND
I WOULD ONLY ASK ONE INDULGENCE
OF THE CHAIR, ONE OF MY WITNESS
TRIBAL WITNESSES DID FLY IN FROM
OUT OF TOWN. I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE CHAIRWOMAN ERICA
SCHENK FROM THE CAHUILLA TRIBE
AND SANDY BURROWS, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CACTUS CLOUDS, AND
GIVE THEM A BRIEF OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT COMMENT IN THE RECORD
BECAUSE THEY DID TRAVEL FAR.
THANK YOU. YES CHAIRWOMAN. THANK
YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU,
IT IS AN HONOR TO BE HERE.
MOYAMOYA. MY NAME IS ERICA
SCHENK, AND I AM THE CHAIRWOMAN
OF THE CAHUILLA BAND OF INDIANS,
LOCATED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
AS THE TRIBAL CHAIRWOMAN OF MY
TRIBE, MY RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
VAST. TODAY, I COME TO YOU AS
THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE KAWEAH
BAND OF INDIANS. AND AS A STRONG
WOMAN AND MOTHER WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PROTECT AND
SERVE ITS PEOPLE. CAHUILLA
INDIANS HAVE CALLED HOME TO THE
PROPOSED AREA OF THEIR INCLUDE
AND THE INCLUDED CHUCKAWALLA
NATIONAL MONUMENT. IN AN
EXPANSION OF JOSHUA TREE
NATIONAL PARK SINCE TIME
IMMEMORIAL. THE AREA CONTAINS
AND REPRESENTS THE CULTURAL
SPIRITUALITY AND THOUSANDS OF
CULTURAL PLACES WHICH WE PROTECT
AND OUR VITAL TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF OUR HISTORY AND OUR PRESENT
DAY OF THE KAWEAH PEOPLE. THE
KAWEAH BAND OF INDIANS WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THOSE
SUPPORTING SUCH A DESIGNATION
AND EXPANSION, AND PARTNER WITH
THE FEDERAL AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENT, AND OFFER CULTURALLY
OF AREAS AND TRIBES TO CO-MANAGE
AND STEWARD THIS AREA AS THE CæA
PEOPLE. WE WILL WORK TO PREVENT,
AND WE WILL WORK TO PREVENT
FURTHER HARM AND TO MITIGATE
EXISTING DAMAGE TO THE REGION.
THÀNH AND OTHER TRADITIONAL USES
AREAS. THE KAWEAH BAND OF
INDIANS ENCOURAGES THE PROMINENT
LONG TERM PROTECTION OF THESE
LANDS FOR CULTURAL, SPIRITUAL
AND NATURAL RESOURCE PURPOSES. I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT COR 16.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, ANY OTHER
SUPPORT WITNESSES? GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS SANDY HERNANDEZ
ORELLANA BARROWS, CONSERVATION
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR CONSEJO DE
FEDERACIONES MEXICANAS AND ONE
OF THE CO-FOUNDERS OF CACTUS
CLOUD INSTITUTE. BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE LOCAL
NONPROFITS LOCATED IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY, AND HAVE BEEN
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF THE
PROPOSED CHUCKAWALLA NATIONAL
MONUMENT DESIGNATION AND THE
EXPANSION OF JOSHUA TREE
NATIONAL PARK SINCE 20 FALL OF
2021. I'M A RESIDENT OF THE CITY
OF LA QUINTA, AND I GREW UP
EXPLORING AND HIKING THE NATURAL
BEAUTY SURROUNDING MY COMMUNITY.
SOME OF MY FAVORITE CHILDHOOD
MEMORIES TOOK PLACE ON OUR
BEAUTIFUL PUBLIC LANDS IN THE
DESERT, AND SPENDING TIME IN
NATURE IN OUR LOCAL DESERT WAS
ACCESSIBLE AND MORE THAN
ANYTHING, WELCOMING TO OUR YOUNG
IMMIGRANT FAMILY. IT WAS IN
THOSE MOMENTS WHEN OUR PARENTS
REMINDED US OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEING OUTDOORS AND CARING FOR
MOTHER EARTH, AND LESSONS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO ME AND WHY I
TRAVEL FROM THE COACHELLA VALLEY
TO BE HERE WITH ALL OF YOU
TODAY. AS A CERTIFIED CALIFORNIA
NATURALIST AND CLIMATE STEWARD,
I HAVE A DEEP UNDERSTANDING AND
APPRECIATION FOR THE EXTENSIVE
BIODIVERSITY IN OUR AREA.
UNFORTUNATELY, MANY, MANY PEOPLE
OFTEN THINK DESERTS ARE BURIED
AND LIFELESS, LEADING TO THE
MISCONCEPTION THAT THEY ARE NOT
WORTHY OF PROTECTION. THIS VIEW
IS INCORRECT AND UNFORTUNATELY,
THIS VIEW IS INCORRECT. DESERTS
ACCOUNT FOR MORE THAN 25% OF
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMASS, AND
NEGLECTING TO PROTECT SUCH A
LARGE PORTION OF OUR STATE WOULD
BE A MISTAKE. THE VAST LANDSCAPE
FROM MECCA HILLS TO NEAR THE
COLORADO RIVER IS ESSENTIAL FOR
SAFEGUARDING SOME OF THE MOST
INTACT AND UNPROTECTED DESERT
SOILS IN THE COLORADO DESERTS.
PROTECTING THESE SOILS IS
CRUCIAL AS THEY SERVE AS A
CARBON SINK, PLAYING A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN MITIGATING
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE PROPOSED CHUCKAWALLA
NATIONAL MONUMENT AND JOSHUA
TREE NATIONAL PARK EXPANSION
WOULD ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF PROTECTING
30% OF ITS LAND AND WATER BY THE
YEAR 2030, AND ADDRESS KEY
OBJECTIVES AND COMMITMENTS OF
THE 30 BY 30 INITIATIVE.
FURTHERMORE, THIS DESIGNATION
WOULD ALSO ALIGN WITH SECTIONS
TWO, ONE FOUR AND 219 OF AMERICA
THE BEAUTIFUL. THE RESIDENTS OF
WESTERN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. WE'RE OUT OF TIME AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANKS SO MUCH WITH THAT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, MR. CHAIRMAN?
THANK YOU. AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE COURTESY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL, FROM SENATOR EGGMAN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO,
APPROPRIATIONS. I'M SORRY. DO
PASS, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR MINH. I MEAN, I
SEE, I SEE, I ALLEN ALLEN, I
DALI. EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GROVE.
HURTADO HURTADO I LAIRD, LAIRD I
LIMÓN. LIMÓN I PADILLA PADILLA I
STERN A STERN I OKAY. 92999
OKAY. THE VOTE IS NINE ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT. OKAY. WE'LL NOW
REOPEN, GO BACK TO SOME OF THE
BILLS ON CALL, STARTING WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OKAY OKAY.
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
SOURTOE SERRADO I ALLEN. ALLEN I
DALI DALI I LIMÓN LIMÓN I OKAY,
THAT VOTE IS 11 ZERO AND THE
BILL IS OUT. WE'LL GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 460 BY
ASSEMBLYMAN BAUER C¢M, THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED.
THE JUDICIARY ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL, SENATOR SARDO.
AYE. OH, SENATOR MINH. AYE MINH.
AYE. SIERRA. AYE. ALLEN ALLEN.
AYE. DALI LIMÓN. LIMÓN AYE.
STERN. STERN. AYE OKAY. THAT IS,
WAIT. YEAH. THAT VOTE IS TEN
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. WE'LL GO
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB
2214. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
SATO. NO. SATO. NO ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE. DALI. NO DALI. NO. GROVE
LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE. 2882. THE
VOTE IS 8 TO 2. THAT BILL IS
OUT, WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
THREE, THE MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR KADO I KADO I ALLEN.
ALLEN I DALI I'M SORRY I HE SAID
I DALI I LIMÓN LIMÓN I OKAY THAT
VOTE IS 11 ZERO. THE BILL IS
OUT, FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
1359. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
Â C¯ ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR CIARDO I CREDO I
ALLEN ALLEN I LEMON, LEMON I
THAT VOTE IS 11 ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
SIX AB 1866. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO JUDICIARY ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ALLEN ALLEN. AYE, EGGMAN.
HURTADO NÓ. HURTADO. NØ. LIMÓN.
LIMÓN AYE. OKAY. 3456. SIX FOUR.
OKAY. THAT BILL IS. THE VOTE IS
SIX FOUR. THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY, WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN, AB 2298. THE
MOTION IS. I'M SORRY. WE JUST
DID THAT, DIDN'T WE? OH, NO. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO EK,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR AB 2298. ITEM SEVEN. YES
SENATOR ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE.
HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN.
LIMÓN AYE. THAT VOTE IS 11 ZERO.
THE BILL IS OUT, FILE ITEM TEN,
AB 2079. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR CADO. CADO. NO. SENATOR
LIMON. LIMON. AYE OKAY. ONE.
TWO. THREE. FOUR. FIVE. IT'S
FAILED. I'M SORRY. IT'S FIVE
FIVE. OH, STERN OR STERN? YOU
ALREADY VOTED. AYE. THAT VOTE IS
FIVE SIX. THE, THE BILL FAILS.
YEAH OKAY. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER 11, AB 3162. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PHYLUM 11. WHAT
DID I SAY? YES OH. IT'S DONE.
OH. IT'S OUT. THAT ONE'S DONE.
OKAY, FILE ITEM 12 AB 2196. AB
2196 Dð PAST APPROPRIATIONS IS
IN MOTION. ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR CIARDO Ã
CARILLO. AYE. ALAN. ALAN. AYE
LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE THAT BILL IS
11 ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM 14, AB 2285. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR CIARDO
NOT VOTING. SEN. ALAN. ALAN.
AYE. DALLY NO, HE'S NOT HERE
LEMON. LEMON. I ALL RIGHT.
123456789. THAT VOTE IS NINE
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. AND THAT
WITH THAT, SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.